TO RESPECT SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND THAT THOSE WHO WISH TO.
PHONE IN WE WILL PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO YOU AS WELL SO
WITH THAT SAID A LIST OF BEGIN
BY MENTIONING THAT FOR THOSE
WISHING TO OFFER TESTIMONY-
THEY CAN DO SO. BY ALSO CALLING
IN OUR TELEPHONE SERVICE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN AND IF THERE ARE
ANY CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO
GETTING ON YOU CAN ALSO. A CALL
OUR OFFICE THAT WE CAN HELP
ASSIST YOU IN GETTING ON THESE
VOICE SYSTEM WHICH IS. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE THREE
ZERO ONE. MEMBERS AT THE SAME
TIME- WILL RUN THROUGH THE
BILLS AT THE END. OF FOR
ADDITIONAL ADD ON SO AGAIN
WE'LL JUST DO THE ADDITIONAL
ADD ONS AT THE VERY END IN
CONCLUSION OF THE COMMITTEE
HEARING. MEMBERS WILL BE GIVEN
FIVE MINUTES TO PRESENT AND. WE
HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON CAN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH WE'VE
TAKEN UP AT ONCE TO WHICH- WHEN
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
THOSE BILLS- THAT ARE ON
CONSENT AB TWENTY TWO TEN
AGUIAR-CURRY. AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY THREE EDDIE GARCIA AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY NINE SALAS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE
STONE AB THIRTY EIGHTY SEVEN
BRO AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR
CHEN. AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY ONE
CHEN. AB TWENTY TO THIRTY TO
GRAYSON A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE MEDINA AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE OBERNOLTE. A.
B. TWENTY TWO FIFTY THREE LOW
AS WELL AS A. B. TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR WHICH IS A COMMITTEE
BILL. MEMBERS AS WELL OF PLEASE
ALSO NOTE THAT TWO BILLS HAVE
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR OF
THAT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
AB EIGHT THIRTY THREE THIRTY
THREE FIFTEEN. AS WELL AS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY FOUR AGAIN THOSE
TWO BILLS HAVE BEEN PULLED BY
THOSE RESPECTIVE AUTHORS.
HAVING SAID THAT THEN LET US
GET INTO OUR REGULARLY
SCHEDULED A COMMITTEE HEARING.
AT AND AGAIN WE HAVE A NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM SO BE
ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE WILL
GO IN FILE. ORDER THEN OF FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO. CARILLO THIS
IS A. B. TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT. THE SCRIPT. ALL RIGHT.
THIS THING ON ALL RIGHT GOOD
MORNING A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
2% AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
WHICH DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD TO CONDUCT A
STUDY. ON INCREASING THE
EXISTING POOL OF INTERNATIONAL
MEDICAL GRADUATES BY JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. CALIFORNIA
IS EXPERIENCING AN INCREASING
SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY POSITIONS
WHICH IS ONLY EXPECTED TO
INCREASE WITH THE AGING
POPULATION. AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT WAS ACTUALLY A
PRE COLD AT NINETEEN ISSUE THAT
WE WERE WORKING ON. THE
NINETEEN OF ONLY FURTHER
INTENSIFIED THE SHORTAGE OF
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HEALTH DISPARITIES
AT ALARMING RATES. AMONG
POPULATIONS ARE NOT THE KNOWN
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES AN
API COMMUNITIES FOR EXAMPLE WHO
LACK THE MOST ACCESS TO MEDICAL
SERVICES. LET ME KNOW
PHYSICIANS HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO KEEP UP WITH SPENT WITH THE
SPANISH SPEAKING POPULATION IN
OUR STATE ACCORDING TO RESEARCH
CONDUCTED BY THE UCLA. LP PI
WHICH IS THE LET ME KNOW POLICY
INSTITUTE THERE IS A RATIO OF
SIXTY TWO POSITIONS PER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND SPANISH
SPEAKERS ADDITIONALLY IT IS AT
THE MAYES ESTIMATED THAT THE
SCARCITY OF THAT THE OPPOSITION
THE CALIFORNIA HAS LED TO A
DEFICIT. OF FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
LATINO POSITIONS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO ACHIEVE PARITY.
WITH NON LATINO WHITE. THIRTY
ALSO SHOW THAT I LIMIT ENGLISH.
PATIENTS THOSE WHO HAVE THE-
CABLE PRIME CARE PROVIDER
BENEFITS PROVIDE. BENEFITS
FROM- POSITIVE HELPED OUTCOMES.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS SPANISH
SPEAKING POSITIONS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT PATIENTS I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE EFFORTS
BY THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD
IN REMOVING THE POST GRADUATE
TRAINING AUTHORIZATION LETTER
WHICH IS ALSO REFERRED TO AS
THE CALIFORNIA LETTER. WELL
THIS IS A GREAT STEP FOR A
GREAT FIRST STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION MORE CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED TO HELP WILL
DOUBLE POPULATIONS THROUGH AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT FINALLY
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING. TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD- OVER THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY IS DOCTOR ILAN
SHAPIRO WITH ULTIMATE- ONE OF
THE LARGEST COMMUNITY HEALTH
CARE CENTERS- IN MY DISTRICT
AND ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND SONY IDEAS WITH
THE UCLA POLICY AND POLITICS
INITIATIVE. AND TO LET YOU MAKE
A CORRECTION TO MY EARLIER
STATEMENT- THIS BILL WOULD
ACTUALLY ARE GOING TO AFFECT
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND JUST AS
A REMINDER TWO MINUTES- LIMITED
FOR WHEN. THE. MODERATOR A KEY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AFTER
SHAPIRO AND SONG INDIA'S. THIS
IS YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GREAT
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
YEAH WHEN I AND THE FAMILY
DIRECT OF YOUTH BACKING UP IN
THE MISSIONARY. LOCATED AT UCLA
WALKED FOR ALL AFFAIRS. IT IS
MY PLEASURE TO DO YOU ALL TODAY
THE MONTH HAVE THE MONEY. THE
PORT OF ASSEMBLY ONE. MEASURE
AB IS FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. AND TO
BE ABLE TO SHOW SIGNS FROM WITH
THE STUDY WHICH FOCUSED ON
HEALTHCARE POSITION RIGHT THAT.
I AM A WOMAN AND DOCTOR SHAPIRO
LATER THAN. THE COMMISSION
SHALL HAS BEEN THAT THAT WHAT
DOES THAT ARE IN MUCH BETTER
WITH NEED FOLLOWING UNDER THIRD
LANGUAGE SPANISH. OUR FLOWER I
AM YET AND- INTERNATIONAL MAN
GRADUATES I MEAN YOU'VE IN THE
WHO ARE BOTH UNDER BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF IN THEIR WE GET BUT
ALSO UNDER BECAUSE THE LACK OF
A BETTER BECAUSE. A VERY PLACE
TO HAVE THIS AND IT'S LIKE THE
AND RIGHT NOW NUMBER OF BORN.
INTERNET MEDICAL. TRAINING AND
PRACTICE EATING PAUL. MY BEHIND
US HERE STATE EIGHT THIRTY NEW
YORK FLORIDA AND ACCESS AB.
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT SIX BAD ACT TO
CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC WE CAN
CHECK PLEASE. ADDITIONAL KEY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YOU'RE
KIDDING ME EVERYTHING ABOUT THE
TOP EURO. HELLO YES THEY HEAR
YOU PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
THIS IS THE DISAPPEAR WANTS TO
DO THAT THAT THE BY THE. CHECK
OUT GOOD MORNING CARILLO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE LEADERSHIP AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
OF THE IMPORTANT DEAL. MY NAME
IS VICTOR LANZA BUREAU AND I'M
NOT THANK YOU CAN BE GET
CREATION AS WELL AS THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR FOR CALIBRATION AND
WHILE THIS NOT THAT MIGHT BE OF
SERVICE- AND WALDRON
INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL GRADUATES
AND WITH YOU MAY MAKE A
GRADUATE FOR I'M NOT WORKING
YOU RECEIVED IN MEXICO. A PART
OF MY EXTENSIVE EDUCATION I
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE SEVERAL MAJOR
HOSPITALS IN MEXICO. HE
STARTING MY TRAINING UNTIL NOW
FOR THE PAST FOUR YEARS I
THOUGHT THE THAT WE CAN I HAVE
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF HEARING
THE PATIENTS OF COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS IN THE US.
INCREASE THANK. RIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA EVEN. THE CALL THE
NINETEEN AND THEN MAKE IT.
CALIFORNIA WHAT ALL. A
EXPERIENCING A SEASONS. NUMBER
NINE HAS TAKEN OUR HEALTHCARE.
LIKE NEVER BEFORE AND ONLY THE
THIRD YUP THAT FORTY. FIVE IN
THE MAKE HAVE MADE HERE BACK
TO. CURRENT CENT WORK FORCE IN
MEET ME UP WOULD BE VERY REST.
IN FACT OVER NEW SOME ACTION UP
ON THE FICON ALTHOUGH TO VERIFY.
CALL TO TELL RESPOND TO THE
FROM THEM YOU CAN IGNORE IT OF
THE FOR FOUR. MAKING UNDER.
NINETEEN HAVE IN. HE'S VERY FEW
AND NOT WITH YOU O'DONNELL FOR
FORMAL THAT MOBILE CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND THAT BEING.
EIGHT EIGHT TO SIXTY FOUR AYE
DYING THE HIGHER RATE ACCORDING
NINETEEN UNDER WHITE AND ASIAN.
COUNTERPARTS I THOUGHT THE- I
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
CARE FOR THAT THEY TEND ON OR
ON THE- A COMPANY WHICH AND
MAKE YEAH WARNING THAT ARE OUT
IN OF THE EIGHTY TWENTY FOURTH
EIGHT YOU WERE MAKE UP THE ON
HOW WE UNDER IN FACT COMPARED
HE ENTIRELY. TO MAKE THAT I
WILL COMMUNE ARE. AND THANK YOU
Q. AND TAKING CARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
THIS IS THE PORTION OF THE TIME
TO WHICH INDIVIDUALS MAY SIMPLY
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES WITH NAME
AND AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO AGAIN A MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO. INDICATE THEIR
SUPPORT NAME AND AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO. TO INDICATE
YOUR SUPPORT YOUR PRESS ONE
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. THANK
YOU INTERNAL CALLERS IN Q. AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR THE NOW ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SHE
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. HERE NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. I WILL CLOSE THE
PORTION THEN ADD TO ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT YEAH IN THE
IN THE CHAMBERS. AND
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN THE CHAMBERS. AND.
J. N. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TESTIFYING OPPOSITION-
THE SCENE THEN LET ME ALSO JUST
A PAUSE FOR A MOMENT AS WE'VE
JUST ESTABLISHED A QUORUM SOAK
UP MISTER SECTOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE STOP SCORE. HERE. AND
THE- THERE. FONG. GIPSON GLORIA
GRAYSON. HOLDEN IRWIN. MCCARTY
MEDINA. MULLIN OBERNOLTE. TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
STUFF THE CORM- THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION THAT IS OUR SECOND HAS
BEEN A MOTION A SECOND ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME. ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHECK.
THANK YOU MISTER CAREFULLY
PRECIADO- THE INDULGENCE I JUST
WANT TO COMMAND- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM WILL HEIGHTS FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND INNOVATION ON
THIS BILL- I THINK WITH
PANDEMIC WITH KOBE NINETEEN
IT'S MORE FOR NEVER THAT WE
INCREASE OUR HEALTH CARE PACKED
BASS CITY. AND THE STARS WITH
THE PEOPLE SO INCREASING NUMBER
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS IN
THE INDUSTRY IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT SPECIAL WITH THE
LANGUAGE- ABILITY OF HAVING NOT
ONLY ENGLISH BUT ALSO SPANISH
SPEAKING. HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS I WOULD FORTY
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND- BNP
BUT ALSO WITH SUPPORTING. THIS
AMAZING BILL ON THE ASSEMBLY
FOR SO THANK YOU AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM. LOS ANGELES
BALL HEIGHTS FOR LEADERSHIP AND
INNOVATION. IN THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AT ASSEMBLY
WOMAN EGGMAN. GOOD MORNING AND-
I AM SORRY I MISSED PART OF THE
PRESENTATION OF MY CONCERT OF
MY CONCERN WITH ALL BILL'S
GOING FORWARD RIGHT NOW IS- THE
ISSUE AROUND IS IT IS IT
RELEVANT IN THIS MOMENT- SOME
OF THE BEST BILLS WITH PAUL LET
GO BILLS THIS YEAR BECAUSE IS
IT RELEVANT IN THIS MOMENT. AND
SO I GUESS MY CONCERN IS THE
MEDICAL BOARD WHO WE ARE
CHARGING TO DO THE STUDY IS
SAYING THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO THE STUDY. AND
WE KNOW THAT EVERYBODY BUDGETS
ARE GOING TO BE CUT SO IS THERE
A PRESSING ISSUE MATH AND RIGHT
NOW TO TELL A BOARD TO DO A
STUDY THAT THEY'RE TELLING US
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES NOW TO DO WHEN WE
KNOW FUTURE BUDGET CUTS ARE
DOING AND WHY THAT'S IMPORTANT.
IN THIS MOMENT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- LET ME
ADDRESS THAT SO THIS BILL IS
THE THING. COMMITTEE IN
PARTICULAR IS LOOKING AT THE
POLICY ASPECT OF IT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION APPROPRIATIONS
WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY DISCUSS
THE FISCAL IMPACT. THAT IT
WOULD HAVE- BUT LET ME LET ME
SHARE SOME SOME ADDITIONAL-
CONCERN- THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP IN MY TIME IN YOUR TIME HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE. EVERY TIME
DOCTORS COME AND VISIT.
SACRAMENTO THEY TELL IS A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT THINGS THE
COST OF THE MEDICAL EDUCATION
IS EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE BURDEN OF
STUDENT LOANS IS EVEN HIGHER-
IT IS HARD TO PRACTICE AND BE A
DOCTOR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE COST.
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
ACTUALLY LEAVING THE STATE. IF
YOU ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO BE BILINGUAL REGARDLESS
OF WHAT IS IN THE CITY YOU ARE-
YOU KNOW THAT THE DEMAND FOR
SPANISH. LANGUAGE MEDICAL CARE
IS THAT THE HIGHEST- IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LATINOS ARE
ACTUALLY THE HIGHEST
POPULATION. ACROSS OUR STATE IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES LIKE YOURS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN YOU KNOW
FIRST HAND. THAT THERE IS A
NEED FOR RULE ACCESS- LANGUAGE
AND CULTURE COMPANIES. THIS
BILL HELPS TO ESTABLISH A STUDY
THAT ALLOWS FOR US TO STATE
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE
HAVE THE FOUNDATION NECESSARY
THE STUDY NECESSARY TO MOVE
FORWARD AND ALLOW
INTERNATIONAL. MEDICAL
GRADUATES TO BE ABLE TO
PRACTICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN A WAY THAT. HELPS
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
HELP CHIEF MEDICAL PARITY THAT
INCLUDES CULTURAL AND LANGUAGE
COMPETENCY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA. I'LL
BE BRIEF MISTER CHAIR JUST AS
THIS IS OUR FIRST BILL BUT DID
WANT TO SAY ONE OF THE THINGS
DURING COPA NINETEEN WE WILL
FIND IS THERE ARE DISPARITIES
AMONGST. CERTAIN RACES AND AS
WE LOOK AT THOSE DISPARITIES
ONE OF THE BEST WAYS WE CAN
HELP TO- ALLEVIATE THAT IS TO
HAVE CULTURALLY COMPETENT AND
POLITICALLY COMPETENT PROVIDERS
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS DO YOU THINK THIS
BILL HELPS US TO HAVE MORE
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT. PROVIDERS SO THAT WE
CAN START TO ADDRESS WHAT HAS
BEEN A SYSTEMIC ISSUE WITH
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH CARE IN
OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
REMEMBER YEAH ABSOLUTELY I
THINK THIS BILL SET THE
FOUNDATION OF WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW. THIS IS ESTABLISHING THE
FACTS FOR US TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH LEGISLATION IN THE
FUTURE THAT ACTUALLY ALLOWS.
FOR INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL
GRADUATES TO PRACTICE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I WOULD
LOVE TO BE ABLE TO RUN THE BILL
NOW THAT SAYS WE NEED THIS WE
NEED THIS RIGHT NOW BUT WHAT
ARE WE GONNA COME ACROSS WE
DON'T HAVE THE FACTS WE DON'T
HAVE THE STUDY WE HAVEN'T DONE
ANYTHING ABOUT IT. SO LET'S
LET'S DO IT LET'S SET UP WHAT
WE NEED TO SET UP TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS CULTURAL LANGUAGE
COMPETENCY AND MEDICAL CARE AND
ACCESS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE WE ALLOW.
DOCTORS TO BE ABLE TO PRACTICE
IN OUR STATE AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL TAKE
THATAS A CLOSE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. I SEE NONE AND CONSISTENT
WITH THE CONVERSATION THAT YOU
AND I BOTH HAD ABOUT THE INTENT
IN TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN BUILD OFF OF THIS. EVENT IN
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE- AND WITH
THAT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
A SECOND MISTER SPEAKER WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS LEFT BY. LOW AYE
PEROT. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
BLOOM. TEN CHEN I'D TO
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I FONG. GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
AT ELEVEN VOTES THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MEMBERS THE JUST GO GO BACK
INTO JUSTIT HAS CAME BACK ON
CONSENT CALENDAR CLEAR THE
MOTION FOR A CONSENT. THE
MOTION IS A SITE IS AND SECOND.
BECAUSE SECTOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI
LOW HI BRO. ARAMBULA BLOOM. TEN
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE FONG. GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GLORIA. GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN WHEN I
IT MCCARTY. MEDINA. MEDINA I AM
MULLIN. OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
TING. AND TO CONFIRM THAT WAS
A. B. THAT WAS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BEGIN WITH THAT YES
CONTENT GALLAGHER. ELEVEN VOTES
THAT WASN'T. IN THE CONSENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- A BELIEF
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THEN MEMBERS WILL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU THIS IS
AB. THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE. THIS
WAS CHIU WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
RIGHT. WELL GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
FIRST I WANT TO- THINK THE
CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING ON THIS BILL WOULD WITH
US AB THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE
FLOW IMPROVED TO TRANSPARENCY.
FULL CONSUMERS BY REQUIRING
THAT THOSE WHO AVERAGE HEIGHT
HE'S SHORT TERM LODGING OR
RENTAL TO INCLUDE ALL OF THEIR
FEES AND THEY ARE ADVERTISED
RATE UP FRONT. CALIFORNIA LAW
MAKES IT ILLEGAL FOR ANY
BUSINESS TO BE UNTRUE.
DECEPTIVE OR MISLEADING THING
ADVERTISEMENT FOR GOOD OR
SERVICE. AB THIRTY TO THIRTY
FIVE IS NOTHING BUT A BUYER BE
AWARE LAW TO CLARIFY- THAT THE
EXISTING LAW. THE INTENT IS TO
REDUCE THE UNPLEASANT SURPRISES
FOR THE CUSTOMERS OF CONSUMERS.
AND TO REDUCE THE- UNNECESSARY
LOSS WHO ALSO TO REDUCE THE
TIME THAT WE SPEND ON BOOKING
IN THE ROOF THE HOTEL ROOM THIS
IS I KNOW THIS IS NOT. IT AND
BY ANY MEANS TO REDUCE DEFEAT
THEY'RE AT THE DATA ON THE
CHARGE TO THE CUSTOMER. I KNOW
THAT DOING THIS A PANDEMIC IS
HAS TO HOTEL THE SERVICE
INDUSTRY REALLY REALLY BAD AND
I WILL ACTUALLY WILL BE
SUPPORTING A DISASTER RELIEF
SURCHARGE FOR THEM IF IT
DOESN'T TAKE FROM FOUR YEAR TO
IMPLEMENT THAT. THEN THIS BILL
IS ALSO A FEAR OF PRACTICE
BILLS BECAUSE SOME OFTEN DO
THEY DO- ADVERTISED THEIR THEIR
DEAR RATE UP FRONT. AND SO TO
MAKE IT INTO- COULD BE MORE
FAIR TO THOSE WHO ALREADY HAVE
A FOLLOWING THE LAW DO WHAT I'M
DOING THAT. AND JUST BILL WILL
PROVIDE A FEAR OF COMPETITION.
THIS IS BILL. DEFINITELY WILL
NOT INFLUENCE WHATEVER THE AG
AND HOW THEY INTERPRETED THE
CURRENT LAW. SO WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
ROBERT CARO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA WHO'S
ALSO THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE- YOUR WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS
HERE IN THE GYM IS THAT CORRECT
IN PERSON RIGHT. IS THAT AFRICA
IS THE IS THE PERSON IN PERSON
HERE. ARE ACCORDING TO THE
NOTES OR IS THIS GOING TO BE ON
CALL I'M SORRY IF THE WITH
THEIR WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS
THAT INDIVIDUAL HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS PHYSICALLY. ACCORDING
TO THE NOTES I HAVE IT IT'S IN
PERSON OR IS IT THE GENTLEMAN
WILL BE CALLING IN SUPPORT. OF
HER QUESTION I DON'T KNOW WHERE
ARE YOU ROBERT. WE CAN- THEN
THE I'M ON THE PHONE OKAY. AS
OLD LAN- FOR OUR FOR THIS
PURPOSE AGAIN AT TWO MINUTES-
UP TO TWO MINUTES FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ROBERT CORRAL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA WITH THE
SPONSORS OF AB THIRTY TO THIRTY
FIVE. I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS ISSUE
AND COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
CHAIRMAN FOR A THOROUGH
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL. AB THREE
TO THIRTY FIVE IS BASED ON THE
SIMPLE IDEA THAT CONSUMERS
DESERVE TO TRANSPARENT WE KNOW
THE FOR TRUE PRICE OF THEIR
LODGING OPTIONS BEFORE MAKING A
PURCHASE THE DECISION. CHARGING
MANDATORY FUSE BUT NOT
INCLUDING THEM IN THE ADVERTISE
ROOM CRISIS IS KNOWN AS TRIP
PRICING AND IT IS DECEPTIVE.
THE MOST COMMON OF THESE FEES
ARE KNOWN AS RESORT FEES BUT
THEY GO BY MANY OTHER NAMES
INCLUDING URBAN DESTINATION
FEES DALY MANDATORY CHARGES.
SOME CLEAN FUELS ALSO UPON THIS
CATEGORY BUT NO MATTER WHAT
THEY'RE CALLED THE CREATE THE
FALSE IMPRESSION THAT A ROOM
COST LESS THAN IT ACTUALLY
DOES. IT'S THE HOTEL INDUSTRY
VERSION OF SURPRISE BILLING AND
IT MAKES THEM THREE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. WE WORK IN GOOD
FAITH WITH ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES AS A RESULT THE BILL
WAS AMENDED TO REFLECT CHANGES
SUGGESTED BY THE HG AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL WITH THE
WAY IT'S IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL
JULY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. YOU TO
COVER NINETEEN. PEOPLE TO THE
BILL WILL ACTIVELY SUGGEST THAT
THE BILL HAS SUDDENLY BECOME
RETROACTIVE BECAUSE WE ARE
CLARIFYING THE LAW. HOWEVER THE
BILL ACTUALLY HELPS THE LODGING
INDUSTRY IN THE LONG RUN
BECAUSE THAT LAYS OUT HOW ROOM
PRICES SHOULD BE ADVERTISED.
THE EASIEST WAY TO AVOID ANY
CONSUMER CONFUSION THE CLEARLY
ADVERTISED THE ACTUALPRICE OF
THE ROOM FROM THE BEGINNING NOT
THE END OF A MULTI STEP.
PROCESS ALLOW ME TO CLOSE BY
QUOTING REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
JEFF FORTENBERRY UP THE BRASS
GOT A CO  HOR
LEGISLATION TO AND- PRICING HE
SAYS QUOTE WHEN TRAVELERS
SEARCH FOR HOTEL OPTIONS THEY
DESERVE TO SEE STRAIGHT FOR
CRISIS. THEY SHOULD NOT GET HIT
WITH HIDDEN FEES THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO CONFUSE CONSUMERS
ON THE START THE ACTUAL PRICE
ON QUOTE. I COULDN'T AGREE MORE
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
CALIFORNIA PURCHASE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY TO THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I HAVE NO OTHER TO WIND.
LOW IN SUPPORT BUT MAY
MODERATOR THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
CALLERS WISHING TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT. OF AGAIN NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO FOR MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. IN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THAN ZERO. WE HAVE A FEW
LINES IN Q. WILL GO FIRST
ONLINE SIX FIVE SIXTY FIVE
NUCLEAR AND. YES GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
DANIELLE CANDOR CARTER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY EIGHT TO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU TERRY
MEMBERS TODAY MARTIN DEL
CONSUMER REPORTS WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE REQUEST
NIGHT THAT. ONE ADDITIONAL LINE
IN QUEUES. FIND SIXTY SIX SIX
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REBEKAH
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU KNOW AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR NO FOR THE
ALLIANCE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR WILL NOW
GO TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE LISTED HERE IT IN
PERSON- WHEN HE SAYS IT IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU. MIGHT BE
ABLE TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE
AND AGAIN UP TO TWO MINUTES
PLEASE FEEL FREE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOHN CALDWELL ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION HERE'S HOW THE
DISCLOSURE OF THESE FEES WORKS
TODAY OR THEY DID PRIOR TO
THESE RESORTS ALL BEING SHUT
DOWN. WHEN YOU ENTER THE DATE
OF YOUR STAY AND THE TYPE OF
ROOM SUITE DOUBLE BEDS KING
QUEEN YOU'LL GET THE ACTUAL
PRICE OF THE STATE. THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WHAT THE
SYSTEM CHANGE TO MAKE IT MORE
CONVENIENT. THEY WANT THE FULL
PRICE INCLUDED BEFORE YOU
CHOOSE THE ROOM TYPE. NOW THIS
WILL REQUIRE COSTLY PROGRAMMING
CHANGE FOR MOST RESERVATION
SYSTEMS MORE THAN ELEVEN
HUNDRED HOTELS IN THIS STATE
HAVE CLOSED SINCE THIS BILL WAS
INTRODUCED IN VIRTUALLY ALL THE
HOTELS WHO CHARGE THESE FEES
ARE CLOSED. WE SIMPLY DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR SUCH A
CHANGE THE COMMITTEE RECOGNIZED
THE PROBLEM AND PUSHED BOTH OF
US FOR A COMPROMISE THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS WOULD HAVE TO BE
DONE UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
BOTH SIDES AGREED OF COMMITTEES
COMPROMISE BUT- AT THE LAST
MINUTE THE SPONSOR THROUGH AN
AMENDMENT. UNSEEN BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION OR THE COMMITTEE.
THAT SAID THE NEW REQUIREMENTS
ARE QUOTE INTENDED TO CLARIFY
EXISTING LAW. AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THERE ARE
NUMBER OF LAWSUITS CURRENTLY
REGARDING THESE FEES. THE
LAWYERS REPRESENTING THE HOTELS
IN THE SUITS TOOK ONE LOOK AT
THAT LANGUAGE AND CONCLUDED.
THE CLARA THAT THE SO CALLED
CLARIFICATION LANGUAGE WILL NOT
WILL NO DOUBT. BE USED AGAINST
THE PARTIES IN THE PENDING
LITIGATION AND THEN FUTURE
LITIGATION THAT MAY BE PROMPTED
BY THIS LANGUAGE. THIS
PROVISION MAY THEREFORE
AFFECTED WE MAKE THE STATUTE
RETROACTIVE. SO WHILE WE AGREED
IN GOOD FAITH THAT THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS WON'T TAKE EFFECT
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR OUR
LAWYERS ARE TELLING US THAT
BECAUSE OF THIS LAST MINUTE
QUOTE CLARIFICATION. THE NEW
RESERVATION SYSTEM REQUIREMENTS
WILL BE APPLIED RETROACTIVELY.
AND THE FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH
THE RETROACTIVE RULES WE'LL BE
USED AGAINST THE INDUSTRY IN
THE CURRENT LITIGATION. AGAIN
IF THE QUOTE CLARIFICATION IS
REMOVED WE WILL SUPPORT THE
DEAL BROKERED BY THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MET MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THIS IS THE PORTION
OF THE MEETING TO WHICH MEMBERS
CAN SPEAK IN OPPOSITION NAME AN
AFFILIATION ONLY IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO. PRESS ONE WHEN THEY'RE
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. NO LINES IN
Q. AT THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE.
K. WILL BRING THE LEVER TO.
SOME JUST PRESS THAT BUT THEY
ALREADY HAVE AN OPEN LINE.
PLEASE HI YEAH. CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK YES. I UP MY NAME IS ANTHONY
LIEU IOWA DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS NO OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
BILL. BUT WE'RE NEITHER AT THE
PORT NOR OPPOSE. HOWEVER I'M
HERE TODAY AT THE INVITATION OF
THE AUTHOR NOT THAT THE ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS- AND
BASICALLY AND THE ISSUE
CLARIFICATION AND LIKE THAT
THANK LAW. AND PLEASE NOTE THAT
TERRY DI OKAY POLICY I WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO COMMENT. ON ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE APPLICATION
OR ENFORCEMENT ACTION THE
LEDGER OPTION. MAY OR MAY NOT
BE INVOLVED. I NOR CAN I
COMMENT ON ANY PENDING
LITIGATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NO LONGER A MEMBER
OF BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WILL
BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OVERALL THE FALL BY ASSEMBLY
ONE EGGMAN. OUR OUR STAFF. BUT
FIRST YEAH THERE WE GO-
ASSEMBLYMAN AYE AYE MY CAUCUS
AS A- I'LL TAKE HIS OFFICE YOU
CAN HEAR ME- I SEE MY CAUCUS
HAS IT OPPOSE RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS BILL- I ACTUALLY DISAGREE
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL I
THINK THIS IS NEEDED CONSUMER
PROTECTION. THAT YOU'RE ACTING
AND I COMPLIMENT YOU FOR
BRINGING FORWARD I HAD A
QUESTION THOUGH ABOUT THE
EXCLUSION OF STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES FROM THE BILL BECAUSE IF
THE GOAL OF THE BILL. IS SO A
CONSUMER CAN WHEN I GET A PRICE
FOR A HOTEL ROOM IN REAL AT
THAT SURPRISE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO PAY WHEN THEY SHOW UP
WHY WOULD WE NOT INCLUDE STATE
AND LOCAL TAXES AND THAT I'M
THINKING ABOUT A SITUATION
WHERE. A CONSUMER IS BOOKED IS
COMPARISON SHOPPING BETWEEN TWO
HOTELS THAT ARE CLOSE TOGETHER
BUT UNBEKNOWNST TO THE CONSUMER
WAS ONE IS RIGHT ACROSS THE
CITY LINE IS TECHNICALLY A
DIFFERENT CITY WITH A VERY
DIFFERENT- OCCUPANCY TAX RATE
SO ONE ACTIVITIES TAX MIGHT BE
TWICE AS MUCH AS THE OTHER I
THINK THAT THAT'S INFORMATION
THE CONSUMER SHOULD GET. I
THINK THE PRICE THAT THE
CONSUMER SIEGE SHOULD BE THE
PRICE THAT THEY PAY WHEN- THEY
BUT WHEN THEY STAY AT THE HOTEL
I WONDER WHY IT WITH THE LOGIC
WAS. NOW IN EXCLUDING THOSE. AS
A KIND OF A OVER. OF MY PART. I
SAW THAT YOU HE- THE SO TAX. IS
NON TO. ALMOST A OR OTHER CUT A
CONSUMERS. SO I'VE ALL BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOU TO INCLUDE.
YOU KNOW ANY LOCAL. TAXES SO WE
HAVE A VERY- THE CLEAR PRECISE
THE. THE FIGURE ONE DO BUT THE
REAL. WELL I'M DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE COMPLEXITIES THAT MIGHT ADD
TO THE BILL I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT IT- ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER YOU CERTAINLY HAVE MY
SUPPORT. DEFINITELY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR JEWETT YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AYE I HAD THIS BILL I
HAD A BILL LIKE THIS I HAD A
AND I ATE WAS A CONSTITUENT WHO
REACHED OUT TO ME HE SAID THIS
IS. I WON'T I WON'T USE THE
WORD THE CONSTITUENT USE BUT
THAT THESE THESE HIDDEN FEES
ARE THERE- AND I AGREED AND WE
WENT DOWN THIS PATH AND WE
WORKED ON IT BUT AGAIN WHEN
KOBE CRISIS CAME AROUND WE I
DIDN'T THINK THAT THERE WAS A
COMPELLING REASON. TO DO THIS
AT THIS TIME I ALSO UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU HAVE THE RETROACTIVITY
ON THERE IT'S BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THE AG NEEDS THAT IN ORDER FOR
AS THINGS GO FORWARD RIGHT NOW
SO. I THINK THE RESORT FEE
POLICY IS A BAD POLICY I LOOK
FORWARD TO VOTING FOR A BILL IN
THE FUTURE THAT WE ADDRESS THE
RESORT FEES THE DURING THIS
COVER CRISIS AGAIN AS WOULD
NEXT WEEK WE'RE ALL GOING TO
SIT HERE AND HEAR ABOUT A FIFTY
FOUR. BILLION DOLLAR HOLE
POTENTIALLY IN OUR BUDGET AND
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GO FORWARD I
IN GOOD CONSCIOUS AS A AS AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL DON'T FEEL
LIKE I CAN PERSONALLY BOTH FOR
BILLS I DON'T THINK ARE
RELEVANT IN THIS TIME SO I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- AND I GUESS I'D
JUST OBSERVE THAT AS WE GO
FORWARD ANY OTHER BILL YOU
DON'T SEE ME VOTING ON I DON'T
SEE THE CONNECTION. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THIS BILL HAD NO
PHYSICAL IMPACT AND PEOPLE DOES
THE WEEKLY STILL TRAVELED
DURING THIS THAT THEY'RE DOING
THE NEW NORMAL SO. TO BE ABLE
TO. OF A CHARACTER. SO AND MAY
A- MORE TO. OF THE EXES. LAW I
THINK THAT IT IS THIS
APPROPRIATE AND WERE. IT THAT
AGAIN. IT IS THE EXISTING LAW.
WELL I'M NEXT DOUBLE GO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I CAN'T TALK IN THESE MASS SO.
AND FOR THE RECORD TEN FEET
AWAY AT LEAST FROM PHIL CHANCE
I THINK WE'RE OKAY- I JUST HAD
A QUESTION ABOUT THE BILL'S
APPLICATION TO. SEE THOSE SORT
OF NORMAL FOLKS THAT MAY HAVE A
PLACE THAT THEY WANT TO RUN OUT
ON A SHORT TERM BASIS WHETHER
SIR HAUSSER VACATION HOME OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT- THE DON'T
GO THROUGH AIRBNB OR SOME OF
THESE OTHER ONLINE PLATFORMS-
SO MY QUESTION IS TWO FOLD ONE
WOULD IT WOULD IT APPLY TO
THOSE PEOPLE. AND TWO IF SO.
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO KNOW WHAT
EXACTLY THEY NEED TO LIST- THE
AWARE THAT INFORMATION GOING TO
BE- COMMUNICATED TO THEM HOW DO
THEY FIND THAT OUT AND ARE THEY
AT RISK OF LIABILITY FOR
LAWSUIT OR ATTORNEY GENERAL
ENFORCEMENT ACTION IF THEY
AREN'T ABLE TO. TO DO IT RIGHT
SO I MEAN THAT THOSE ARE MY
CONCERNS AYE AYE I. I
APPRECIATE AND I SUPPORT THE
DISCLOSURE ASPECT OF THIS- BUT
I AM CONCERNED BECAUSE IN MY
DISTRICT WE HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS
THAT YOU KNOW RUN OUT THEIR
HOUSE FOR A COUPLE WEEKS IN THE
SUMMER AND I JUST DON'T KNOW
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO THIS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION YES WE THE COVERED
THE- IF THERE BE. A B. AND B.
AND- REGARDING TO HOW THE FINAL
THE VIAL. THE CHARGES AND BUT I
THINK. THE ONE THEY'RE GETTING
INTO THE BUSINESS. OF IS REALLY
UPON DONE TO FIND NOW. SO WHAT
ARE TO. THAT THE CHARGES THAT
THAT THEY NEED TO PAY. TO THE
THIRD PARTY OR WHATEVER. SO
YOU'RE- A IF THEY DON'T. KNOW
THE CHARGES. AND I THIS IS NOT
TO BE APPEARED OF THE LAW AND I
GET TO OPEN UP THE DOOR TO CALL
US TO INFORM THE TO EDUCATE
THEM. OF ALL THEIR CHARGES BUT
USUALLY THEY KNOW- WHAT DID
THEY NEED TO CHARGE THE TO
THEIR CUT A CONSUMERS AND OTHER
CUSTOMERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. BEING
SOMEONE WHO TRAVELS QUITE A
BIT. OF I UNDERSTAND THE LOGIC
AND AM SOMEWHAT SYMPATHETIC-
BUT LIKE WE'VE HEARD. FROM
OTHER COLLEAGUES. I BELIEVE
THAT THE TRAVEL INDUSTRY AT
THIS TIME HAS BEEN HARD HIT
ENOUGH AND THAT THIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO IMPOSE EVEN MORE A
REGULATIONS ON THE TRAVEL
INDUSTRY SO WITH THAT I WILL
LAY OFF AT THIS TIME. WE GIVE
THEM FOR YEARS SO THIS ONE WILL
NOT BE OF IN THE IMPACT OF.
UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
THAT'S WHY WE THIRTY EIGHT MM
AND TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
DESERVE THIS IS EXISTING MALL
NOT TO- TO DECEIVE. THE THEIR
CUSTOMERS SO IT THERE'S A FOR
YEARS TO. IMPLEMENT AT AT- LIKE
AS A SAID A GROUP OF FOUR- I
WILL EVEN SUPPORT- THE DISASTER
RELIEF SURCHARGE AND I DON'T
THINK IT WOULD TAKE THEM FOR
YEARS. TO IMPLEMENT TO ADD THAT
SURCHARGE TO THEIR BILL. SO YOU
KNOW I'M I'M SPEAKING IT OF
WHAT WAS MY OF PROGRAMMERS HAD
ON THE- BUT WITH THE BILL DOES
GET TO PROVIDE FOR YEARS FOR
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- I THINK THE
DISCLOSURE PART OF THIS BILL IS
INCREDIBLY NOBLE I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. I WANT TO ASK
ABOUT- THE CLARIFICATION
LANGUAGE THAT WAS ADDED TO THE
BILL AT THE LAST MINUTE- WHAT
IMPACT DOES THAT HAVE OR WOULD
THAT HAVE. ON THE CURRENT
SITUATION WITH THE GLACIATIONS
WITH AG AND THE FTC. SO JUST
PRETTY MUCH REMINDER YOU KNOW
BECAUSE OF THE LONG-
IMPLEMENTATION IT'LL FOR YEARS-
WALLET JUST TO REMINDER THAT
THERE IS AN EXISTING LAW. YOU
KNOW AND THIS BILL WILL NOT-
TRYING TO INFLUENCE. THE AG'S
THE HOLDING INTERPRETED THE
EXISTING LAW BUT JUST BECAUSE
ALL THAT. IMPLEMENTATION TIME.
I FELT IF I MAY TO THE CHAIR
SURE I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO HEAR
FROM- THE AG'S REPRESENTATIVE
AS WELL AS OPPOSITION ON WHAT
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN. WHAT THEY
BELIEVE THE IMPACT WOULD BE AS
WELL SURE SO CAN CHOOSE WHAT TO
ORDER THAT IS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RESTORATION LET US THEN
JUST GO TO THAT TECHNICAL
QUESTION THEN. AGAIN FROM THE
REPRESETATIVE ON THE LINE FOR
A FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
pOFFICE AND PERHAPS MR GREY HE
MIGHT JUST BE ABLE TO REPEAT.
THAT QUICK CLARIFICATION SURE
AS WELL. SURE SO. THE
CLARIFICATION LANGUAGE AND
RETROACTIVITY. HOW WITH THIS
BILL IMPACT- OF THE CURRENT
SITUATION WITH THE GO SHE SHINS
BETWEEN AG OFFICES. AND THE FTC
WITH THE CAR. FOR RETROACTIVE
RETROACTIVE IN INDUSTRIAL
THERE'S A CURRENT LAW AND FROM
THE BOOK OKAY GREAT SO WE'LL GO
TEND TO MODERATE FALL- BY MR
CALL THE BUT- MISTER MODERATOR
IF AND- I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAVE MISTER ANTHONY LOU ON THE
LINE FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO ANSWER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. TECHNICAL QUESTION.
THANK YOU HI THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION- SHALL WITH THE IMPACT
THAN. CURRENT NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN THE AG AND ATHLETES
BEING- THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT CAN REALLY DISCUSS- BUT
NOT WILLING. AGAIN SOMETHING I
CAN COMMENT ON- I CAN PROVIDE
TACKLE AT THE FENCE ON THE
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL BUT I
CAN'T REALLY. ABOUT THAT TIME-
SOMEONE GRAYSON DID NOT YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL FALL THE
QUESTIONS FOR THE
REPRESENTATIVE AT THIS POINT
NOT THAT. I'M NOT FROM THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF FROM
OPPOSITION YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISS
NOT RUNNER DEMO THEN GO TO MR
CALL WELL AGAIN. WHEN WE SAW
THIS LANGUAGE WE GAVE IT TO THE
ATTORNEYS WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
THESE CASES AND THEY WROTE TO
ME ON MONDAY. THE QUOTE
CLARIFICATION LANGUAGE WILL NO
DOUBT. NO DOUBT BE USED AGAINST
THE PARTIES IN THE PENDING
LITIGATION. AND FUTURE
LITIGATION THAT MAY BE PROMPTED
BY THIS LANGUAGE THE PROVISION
MAY THEREFORE EFFECTIVELY MAKE
THE STATUTE RETROACTIVE AND IT
HAS TO THE RETROACTIVITY I AM
NOT AN ATTORNEY. I'M JUST PLAIN
READING OF LANGUAGE. YOU CAN
YOU SET UP A REQUIREMENT FOR
CHANGING ALL THE RESERVATION
SYSTEMS AND THEN YOU SAY THIS
IS INTENDED TO CLARIFY EXISTING
LAW. I'M SORRY JUST REASONABLE
A REASONABLE READ IS OKAY. ALL
THIS STUFF SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE FOR YEARS. SO WE DID THIS
IN TEND TO YOU KNOW INTENDED TO
CLARIFY EXISTING LAW. GETS US
INVOLVED IN GUESSES LEGISLATURE
TAKING SIDES IN OR IN EXISTING
LAWSUIT AND IT MAKES THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THIS BILL
RETROACTIVE. SO AND AGAIN THE
TERM I'M NOT A TURNING THE
ATTORNEYS THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THE CASE SAY. IT WILL BE
INVOLVED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COULD BE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO DO WHICH TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT TO COMMENT ON ANY OF
THE EXISTING LAW I DON'T KNOW
IF THERE'S ANY- EXISTING LAWS
TO BUT THIS IS THE BUILDING
TENSION IS REDUCED- DOES
CONFUSION THE SO CRISIS AND
REDUCE. THE NUMBER OF THE
LAWSUIT AND AGAIN- THE EXIT
THIS IS NOT TO CHANGE- OR
INFLUENCE THE AG ON HOW THEY-
INTERPRETED THE EXISTING LAW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SIMILAR TO- I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
IT AS STATEMENT SUCH THAT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK ONLY WITH YOUR OFFICE BUT
ALSO WITH OPPOSITION. INDEED AS
INITIALLY PRESENTED YOUR BILL
WOULD HAVE GONE INTO EFFECT AT
WITH THE INTENT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUT WE BECAUSE OF
THE COMEDIAN MAINTENANCE.
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TO ACCOMMODATE AND
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- UNKNOWNS
AND THE UNCERTAINTY IN THE
INDUSTRY- SIMILARLY ALSO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE
OPPOSITION FOR YOUR GOOD FAITH
EFFORTS AND WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR. AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE A CLEARLY THIS
LANGUAGE- SPECIFICALLY THAT HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED WAS
SPECIFICALLY FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS A CALL
SOME PAUSE AND I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL BE. A COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH-
OPPOSITION AND OF ADDITIONAL
GOOD FAITH SO THIS DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. IS
THERE A MOTION. KATE MOTION THE
SECOND. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB THIRTY TO
THIRTY FIVE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE LOW. I AM SORRY JUST
FOR A WOMAN MEMBERS AND WE'RE
HAVING A LITTLE BIT HARD TIME
TO A HEARING YOU AND JUST SO
THAT WE COULD RECORD YOUR VOTE
ACCURATELY WOULD YOU MIND.
SPEAKING A LOUDLY. MISTER
CHAIR. HELLO HI. LOW HI BRO.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA NOT VOTING
BLOOM. CHEN CHEN NOT VOTING TO
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING EGGMAN. I AM NOT VOTING
FONG. GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON GRAYSON NOT VOTING
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA NOT VOTING MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
HAS SIX WHAT THAT IS SIX FOOT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
BEING PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN DOLLY THIS IS A A. B.
THIRTY SIXTEEN. CAN THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AB
THIRTY SIXTEEN. WELCOME PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHATEVER
READY. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS ON THIS BILL AND ALSO FOR
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR I AM
HONORED TO PRESENT AB THIRTY
SIXTEEN WHICH WILL CREATE A
MORE EFFICIENT PROCESS FOR
LICENSE VERIFICATION. FOR
CALIFORNIA NURSES SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT IN MULTIPLE STATES
BY REQUIRING THE BEER AND TO
IMPLEMENT ELECTRONIC LICENSE
VERIFICATION VACATION SYSTEM.
YOU'RE MAKING GOING. WELL WELL
WELL WELCOME TO THE LEGISLATURE
OFTHAT IS THE INDICATION OF
THAT THAT YOU HAVE WIDE SUPPORT
IT IS IT IS YOUR DESIRE TO
CONTINUE ON YOU MAY DO SO BUT-
URGE YOU TO DO SO WITH CAUTION.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT I
AM VERY GOOD WELL SAID I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW AND
THEN. GO TO ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- AND- I UNDERSTAND THAT
WE HAVE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT-
FROM THE INTENSIVE CARE NURSE.
A TRAVEL WAS INTENSIVE CARE
TRAVEL NURSE- SO MISTER
MODERATE I WILL PROVIDE UP TO
TWO MINUTES FOR MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK. FOR KEY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING I AM
HIGHLY HENDRIX AND I AM HERE
TODAY IN MY CAPACITY AS AN AYE
YOUR TRAVEL THERE ACCORDING AB
THIRTY SIXTEEN. I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
LIKE ME VERIFICATION PROCESS
AND THE PREPARATION THAT THE
CURRENT ANTIQUATED SYSTEM. HERE
TODAY TO ADDRESS AMERICA AT
THIRTY SIXTEEN. I'M FROM
MINNESOTA WHICH IS NOT A
CONTACT STATE MEAN I NEED TO
APPLY FOR A LIFE YOU FIND YOUR
MIND AND EACH STATE THAT I
TRAVEL TO- FORGETTING MY
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND THEY
TYPICALLY COULD APPLY FOR A JOB
IN ANOTHER STATE. RECEIVE A
TEMPORARY WORK PERMIT AND
THIRTY JOB IN THAT STATE WITHIN
TWO WEEKS. NOW THAT I HAVE MY
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND I MISSED
OUT ON MANY JOB OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE OF THE BANK THE
VERIFICATION PROCESS. BUT THE
PANDEMIC AYE THAT DIFFICULTIES
RESPONDING THE HOT BUT AREAS
BECAUSE OF HAVING A CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND- MANY STATES HAVE
ANNOUNCED THAT ANY STATE
LICENSES ACCEPTED BUT WITH
MULTIPLE TRIALS. I'VE LEARNED
THAT NOT MANY HOSPITAL SYSTEM
THEY'RE WILLING TO ACCEPT ANY
STATE LIKE THEM. BUT MY MOST
RECENT CONTRACT BEING CANCELED
I'M LOOKING TO VENTURE TO
ANOTHER STATE THAT HAVE. WE
NEED BUT WHAT BY. WEEKS LEADING.
PREPARE I'M CURRENTLY. AND
CALIFORNIA. THE BILL IS NEEDED
IN MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE TO
ALLOW CALIFORNIA LICENSE ARE
AND TO RESPOND TO NURSING
SHORTAGES. ACROSS THE NATION.
AVOID ON AND MEN AND THE NEED
TO USE STATE RESOURCES AND- TO
RESPECTIVELY RESPOND TO THE
CHANGING DYNAMICS OF THE NATION
IN GENERAL. AB SIXTEEN WITH.
SIXTEEN YEAR BY A LOT IN
PRETERM. HOW NURSES HAVE ALIVE
AND THEN AND STATEMENT KINDLY.
OF OTHER RESPOND TO THE CURRENT
HOPLITE AREAS AND WHAT OFF THE
MORE EMPLOYMENT OP. THANK A
THIRTY. WITH AN ACT THE LIKE
VERIFICATION CODE. FOR THERE'D.
THANK YOU MIGHT MISTER ANOTHER
WOULD BE OUR AND I. WITH. WISH
TO SHARE YOUR- SUPPORT FOR THE.
WE'LL GO FIRST TIME LINE OF
FORTY SIX FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI SHERRY BALLPARK DEAN
OF HEALTH SCIENCES COLLEGE OF
MARIN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE
DO HAVE SEVERAL OTHERS IN Q.
WILL GO NEXT THE LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE OF THE. I
MEMBERS COASTLINE OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
WE'RE NOT OPPOSE OR SUPPORTING
THE BILL BUT HAVE SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF CONCERN WE SHARE SOME
OF THE SAME CONCERNS AT THE
BORDER REGISTERED NURSING HOUSE
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING ONLINE
SEVENTY TWO SEVEN TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE CALLER ONLINE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE ONLINE SEVENTY ONE
SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHELDON FOR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU AND THERE
ARE NO FATHER FURTHER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE PORTION OF THE HEARING
FOR WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION I HAVE TWO LISTED
REMINDER UP TO TWO MINUTES PER
INDIVIDUAL WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY I HAVE
LISTED A TELL MY HARRIS TO
BEGIN. BUT THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. HELLO MY
NAME IS THE ONLY HEAR SOME TO
THE LEGISLATION FOR THE BORDER
REGISTERED NURSING. AND WE
APPRECIATE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DOLLIES DESIRE TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS. FOR HER CONSTITUENTS
AND WE TO HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
INEFFICIENCIES OF. OF REGARDING
THE VERIFICATION PROCESS FOR
OVER A YEAR. SO I'M HERE TODAY
TO AGREE THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM. BUT RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREEING WITH THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION AS THE PROPER
SOLUTION. AS A MATTER OF
POLICY. WE BELIEVE IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS AND LICENSEES FOR THE
STATE. TO MAINTAIN CONTROL THE
LICENSEE OVER OUR- OVER A HALF
MILLION REGISTERED NURSES IN
pREASONS BOTH FOR QUALITY AND
COST CONTROL REASONS THEREFORE
WE OPPOSE THE EFFORTS. TO
CONTRACTORS WORK OUT TO PRIVATE
COMPANIES ESPECIALLY OUT OF THE
STATE. CALIFORNIA'S REGISTERED
NURSES ARE 20% OF THE NATIONAL
WORKFORCE AND BECAUSE WE
PROCESS OVER AN AVERAGE OF
THIRTEEN THOUSAND VERIFICATIONS
PER YEAR. WE CAN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY NURSES HAS A BUSINESS
INTEREST IN ACQUIRING
CALIFORNIANS WORK FORCE.
HOWEVER THE B. R. AND DOESN'T
BELIEVE IT'S IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF CALIFORNIA. WE DO
AGREE HOWEVER THE LICENSEES
DESERVE BETTER SERVICE SO I'M
PLEASED TO PRICE THE OFFERING
THE COMMITTEE. THAT WE
INITIATED A SEE THROUGH CHANGES
MAKE IT ALL. AT IMPAIR TO THE
D. A VERY SLOW. TO HAVE ACCOUNT.
THIS WILL SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS
FOR THE LICENSEES SHORTEN THE
PROCESS TO. THIS DAY THE LAST.
AND WE WERE. MULTI PRICE. THE
CHANGES THAT ANTICIPATE BEING
ABLE TO REMOVE. THAT FIVE
BUSINESS DAY MY STONE BY THE
END OF THE YEAR. NOW HERE IN
DALLAS WITH. IN EARLY TWO.
TWENTY WE ARE AND HOW OVER.
THREE HUNDRED SEVEN. THE LAST
WEEK SO THREE DATA SHOW THAT IN
OUR OF THREE THOUSAND MY AS A-
OF THE BEAST P. PASSED BY THE
LEAD. EFFECT JULY THOUSAND. WE
HAVE INCREASE STAFFING FOR THIS.
FROM ONE HALF DAY. TO ONE FIVE.
FINALLY ON THE FREE. FEED OF A
HUNDRED. TO BE AREA WOULD NOT A-
IF TO LET WANTS TO THE LET
WANTS TO LOWER THE FEE. OUR
FEES ARE IN STATURE AND
REGULATIONS ARE. REQUEST YOU
YOUR VOTE OF NO ON. EIGHTY
THREE ONE THREE ZERO ONE SIX
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW MR MODERATOR MIGHT THERE BE
ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. I
BELIEVE THERE IS ONE ONLINE.
PLEASE IN OPPOSITION. BOB GO TO
THE Q. IF YOUR POSITION AS AN
OPPOSITION IN YOUR PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ALIGN THE CUED
UP YOU MAY CONTINUE. THANK YO
VERY MUCH OF BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN TO THE AUTHOR I WOULD
LIKE TO BE CONSIDERED AS A COST
OF HIS BE ALL THINGS TO GET
BILL COMMON SENSE AND PLEASE
CONSIDER ADDING ME AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. KATE SEE
NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF VERY MUCH FOR
ALL THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL WE'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH AND WE HAVE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THIS STRICTLY MODERNIZE THE
MAKES ARE MORE EFFICIENT FOR
OUR NURSES. AND CONSIDERING THE
PANDEMIC WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
BE QUICK AND TRAVEL THOSE HOT
SPOT SO WHERE WHERE NEEDED SO
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE O WORK
WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AT THE
COMPUTER WORK OUT TO SOME OF
THESE OUTSTANDING ISSUES THIS
DOES THE JOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND. MR
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB THIRTY SIXTEEN THE
MOTION IS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. HIGH LOW HI
BRO. BRO I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE BLOOM. CHAN CHAN I TO
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG AYE AYE
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA
GRAYSON RECENT I HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA. MULLIN
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I TEN. FORTY BUCKS
LEVELS UP. THANK YOU WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON
THEN TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
SOME OF OUR DAILY THIS IS AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY AGAIN FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY MR DAILY THIS DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES THE AISLE THESE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THE DEFINITION OF A HOUSEHOLD
GOODS MOTOR CARRIER. IN OUR
STATE STATUTES THE DEFINITION
IS OUTDATED. AND SHOULD BE
ADJUSTED TO REFLECT THE
DIFFERENT SERVICES PROVIDED BY
MOVING COMPANIES. THE BILL
SPONSORED BY THE TEAMSTERS AND
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION. BILL I THINK MAKE
WILL MAKE THE INDUSTRY A LITTLE
BIT MORE EFFICIENT AND SERVE
CONSUMERS BETTER. I ALSO
BELIEVE IN THIS. ERA OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THE TYPE OF MOVING
COMPANIES WE ARE. TALKING
ABOUT- PERFORM SERVICES
WITHOUT. GOING INTO THE HOME.
OR WITH VERY LITTLE TOUCHING OF
THE GOODS. FOR THE CUSTOMER SO
IT'S IN THE SPIRIT OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING I BELIEVE. AND I
HAVE TO REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
SPONSORS. IF YOU MOTOR ITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
AND SHINGLES MONTH WITH THE
TEAMSTERS. WHO ARE AVAILABLE TO
SPEAK IF NECESSARY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH UP TO TWO MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SHOULD YOU
WISH TO DO SO. OKAY LEARNING
CHAIR HELLO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CARILLO-
CHRIS MOTOR CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION- IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE HOUSEHOLD LEVERS
ACT- SHIFTED OVERSIGHT IN THE
MOVING INDUSTRY FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION OF
HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND SERVICES I
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACTORS
BROUGHT THE WHITE
INCONSISTENCIES WITH
LONGSTANDING FEDERAL LAW IN
THIS AREA AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
UPDATES CALIFORNIA LAW TO
REFLECT ACTION TAKEN BY
CONGRESS IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
TO GIVE CONSUMERS A LOWER COST
ALTERNATIVE FULL SERVICE
HOUSEHOLD WHICH UNDER FEDERAL
LAW TRUCKING COMPANIES ARE
AUTHORIZED TO FORM A LIMITED
RANGE OF SELF MOVING SERVICES
SELF MOVING PROVIDES THOSE WHO
CHOOSE TO PACK AROUND HOUSEHOLD
ITEMS AND COST EFFECTIVE LOWER
NO TOUCH DO MOVE OPTIONS. IT
MUCH AS A 50% SAVING OVER
SERVICE WHICH I WILL FOR
TRAFFIC IN HOMES REDUCING
EIGHTY TWO FOUR SIX SIX SHE
BOUGHT THE HEALTH AT WILL BE.
OF CALIFORNIANS RELOCATING AND
THEIR. WITH TO THE OPPOSITION.
ABOUT THAT I IN THE HOUSEHOLD
WE INTO SHE- WE WANT TO BE
NOTHING THIS BILL. WITH FROM
THE ALL SERVER MEMBERS WHO
SHOULD BE LICENSE OUR LOW. OR
FROM OUR INCOME CLAIMING TO
WHAT SERVICE. WORKER ACTION
AGAINST PREDATORY. AB TWENTY
FOURTH SO ALIGN SPEAKING FROM
LAW RESPECT REPAIRS. OF MOVING
SIR. THANK YOU SO. SAVES CAL
MONEY PROVIDE FOR HELP YOUR
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME. THANK YOU MUCH. ANY
AT THE- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK AND- MR
SHERMAN MORNING SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF. THE TEAMSTERS ARE
REALLY CLOSE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL FOR US IS BILLS ABOUT JOBS
OUR MEMBERS ARE EMPLOYEE
COMMERCIAL DRIVERS WHO MOVED
PRE LOADED GOOD FOR. VERY LARGE
TRUCKING COMPANY SOMETIMES THAT
CONTAINER OF FURNITURE THAT OUR
MEMBERS DRIVE FROM POINT A TO
POINT B. SOMETIMES IT'S A
CONTAINER OF SOMETHING ELSE.
THEIR TRUCK DRIVERS NOT MOVERS
THEY DON'T GO INTO PEOPLE'S
HOMES THEY DON'T LOAD OR UNLOAD
FURNITURE. THEY DON'T DO THE
THINGS THAT THAT MOVERS DO WE
COSPONSORED THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACT. OF THIS NEW
INTERPRETATION OF THE LICENSEE
LONGER JOBS THE COSTA
ADDITIONAL RATE. THAT ANN ARBOR
IS COMPLETELY AND THAT. COULD
MEAN THE DEATH BETWEEN OUR
EMPLOYERS CONTINUE TO CONTINUE
TO DO THIS WORK OR NOT- NOW
WITH THE IMPACT OF KOBE
NINETEEN ON THE ECONOMY. WE'VE
BEEN MORE CONCERNED TODAY THE
NEW YORK TIMES REPORTED THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION JOBLESS CLAIMS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES. THIS
BILL ENSURES THAT OUR MEMBERS
ARE ADDED TO THAT LIST WE ARE
DRIVE A THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
WILL MOVE ON TO THE PORTION
WHERE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAY
ALSO VOICED THEIR SUPPORT. OF
NAME IN DELAYS IN. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISH INTO SPEAK
INTO. THAT IS YOUR BROTHER YOU
MEAN FOR THE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN USING TELEPHONE YOU
MAY PRESS BUTTON. NO ONE Q. AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION KEY WITNESSES WHICH
IS BEGIN OPPOSITION AT THE TWO
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. AND WE
HAVE LISTED A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA MOVING AND
STORAGE ASSOCIATION PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING SIR STEVE
WIDE CAMP FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MOVING AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION
THE HUNDRED AND TWO YEAR OLD
TRADE ASSOCIATION. REPRESENTING
LEGAL ELECTED MOVERS. THANKS
FOR THE CHAIR OF THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ATTEMPTING TO WORK WITH THAT.
AND LISTENING TO OUR ISSUES
FORTY. WE MY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
SIX. THE DEFINITION OF A
HOUSEHOLD. VERY IT DOES NOT
SPEAK TO PACK LOADING A LABOR.
TO THE TRANCE. OF USED
HOUSEHOLD GOOD ON THE HIGHER.
THE LIGHTS. NOT OLDER NEED TO
RE. THE HOUSE OF IT MOVERS OUT
WAS REVIEW AND RE. IN TWO TEN.
IN NINETEEN. WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE AGENCY AND STATE.
TOOK DEEP DIVE INTO HOW OF
THEIR- ADDITIONALLY HELPS A
GOOD MOVE ACT AND ITS PREY. THE
HOUSE COULD. OUT HAVE BEEN.
REGULARLY TO INCLUDE MORE NOT
LESS ENTITIES. INTO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY ONE EIGHT
BUT- AMENDED THE I IN RHODE
CODE. TO CHANGE THE DISTANCE
THE- HOW. MOVE ADDING BROKE
CHECK GROUP CLEARLY STATING
FROM MUST HAVE THE SAME PERMIT.
FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT FOR STATE
FROM THE NOT IN FOR THEIR OWN
LAWS. REQUIRE OFFERED STREAMING.
FOR PER REQUIREMENTS TO
STRUGGLE. THE FEDERAL. TO NOT.
IF YOU'RE TRANSPORTATION OF.
GOODS. THE STANDARD TO BE
QUALIFIED TO THE FEDERAL MOTOR
CARRIER IS EMBARRASSINGLY LOW
AND INCLUDES ALMOST NONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA GIRLS HOT GOOD
SERVICES. FIFTY TWO PAID
QUALIFICATION PACK BUT
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND PRACTICAL
RULES TEST. BE HUGS PERMIT IS
THE GOLD STANDARD. THEY ALSO
CONTEND THAT THESE REGULATIONS
PUT A BURGER ON ON THEM. IF
THIS IS ACCURATE WOULD IT BE
TRUE THAT A PLACE IN THE SAME
BURDEN ON THE BUSINESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TO FOLLOW THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT MAKE
MOVING CALIFORNIA SAFER TO THE
PUBLIC. THAN ALMOST ANY OTHER
STATE. THERE ARE MOVING
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLD GOODS
THEREFORE THEY SHOULD BE
CONSTRAINED BY THE SAME RULES
AND REGULATIONS PLACED ON ALL
MEMBERS OPERATING STATE.
FAILURE TO DO SO SUBJECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS THE
DAMAGES. WE FEEL THAT. MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS BILL IS
REPRESENTS A MORAL HAZARD. AND
WE ARE. A VOTE AGAINST THIS
BILL THANK YOU. YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION NAME AND AFFILIATION
MISTER MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THERE'S BEEN IN MOTION
AND A SECOND ARE READY- MR
DAILY TO WHICH TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
RECOMMENDATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. WE'VE WORKED HARD TO
ACCOMMODATE AS MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS AS WE- POSSIBLY
COULD. THE BILL SIMPLY ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA LAW. WITH FEDERAL
LAW. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HI LOW HI BRO. WROTE I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM CHAN CHAN I
TO CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON. GLORIA GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY. MEDINA
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
MULLIN. OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
TING. GIPSON AYE. TWELVE WHAT'S
THE BOTTOM THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR DALY WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS- COLLEAGUES JUST A FEW
A TO ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPER I
NEEDS AS AS A REMINDER. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. AB THIRTY TO
THIRTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU THE BILL IS STILL ON
CALL. AGAIN A. B. THIRTY TO
THIRTY FIVE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE IS STILL ON CALL. AND
MEMBERS- WE ALSO PROVIDED A
CREST LUNCH FOR YOU- STARTING
AT TWELVE NOON IN THE LOUNGE. I
WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE ON AND
FOLLOW ORDER OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX. BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GARCIA THIS IS AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY TWO WELCOME. AND THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY TWO WOULD SIMPLY GET
CALIFORNIANS ANOTHER OPTION FOR
THE REMAINS WHEN THEY HAVE
PASSED. AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO BE
ORGANICALLY THE COMPOSED. THE
FAMILY WITH ME THEN YOU THREE
MAIN FESTIVAL AMENDMENT TO
PLANT A TREE OR BOARD AND EVERY
MEMBER OF THEIR LOVED ONES. I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WE HAVE A
WITNESSES BEFORE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN- ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES-
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE. A TWO LISTED AT PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO SPEAK WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY UP TO TWO MINUTES
FOR WHEN THIS IN SUPPORT. LIDAR
OPEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. HEARING NONE. WILL
MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
OPPOSITION MISTER MODERATE.
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SIXTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN CAN
YOU HEAR. MY SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE SIXTY FOUR
SHOULD BE IN SUPPORT MAKING
CARMICHAEL LICENSE CREMATED
REMAINS TO SO THE REPRESENTING
TO THE DIVE INTO DEATH
PROFESSIONALS UP YOUR
COLLECTIVE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
FIVE NINETY TWO. THANK YOU AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS JERRY DESMOND BUT THE
FROM A TERRY A MORTUARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WITH
A NEUTRAL POSITION ON THE BILL.
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
CUED UP AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR GIVING TAKING
HEAR ME. THIS WAS THEIR IT ONE
LAST A FINAL MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK. YEAH
THREE THE THREE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. BONTA NUMBER. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU DO YOU WISH TO
JUST IDENTIFY YOUR YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. I'M AFRAID THAT I'M
IN THE WRONG COMMITTEE MEETING.
LOOKING FOR REDUCTION OF HUMAN
REMAINS THAT THAT THAT IS THAT
IS THAT IS THE CORRECT ONE IT
HASN'T BEEN BURIED YET SO WOULD
YOU DO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND I
BELIEVE I AM CALLED AS A
WITNESS. NO POP BUT WAS THAT
YOU WOULD WILL IT SHALL WE TAKE
THAT AS YOUR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT WILL PROVIDE YOU UP TO
TWO MINUTES BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
YOU ARTIFICIALLY LISTED IN
ADVANCE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KATRINA
STATE. FOUNDER AND CEO OF
RECOMPOSE. A PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING NATURAL ORGANIC
PRODUCTION. THANK YOU TO OUR
BILL SPONSORED THE SPECIALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA TO OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND YOUR
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA
INTEREST IN BRINGING NEW END OF
LIFE OPTION TWO YOU'RE STATE.
IT'S AN UNDERSTANDABLE TENDENCY
TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF TIME WE
SPEND THINKING ABOUT DEATH
CARE. HOWEVER CONSIDERATION BY
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ACCESS TO
MEANINGFUL DEATH CARE OPTIONS
MAKE NOW AND ESPECIALLY TIMELY
MOMENT FOR CALIFORNIA TO ADD
NEW OPTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
THE END OF BY. SHE IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN AS PART OF MY
GRADUATE STUDIES IN
ARCHITECTURE I LEARNED ABOUT
DECADES OF RESEARCH AROUND THE
PROCESS OF LIVESTOCK MORTALITY
COMPOSTING. IF PRACTICES USED
BY FARMERS ALL OF THE UNITED
STATES AS A SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
WAY TO RECYCLE ANIMAL CARCASSES
BACK TO THE LAND. THE PROCESS
IS SIMPLE A BODY IS COVERED AND
NATURAL MATERIALS LIKE STRAW
AND WOOD CHIPS. AND OVER THE
COURSE OF SEVERAL WEEKS IT
GENTLY ROKEN DOWN INTO THE
SOIL THANKS TO MICROBIAL
ACTIVITY. OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS TOGETHER WITH RESEARCHERS
FROM SEVERAL MAJOR
UNIVERSITIES. WE'VE SIX
ACTUALLY CONCLUDED THAT THE
SAME PROCESS. NOW CALLED
NATURAL ORGANIC PRODUCTION. IS
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE FOR HUMANS
POSITION. MOST SIGNIFICNTLY IN
THE RECENT PILOT AT WASHINGTON
STATE UNIVERSITY ALL FIFTY
THRESHOLD FOR MATT AS OUTLINED
BY DEPARTMENT OF ECOLOGY AND
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. IN
ADDITION TO BEING SAFE NATURAL
ORGANIC PRODUCTION IS NATURAL
AND SUSTAINABLE. THEY PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS IN CARBON
EMISSIONS AND USES JUST ONE
EIGHT THE ENERGY OF CREMATION.
FINALLY IN COLLABORATING WITH
PEOPLE DIRECTORS FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA MANY OF WHOM ARE
CALLING IN OR LISTENING TODAY.
IT'S BECOME CLEAR THAT THE
STATE'S RESIDENTS WHAT MORE
CHOICE WHEN IT COMES TO THE END
OF LIFE. EVERY DAY WE HEAR MORE
INTEREST FROM PEOPLE HOMEOWNERS
INTERESTED IN ADDING THE
SERVICE. FROM CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS TO FIND OPTION
MEANINGFUL CHOICE FOR BOTH
THEMSELVES AND THEIR LOVED ONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WILL
CONCLUDE A PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE
MOVE THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY WARNING.
THANK YOU AND- MISTER SEE I
WASN'T HERE FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS READING AT THE
HEREBY MASSIVE EVERYONE THE
QUESTION BUT TELL ME HOW THIS
IS COATED RELATED NOW. NO I AM
A BIG FAN OF END OF LIFE
OPTIONS AND- AND CERTAINLY THIS
ONE IN PARTICULAR BUT TELL ME
HOW IT'S RELEVANT. NOW. YES I
THINK YOU KNOW I THOUGHT AS A
BODY WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE CO
THERE TO ADD MODES SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM WE'RE GOING TO BE
DEALING WITH THAT BUT I THINK
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
CONTINUE. ALL OF OUR WORK. I AM
PROVIDING. INDIVIDUAL OF
ANOTHER OPTION FOR INTERNET IS
IMPORTANT- AND- I THINK WHAT IT
IS IT'S PART OF LOCAL THAT.
ALSO IF WE'RE DEALING WITH
PEOPLE. AND FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
BEING FACE AND FORCED TO DEAL
WITH AND THE LIKE TO BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW- UNEXPECTEDLY. INTO
THIS WILL PROVIDE OF ANOTHER
OPTION I DOWN THE ROAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. SEEING NONE OF THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA DO WISH TO
CLOSE. THE FACTORY AFTER AND
I'VE UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO THE MOTIONS TO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS LOW HI LOW HI BRO.
BROKE NO ARAMBULA. BLOOM. TEN
CHEN NOT VOTING TO. CUNNINGHAM
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG
AYE GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA
GRAYSON. GRAYSON I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN WHEN I AND
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I TEN. THE BILL IS
TEN VOTE OF THOSE ON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS SOMEONE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. WILL MOVE ON TO A FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE THIS IS AB
THIRTY FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE A JEWEL
PRESENTATION ALSO- WITH. OUR
OTHER ADDITIONAL COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WINNER EVERY ALREADY GENTLEMAN
A PLEASE NOTE THAT THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES THE OP. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN- MEMBERS LET ME BE
BRAVE GIVEN. I HEARD A MOTION
AND A SECOND I KNOW THE
COMMITTEE IT'S TIME IS VALUABLE
LAST SIXTY YEARS NUMBER OF JOBS
REQUIRING AN OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE OR GOVERNMENT APPROVAL
HAS GROWN FROM AROUND ONE IN
TWENTY. TWO ONE IN FOUR.
LICENSING LAWS RIP MEDITECH THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONSUMERS.
BUT EXCESSIVELY OWNERS
REQUIREMENTS CAN CREATE
BARRIERS FOR MANY VISUAL DOUBT
DEMONSTRATED PUBLIC BENEFITS.
MILITARY FAMILIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING BERRIES
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
LICENSE PORTABILITY. THE
MILITARY TRAINS VETERANS AND
SKILLS APPLICABLE TO NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO CIVILIAN
LICENSED OCCUPATIONS AND MORE
THAN A THIRD OF MILITARY
SPOUSES ARE EMPLOYED IN THE
FIELD REQUIRES LICENSURE.
FAILURE TO RECOGNIZE OUR
VETERANS UNIQUE EXPERIENCES CAN
DISCOURAGE THEM FROM ENTERING
REMAINING IN THE LABOR MARKET
IS LEAD TO UNEMPLOYMENT RATES
AMONG MILITARY SPOUSES NEARLY
FOUR TIMES THAT OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION. THE BNP CODE
ALREADY CALLS FOR THE GRANTING
OF TEMPORARY LICENSES TO
MILITARY FAMILIES IN MOST
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS AS WELL
AS ENGINEERS LAND SURVEYORS
GEOLOGISTS. AB THIRTY FIVE
CREATES LICENSE PORTABILITY FOR
ALL OTHER LICENSES FOR BOTH
VETERANS AND ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY SPOUSES. AB THIRTY
FIVE IS NO OPPOSITION THE
SUPPORT BY THE U. S. DEPARTMENT
DEFENSE THE AMERICAN LEGION AND
THAT'S THE SAN DIEGO MILITARY
ADVISORY COUNCIL AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH SERVICES AT HOME AMONGST
OTHERS. I'M HONORED TO ADD
TODAY SOBRE PATTERSON IS A
JOINT AUTHORED AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER IS A PRINCIPAL
CO AUTHOR. WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT- BEYOND
THAT ON THE PHONE DISTORT
ALTERED OVERDUE SUMMER
PATTERSON FOR ANY COMMENTS HE
HAS FOR THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION RESPECT
LAST RIVAL. WHAT IS PRESENT
THANK YOU AND- VERY QUICK AT OF
THAT THANK YOU TO OPT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY FOR. LEADING OUT ON
THIS I ALSO APPRECIATED THE
GUIDANCE WITH RESPECT TO JOIN
IN- THE BILLS AND- DISCOVERED
THAT ADAMS ORIGINAL BILL WAS
SLIGHTLY BETTER THAN OURS.
WHICH HAD THE VETERANS IN IT AS
WELL AS THEIR SPOUSES THANK YOU
FOR THAT GUIDANCE THANK YOU FOR
THE SUPPORT SUPPORT MASK FOR
YOUR- AYE VOTE WITH TIME COMES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALSO MISTER
PATTERSON FOR YOUR
ACCOMMODATION IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE NAILED THE POLICIES
TOGETHER. IN ONE VEHICLE HAVING
SAID THAT WILL MOVE ON THEN TO
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL HAVE UP TO
TWO MINUTES FOR EACH MEMBER
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
AND FEEL FREE TO IS THAT
WHATEVER THE UP TO TWO MINUTES
EACH. YOU READY FOR THE PHONE
LINES ARE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE.
IN THE ROOM. THIS IS THE
PORTION OF BEING WERE ANY
WITNESSES KEY WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE HAVE UP
TO TWO MINUTES FOR KEY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT I HAVE A MISTER BOMBED
BOMBER AND A MISTER REAP AS OF
EITHER OF YOU ARE ABLE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. YOU
HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES EACH. SO
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO SPEAK
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. DO WE
HAVE A MISTER BALL MURDER
MISTER SEE MISTER REED AT ALL.
MILLER. HEARING HEARING NO KEY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHICH IN A SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF NAME IN
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE A NUMBER QUEUING UP.
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE. YES
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER IF YOU. YES
ONE MOMENT DIAPERS GIVEN THE
NUMBER. WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
EIGHTY ONE CAN YOU HEAR IT.
YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. FIVE
THREE FOUR THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS CALLING AND TO
REPRESENT MY CLIENT. AMERICAN
LEGION AMPAT. VETERAN FOUND-
NOT TERRY OPTIONS SHOULD FROM
AMERICA AND VIETNAM VETERANS.
ERICA WHO ARE ALL IN SUPPORT-
PANDEMIC TO SHOW THAT OUR
SERVICE MEMBERS HAVE A ROLE TO
PLAY IN THIS RESPONSE NATION
FIVE OR FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
MILITARY TROOPS AND NATIONAL
GUARD MEMBERS THE- FRACTION
OVER FORTY FOUR THOUSAND.
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED TO FIFTH OF NINETEEN.
THE FEDERAL. MILITARY COMPONENT
MOBILIZED URBAN AUGMENTATION
MEDICAL OUT FOR. ALONG WITH
POSSIBLE THE TAPE THE RECAP
WITHOUT THE- RIGHT THING AND
HELPED OTHERS HAVE. AFTER AND
THE ONLY IF STANDARD NOT ONLY
IF AND OUR COUNTRY BUT ITSELF
WITH WITH GIVE TO THE ACCOUNT.
OFTEN TELL THE A FRIEND. THEY
GIVE THEY'RE ALL NOT DO BUT THE
HURDLES AND- TO OBTAIN CAME
EMPLOYMENT DURING MILITARY DUTY.
REASSIGNMENT OR MOVE INTO A
AFTER STATE. IN HONG HOME
GETTING VETERAN ABOUT INFILL
WORK FORCE BACK INCREDIBLE
PUBLISHED BOB HOPE TO BE FOR
CA ON. A TWELVE PROVIDE
NEEDED BILLS TO COMMUNITY. THE
BILL MY CLIENT THAT ONLY
SUPPORT OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MAMA I TRY WIN AND WHEN I'M ON
TO THEM OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO ADD THEIR ME TO USE MEMBERS
OF THE WHICH AND VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT NAME AFFILIATION A YOU
WISH TO DO SO. ACTUAL LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AT. DANTE
PERSON ON BEHALF OF THE TRAVEL
COMMUNITY CONSORTIUM VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT. LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS KELLY MAY DOUGLAS I'M
WITH DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
STATE LIAISON OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. WE'LL GO LINE FIFTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CHANNELED THROUGH WHO KNOW.
YOUR CALIFORNIA DEPEND
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE REPRESENTING
ALL COMMUNITY SUPPORTED
MILITARY INSTALLATION AND WE
ARE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU I'M AT SEVEN.
THIS IS MEGAN ALL RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
NINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MARK DOWNWARD WITH THE SAN
DIEGO MILITARY ADVISORY
COUNCIL- WHERE A STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR THIS BILL THREE
ZERO FOUR FIVE WILL REALLY MAKE
A DIFFERENCE FOR OUR MILITARY
FAMILIES THANK YOU. AND LINE
EIGHTY FOUR. YES GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS FRAN PIECE I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
MILITARY LIAISON COUNSEL AND WE
ARE IN GREAT SUPPORTED THIS
MUCH NEEDED THEY'LL. THERE ARE
NO OTHER PEOPLE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR AND NOW THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. PRESS STAR ZERO TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. NOBODY IS
KILLING OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK
TO MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WILL BEGIN FIRST WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD
ASK THE- THE AUTHOR THE BILL
WITH YOU CAN PLEASE CONSIDER-
ADDING ME AS A CO AUTHOR THE BE
ALL THINGS TO GOOD BILL. I
THINK A MOVES IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND ALSO RECOGNIZE
OUR MILITARY THOSE WHO HAVE
FOUGHT FOR THIS COUNTRY SO. I
WOULD LOVE TO BE CONSIDERED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- SOMEONE AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA BILL
FOR THIS IS A GREAT BILL I LOVE
THIS BILL I REPRESENT A LARGE
NUMBER OF A MILITARY MEMBERS
BECAUSE OF. ALL THE MEAT THE
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS IN MY
DISTRICT. AND I CAN TELL YOU
THIS BILL SOLVES A VERY REAL
PROBLEM I LIKE TO JOIN MISTER
GIBSON. AND REQUESTING THAT I
BE ADDED A CO AUTHOR OF THE
ARTICLE OUT OF THIS BILL.
THANKS FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. SEEING
NONE. OF GERMAN WOULD DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE. THERE IS
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS WE
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION WOULD
BE HAPPY IF IT PLEASES THE
CHAIR TO OFFER. ANY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO JOIN AS CO
AUTHORS WE COULD- PROCESSES
COME OUT COMEDIAN AGAIN- THANK
YOU FOR THE HEARING
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR
IPHONE. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WILL MOST CERTAINLY
PROVIDE THAT OPPORTUNITY
ACCORDINGLY- IT ALSO WANT TO
THANK- THE AUTHORS FOR OF
BRINGING THIS BILL FOURTH.
ADDITIONALLY YOU COULD ALSO I
RECOGNIZE JUST IN TERMS OF A
PROCESS THAT AT THE MERGING OF
THE HOUSES IN THE SENATE BILL
IS ALSO AN IMPORTANT
CHARACTERISTIC- SHOULD THIS
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD SO
CERTAINLY LIKE TO. GIVE YOU A
GOOD SENSE TO MAKE IT TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION ALSO- AS THEY
WILL VANCE THIS HOUSE SO HAVING
SAID THAT THIS DOES ENJOY DO
PASSED COMMITTEE SECTOR. CALL
THE ROLL. AB THE FORTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I I'VE- I
ARAMBULA BLOOM GEN CAN I.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
FONG. FINE I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GLORIA GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN WHEN I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE TING. THE BILL IS
ON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. WHEN I MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN THIS IS AB%
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IS THERE IN
WHICH IS THE MISTER NAZARIAN
THIS DOES JOY ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES.
PLEASE FEEL FREE PRESENT
WHATEVER READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AYE
AYE I WILL TAKE THE HINT AND
KEEP IT VERY BRIEF THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL- WHICH
WILL EXTEND THE SENSE THAT THE
ON A PILOT PROGRAM WE PUT INTO
PLACE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THROUGH SB SIX ONE
THREE I APPRECIATE THE WORK
MISTER CHAIR OF YOUR COMMITTEE
AND YOUR INVOLVEMENT- HAPPY TO
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS AND THEN
COME BACK AND- AT A TIME WHEN
WE CAN HAVE A GREATER
DISCUSSION LINK YOUR
DISCUSSIONS- MOVE- MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD AND- POTENTIALLY-
THIS PROGRAM FORWARD AND GET
RID OF THE SUNSET DATE. AS WELL
PERMANENTLY SO WITH THAT I-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
BUT ALSO WITH ME ARE BILL
SPEAR- SENIOR DIRECTOR- FOR
ADVOCACY AND REGULATORY POLICY
FOR THE PLASMA PROTEIN
THERAPEUTICS ASSOCIATION AND
JOHN VALENCIA REPRESENTING BY A
LIFE TO KATO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE PORTION- OF
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OF KEY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT UP TO TWO MINUTES SO
WE'LL BEGIN WITH UP TO TWO
MINUTES FOR MISTER SPEAKER
FOLLOWED BY UP TO TWO MINUTES
FOR MISTER CLINTON. FREEDOM AND
WHENEVER READY. HELLO A NUMBER
THE COMMITTEE FOR COUNTRY
DOLLAR BILL. I'D LIKE TO SHARE
POWER WITH OPERATORS EXCEPT WE
PERFORMED MORE THAN THREE TO.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PILOTS
THAT. PILOT BEGAN THERE WERE
MORE THAN FIFTY MILLION TESTS
PERFORMED LAST YEAR AND THE
STATE THAT'S ALL OF THE PILOTS
VANTAGE. THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY
PATIENT ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING INDIVIDUALS WHO
RELY ON THEIR PIECE MADE FROM
PLASMA DONATION. RIGHT NOW IT'S
ONE THIRTY ONE THE CRITICAL
NEED FOR BLOOD TO PUTTING
THERAPIES HAS BEEN GROWING
STEADILY FOR MANY YEARS. NEED
HAS ONLY INCREASED UNDER COVER
NINETEEN. AND THERE HAVE BEEN.
MANY MUCH DISCUSSION AROUND THE
WORLD ABOUT THE ROLE OF COTTON
FORTY THERAPIES- BUT THEY COULD
PLAY IN TREATING CO THE
NINETEEN. FTA RECENTLY STATED
PLASMA DONATION CENTERS HAVE
EXPERIENCED A DRAMATIC
REDUCTION IN COLLECTIONS
HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED TO PATCH
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR AND THEIR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US AND I'M HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
VALENCIA. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JOHN VALENCIAN TO HAVE
TO GET A BY ALIVE PLASMA
MINDFUL OF THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION I WILL SAY
SIMPLY THAT WHILE WE MAKE
BETTER SENSE FOR RARE DISEASES
LIKE HEMOPHILIA AND PRIMARY
IMMUNE DEFICIENCY IN CALIFORNIA
WE DO NOT YET COLLECT A SINGLE
DROP. OF HUMAN DIRECT A PLASMA
FOR THAT PURPOSE THIS MEASURE
GOES A LONG WAY TO HELPING US
ENTER THE STATE AND TO
FACILITATE AN EXPANSION BY
OTHERS IN THE INDUSTRY I WILL
NOTE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS FEWER
PLASMA COLLECTION CENTER
STATEWIDE THAN NON NATION
STATES LIKE GEORGIA AND ALABAMA
LITTLE OWN TEXAS. ALSO THIS
BILL WILL ADDRESS AN IMPEDIMENT
TO US AS A COMPANY IN OUR
INDUSTRY IN OFFERING HIGH
QUALITY ENTRY LEVEL WELL PAYING
JOBS IN THE HEALTHCARE SECTOR
AT A TIME WHEN CALIFORNIANS ARE
MOST MORE THAN EVER LOOKING FOR
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES TO CATER BY
LIKE LAST MONTH RESPECT. BOTH
FOR THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL. SPEAKING
SUPPORT WE SIMPLY NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU DO SO MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT THAT. YES WE DO. I'M
SORRY NUMBER ONE I THEIR OWN.
THAT GENTLEMAN HAS LINE OPEN
YOU WANNA GO AHEAD SIR. FOR
THAT. OKAY WILL GO BACK TO THE
FOR MY DOG YEAH THEY- WE WILL
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ON
DELGADO ON BEHALF OF PERSONS
WITH TO BE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MIKE ALLEY BUT ALL REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MAUREEN HIGGINS- ON
BEHALF OF BIO COM IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. MOVING
ALONG TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT. WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU NEXT TO
A LINE EIGHTEEN. NINE EIGHTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DATING
AND DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY ONE
YES THANK YOU- THIS IS BRIAN
FADE AND WITH CSL BEHRING- IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND MY NINETY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. YES MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SECURITY CALGARY HELL WITH HE
MONTHLY ACCOUNT CALIFORNIA IS
STRONG SUPPORT. THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS CUED UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW MOVING
ON TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AGAIN THIS IS THE PORTION OF
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE LISTED IN
TERMS OF KEY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MISTER LANG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
YOU HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES
PLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CURSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
SEEING AS OPPOSED AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE WHICH WOULD ALLOW
UNLICENSED INDIVIDUALS TO
PERFORM A TOTAL PROTEIN TEST.
USING THE DIGITAL REFRACTOMETER
ENOUGH PLASMA COLLECTION
FACILITY. BUT SHIFTING WORK
THAT SHOULD BE DONE BY LICENSE
ANDEXPERIENCED PERSONNEL TO
UNLICENSED HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINETY
SKILLS THIS WORKFORCE INCREASE
POTENTIAL HEALTH RISKS. THE
TOTAL PROTEIN WITH PROCTER
METER TEST ISSUES PRIOR TO A
DONOR UNDERGOING
PLASMAPHERESIS. THIS TEST HELPS
UNDER A DETECTUNDERLYING
CONDITIONS THAT MAY CAUSE
COMPLICATIONS. IF THE TEST IS
PERFORMED INCORRECTLY
SIGNIFICANTLY SIGNIFICANT HARM
TO DONOR PATIENTS COULD RESULT.
THE FDA HAS CATEGORIZE THE
PROTEIN WITHOUT THE METER TEST
AS A MODERATE COMPLEXITY TASK.
INDICATING THAT IT'S NOT A
SIMPLE TASK WITH A LOW RISK FOR
YOUR AUDIENCE RESULTS. AS A
RESULT ONLY PROPERLY TRAINED
LIFE AND PERSONNEL SHOULD BE
PERFORMING THE TOTAL WE TRY TO
BE THERE PASSED. SUPPORTERS
HAVE NOT DEMONSTRATED THERE'S A
SHORT OF LICENSE IN ANY. AND
EXPERIENCE. AND EXPERIENCE
PERSONNEL DURING A REQUIREMENTS
CHANGE AND LAW. AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE SIMPLY NOT
NECESSARY. IN ADDITION IT IS
CLEAR THAT MANY RESERVE DID
MANUFACTURER THE DIGITAL
REFRACTOR METERS AND OTHER
BUSINESSES STAND TO GAIN
FINANCIALLY BY THIS BILL. DON'T
PATIENT OR OTHER AND WILL LOSE
FOR THESE REASONS NURSES ASSN
VOTE NO. ON AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK MISTER
MODERATOR MIGHT THERE BE ANY.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE TO
SPEAK IN NOT BEEN NAME AND
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO HOPE THAT
IT'S YOUR POSITION. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE FOR A FIRST LINE IN Q.
IF THERE ARE ANY OTHERS EMAIL
WILL PRESS ONE THAN THE ZERO.
GOAL TO LINE FORTY FIVE. LINE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
CAN MORNING TEN MEMBERS AND I
NEED A JEDI GRAY LAW AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE OF
THE W. WESTERN STATE COUNSEL IF
YOU W. WITH PREVIOUSLY OPPOSED
TO THE CELL AND WOULD LIKE TO
THINK THAT CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR TIRELESS
WORK ON THE BILL. YOU WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THINK THE OFFICE
FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH THAT BUT THEY COMMITTEE
PROPOSED AND ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS WE ARE NOT MUTUAL-
HOWEVER I THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS STATE THE FUNDS THAT
EXPECTED THESE AMENDMENTS TO
ALLOW CD PH TIME. RIGHT MORE
INFORMATION ON THE PILOT
PROGRAMS AT THE COMPLETE IF YOU
W. STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT THE
INFECTED AMENDMENT SAYS THAT
THEY BELIEVE THE TRAINING AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ARE
CRITICAL TO ENSURING PATIENTS
TAKING CARE AND SHOULD REMAIN
IN THE BELL INDEFINITELY
ADDITIONALLY IF YOU W. RESERVE
THE RIGHT TO CHANGE OUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AT THE MAD
MEN. IF THERE ARE AMENDMENTS IN
THE FUTURE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THAT THE FOUNDERS AND THE.
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. NO FURTHER
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW BRING
THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I TO
BE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
THING DONE THERE'S ALSO BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DESERT DO WISH
TO CLOSE. UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I. JUST TO BRIEFLY GIVE A
RESPONSE- THE ORIGINATING- BILL
EIGHTY SIX ONE THREE FROM TWO
YEARS AGO DID NOT REQUIRED. THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH TO DO
REPORT. WE HAVE ASKED FOR A
REPORT- WE MIGHT POTENTIALLY BE
GETTING SOMETHING. AS BY AUGUST
GIVEN WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT
NOW. THEY'VE THE PART OF A- A
PUBLIC HEALTH IS A LITTLE
BACKED UP SO- MIGHT- WE- HOPE.
TO GET SOME NUMBERS AND DATA.
BY AUGUST SO THAT WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE THE EFFICACY OF
THIS MOVING FORWARD. AND ALSO
COME BACK IN A FUTURE TIME TO.
ADDRESS SOME OTHER ISSUES AS
WELL SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THIS DOES ENJOY TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND THE
COMMITTEE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS. TO WORK ON
THESE ISSUES AND TO. ADDRESS
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION'S
SIMILAR CONCERNS. AND WE ARE
EQUALLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATIVE WORK OF YOUR OFFICE
AS WELL. IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
SO. HAVING SAID THAT THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SIX THREE PLEASE CALL
THE- AB TWENTY. NINE NINE
MOTION IS PASTOR APPROPRIATE.
LOW I. LOW HIGH BROW. BRO I
ARAMBULA. BLOOM CHAN CHAN I TO
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN. WOULD YOU
LIKE EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG I
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA I AM
MULLIN. OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
TEN. WELL THAT'S THE BOTTOM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE THIS IS AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL. GEN THIS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY PLEASE FEEL FREE 2%
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. BUT GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO. PRESENT AT THIRTY THREE
THIRTY. WHICH WILL GIVE LOCAL
OFFICIALS THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO PREVENT ILLEGAL CANNABIS
SALES. THROUGH ONLINE
DIRECTORIES. EVER SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION TWO
FIFTEEN AND SIXTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA HAS WRESTLE WITH HOW
TO BEST REGULATE ITS LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. THROUGH
SEVERAL PIECES OF LANDMARK
LEGISLATION THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED THEM THE MEDICINE ALL
AN ADULT USE CANNABIS
REGULATION AND SAFETY ACT. THIS
ACT WAS BUILT ON THREE KEY
PRINCIPLES PROMOTING ILLEGAL
CANNABIS. NINE CAN PROMOTE
ILLEGAL CANNABIS CELLS TO WORK
WITH REGULATORS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROTECTING
CONSUMERS SOME OF WHOM NEED
CANNABIS TO TREAT SEVERE
MEDICAL CONDITIONS AND ENSURING
LOCAL INTRO OVER CAN'T I WERE
HEALTH CANNABIS IS GROWN AND
SOLD IN A GIVEN COMMUNITY. AS
IS BURGEONING INDUSTRY HAS
CONTINUED TO EVOLVE A NEW
BUSINESS MODELS HAVE PRESENTED
NEW CHALLENGES TO UPHOLDING
THESE PRINCIPLES. IN RECENT
YEARS CANNABIS RETAILERS BEGAN
USING ONLINE ADVERTISING AND
HOSTING PLATFORMS TO REMOTE
THEIR BUSINESSES AND FIND NEW
CUSTOMERS. WELL THIS IS
PROVIDED MORE OPTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS IT IS ALSO PROVIDED
UNLICENSED CANNABIS SELLERS
WITH A NEW OPPORTUNITY TO
BYPASS STATE AND LOCAL CANNABIS
REGULATIONS. BY CONNECTING
THROUGH THESE ONLINE PLATFORMS
ILLEGAL OPERATIONS CAN DELIVER
CANNABIS ACROSS CITY AND COUNTY
LINES WITHOUT A LICENSE WELL
THE STORE FOR. IT WITHOUT
FOLLOWING ANY OTHER REQUIRED
SAFETY PROCEDURES INCLUDING
EXTENSIVE TESTING OF THE
CAMPUS. BY AVOIDING THESE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BITING THE
LAW THESE ILLICIT SELLERS HAVE
GAINED AN UNFAIR ADVANTAGE OVER
LICENSE OPERATIONS. IN ADDITION
THERE TRANSIENT NATURE MAKES
INVESTIGATIONS LONG AND COSTLY
AFFAIRS ACROSS MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS THAT RARELY HAVE
A LASTING IMPACT EVEN IF THEY
ARE SUCCESSFUL. TO CURTAIL
THESE UNLICENSED SELLERS WE
MUST CUT THEM OFF FROM THE
THING ALLOWING THEM TO SELL
THEIR ILLICIT GOODS. THEIR
ONLINE ADVERTISING. AB THIRTY
THREE DOES THIS BY MAKING A
PUBLIC NUISANCE. TO COLLECT A
FEE TO ADVERTISE OR PROMOTE A
SAILOR CANNABIS IN VIOLATION OF
THE MEDICINAL AND ADULT USE
CANNABIS REGULATION AND SAFETY
ACT. THIS WILL ALLOW LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO BRING ABATEMENT
ACTIONS REMOVING THE ADS IN
QUESTION AND STOPPING THE
ILLEGAL SALES IN THEIR TRACKS.
JOINING ME BY PHONE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS STEVE NEAL FROM
LONG BEACH THE LONG BEACH
COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION AND
DOUGLAS HOWARD HOWARD THE LONG
BEACH CITY PROSECUTOR- MISTER
CHECK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO KEY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AGAINST THE WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT WE HAVE TWO LISTED
UP TO TWO MINUTES EACH. AND IT
WILL BEGIN WITH MISTER NEAL.
GOOD A GOOD MORNING AND OUT
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
LOW AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
OUT WE STAND THE STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE LEGISLATION THE LONG
BEACH THE A BC EIGHT WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS- ON THIRD LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD. IN THE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKETS AS ALL OF YOU
KNOW THE LIFTED MARKET HAS
NEARLY 80% OF CANNABIS FAILED
SO. BAD IN ITSELF IS A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE. AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY GIVE OF ANOTHER TOOL AND
JURISDICTION TO COMBAT THE LIST
OF MARK SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE ITEM THE BILL PROVIDES
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND THAT
ALSO STRENGTHENED THE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET AND- WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO MISTER
HUBBARD AND- THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH OR THE PROTECTION OF LONG
BEACH. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN LOW-
I AM THE CITY PROSECUTOR FOR
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH MY
OFFICE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR AND
FOURTEEN STATE AND LOCAL LAW.
AND I'VE BEEN OUT TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE
A. B. THIRTY THREE THIRTY IS
BOTH LAWFUL AND EFFECTIVE AND
HAS WRITTEN IT IS POLL. AS
BACKGROUND- ON THE PROBLEM FOR
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND CITIES
LIKE LONG BEACH. HAVE ATTEMPTED
TO CREATE A REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT WHERE CANNABIS IN
CANNABIS PRODUCTS ARE ARE GROWN
MANUFACTURE TRANSPORTED AND
SOLD IN A SAFE MANNER WORDS
KEPT OUT OF THE HANDS OF
CHILDREN. WHERE NEIGHBORHOOD
IMPACTS ARE MINIMIZED IN WORK
CONSUMERS I GET CANNABIS THAT
IS SAFE AND TESTED AND FREE OF
HARMFUL PESTICIDES. THAT THAT
ENTIRE REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT-
COLLAPSES IN CANNOT EXIST- IF
THERE CONTINUES TO BE A
PROLIFERATION OF UNLAWFUL
DISPENSARIES AND DELIVERY
SERVICES. FOR THE LAST YEAR MY
OFFICE HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
SIGNIFICANT INVESTIGATIONS OF
THE PROBLEM AND WHAT POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS EXIST. AND WE FOUND
THAT THE KEY TO STOPPING
UNLAWFUL DISPENSARIES AND
DELIVERY SERVICES IS TO REIN IN
THEIR ABILITY TO REACH
CONSUMERS THROUGH ADVERTISING.
AND MARKETING. I AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY PROHIBITS A PERSON
FROM COLLECTING COMPENSATION
FOR ADVERTISING OR MARKETING
THE SAILOR PROVISION OF
CANNABIS ARE CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
UNLESS THE SAILOR PROVISION IS
IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
LOCAL CANNABIS LAWS. IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTION ABOUT THE EXTENT
OF THE PROBLEM OR THE URGENCY
OF THE PROBLEM LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET HAD ORIGINALLY ESTIMATED
APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN REVENUE FROM THE
LEGAL TALE CANNABIS HOWEVER THE
ILLICIT MARKET. BECAME SO LARGE
THAT THE STATE LOST UPPER SIX
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS.
REVENUE BILL THAT'S REVENUE
THAT OF ESPECIALLY IN TODAY'S
ENVIRONMENT THE STATE CAN'T
AFFORD TO LOSE. I WITHOUT
CONCLUDING JUST BANK I THINK
THE SIMPLY MEMBER. AND ALSO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF- MISTER SUMNER
WHOSE- WORK WITH US ON NON THE
BILL AS WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES KEY WITNESS TESTIMONY
WE NOW MOVE ON TO THAT PORTION
TO WHICH MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
MAY WISH TO SPEAK. SIMILARLY IN
SUPPORT NAME AND AFFILIATION
ONLY IF YOU WISH TO DO SO
MISTER MODERATOR ARE THE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
BUT. ALL FIVE. ALL RIGHT THE
PEOPLE AT THE OF ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ONE
MOMENT. AGAIN LIKE INSTRUCTIONS
ARE ONE THEN ZERO IN LINE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GROW
WITH YOU AT THE W. ACTIVATE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT YEAH.
ONLINE NINETY SEVEN NINE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN SECOND I
NINETY SEVEN ON THE OTHER. MY
YES HELLO MY NAME IS OUT OF THE
JAZZ THE PRESIDENT THE LONG
BEACH COLLECTIVIST SO STATION
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THAT
BILL. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH
SEVEN ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RESEARCHER MEMBERS RANT
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CMG COOLEY
OF A MAJOR VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CAMERAS COMPANY IN
SAN JOSE AND SUPPORT. THERE IS
ADDITIONAL LINE UP THE
MICROPHONE HERE BE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE MY UNDER THE
OTHER WITNESSES TO MEET YOUR
PHONE LINE WILL NOT SPEAK IN
THAT OTHER LINE DISCONNECTED
MISTER TERRY MAY CONTINUE. OKAY
HEARING NO OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE
SUBMITTED INDIVIDUAL WITH
RESPECT TO OPPOSITION FOR KEY.
TESTIMONY FOR UP TO TWO MINUTES
AND THAT IS MISTER MILLER SO
MISTER MILLER UP TO TWO MINUTES
IN OPPOSITION. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GEORGE MILLER ON BEHALF
BELIEVE MAPS- THAT WAS EXPRESS
OUR OPPOSITION MAYBE THIRTY
THIRTY THIRTY AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. A SIMPLE MAN AND IN
ITS CURRENT FORM THIS
LEGISLATION HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO CAPTURE. ACROSS MULTIPLE
MEDIA PLATFORMS WHO ARE NOT
INTENSELY SUPPORTING THE
ILLICIT CANNABIS MARKET PLACE.
WELL THIS LEGISLATION DOES NOT
TACKLE THE PRICE PARITY. AND
DEMAND FACTORS THAT LARGELY
FEEL THE I'M LICENSE MARKET
PLACE IT DOES THIS INCENTIVIZE
AND PUNISH INDIVIDUALS AND
ENTITIES THAT ARE SUPPORTING
ELLIS ITSELF THROUGH
ADVERTISING OR MARKETING. WE
APPLAUD THE OP THERE FOR HIS
ATTEMPTS TO DO SO.
UNFORTUNATELY AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN IT DOES NOT FACTORED IN
THAT OR THE LACK THEREOF. OF
ANY SUCH ENTITY TO AID AND I'M
LICENSE CAMERAS BUT SO C. IF
YOU MAY BE AWARE WITH MAPS IS
WORK TO REMOVE ON LICENSE
BUSINESSES. FROM OUR PLATFORM
AND CONTINUE TO DO SO. WITH
STATE REGULATOR TO AND THAT IN
AVERAGE. IN THE STATE OF OUR OF
THE WAY BUSINESSES ADDITIONALLY
WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED PROCESSES.
TO ALLOW FOR THE FLYING OF
ADVERTISEMENTS THAT ARE
SUSPECTED TO BE FROM- LICENSE
BUSINESSES SPECIFICALLY WE
ENCOURAGE ANYONE TO FIGHT THIS
MISSUS ACTIVITY. DIRECTLY ON
OUR WEBSITE. WE THAT WE ALSO
WORK WITH THE STATE'S DATABASES
AN ADVERTISER TO RECTIFY ANY
DISCREPANCIES IF CORRECTIVE
ACTION ON AN ACCURATE
INFORMATION DOES NOT SUFFICE OR
ABOUT LICENSE NUMBER IS NOT
PROVIDED THE ADVERTISEMENTS
PROBABLY REMOVE MARK. FOR
UNFORTUNATELY. WITHOUT
FACTORING IN TEN INTO INTENT AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY. LEAVES NO
ROOM TO REMEDY ANY EMISSIONS
THAT STEM FROM A LAPSE IN
LICENSURE OR POSSIBLE TIME
BUFFERS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
SPEED IN WHICH INFORMATION IS
ADDED TO OR REMOVED FROM THE
STATE DATABASE BY REGULATORS AS
SUCH WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. IN ITS CURRENT
FORM. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ROSA HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL A KEY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION AND WE
UNDERSTAND THIS- MISS LOBAR
PLEASE UP TO TWO MINUTES
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. AGAIN
MENTAL OVER ONE MORE PLEASE YET
YEAH. WE HAVE A LINE CONNECTED
WELCOME. MISS WALKER PLEASE
READ STARTLED. OKAY AT MISTER
KERRY MEMBERS MY NAME IS MEGAN
LOPER AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PROGRAM FOR
TIGHTENING EACH AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIRTY
THREE THIRTY. WE CERTAINLY
RESPECT THE UTHOR'S DESIRE TO
COMBAT UNLESS. EMPATHIZE WITH
OUR MEMBERS WHO TRAVEL BUT THE
CHALLENGES OF UNLIKELY
BILLBOARDS BUT FAILED TO COMPLY
WITH OUR MEETING LICENSING AND
SPEAKING REQUIREMENTS NOW
DROWNED PROTECT ACT. SHE HAD
THE CONVERSATIONS THE AUTHOR
HIS STAFF AND THE CURRENT DATE
BUT HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
RESOLVE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE MEASURE IN
PRACTICE. AND I'LL BE HEARD
EIGHTY ANYTHING. MMHM CIVIL
LIABILITY ON MEDIA COMPANIES
INCLUDING THOSE AND OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING INDUSTRY EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE NOT SURE THAT OUR
INDUSTRY IS INVOLVED WITH THE
COMPLIANCE ISSUES THAT HAVE%
BEEN CITED RELATED ONLINE-
ADVERTISING- ARE WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED WHEN. THE AB
PENALTIES- ADDRESS THIRTY SOME
DOLLARS FOR EACH VIOLATION ON
MEDIA COMPANIES AND IF I'M
LICENSE OPERATORS MIGHT FOR AND
BURDEN PUBLISH AN ATTIC AND
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES OUTDOOR
ADVERTISERS TO DISPLAY THE
LICENSE NUMBER OF THE HAMMOND
LIGHTEN BUT NO MORE. AB
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ADVERTISEMENT AND IT IS THE
PRACTICE OF THE MEMBERS OF THAT
THE OTHER WAY REQUIRE CANNABIS
ADVERTISERS TO PROVIDE A PROPER
LICENSE NUMBER FOR ANY PROPOSED
AT. WE REMAIN VERY CONCERNED
HOWEVER THAT WE DO NOT HAVE A
DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
BUREAU CANNABIS CONTROL AND
WILL NOT HAVE ANY WAY TO KNOW
THE LICENSE ADVERTISER HAD A
LICENSE REVOKED OR SUSPENDED
AFTER CONTRACT. NINE FURTHER WE
POINTED PAGE TWO OF THE
ANALYSIS THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE
BILL THE BY. PUBLIC NUISANCES
ALLOWING ANY MAY OF THE- BRING
AN ACTION FOR A BI. WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THIS COULD LEAD
TO EXTENSIVE LEGAL EXPENSES OR
PRESSURE TO ENTER SETTLEMENT
EVEN WHEN OUR MEMBERS MAY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PREVAIL. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF HAVING
EAGLE RULES FOR ALL MEDIA HI
CURRENT LAW ALREADY
DIFFERENTIATE. BETWEEN MEDIA
BASED ON EACH UNIQUE PLATFORMS
CHARACTERISTICS OUT FOR OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING FOR EXAMPLE IS
SUBJECT TO LAWS REQUIRING
LICENSE NUMBER. THE THING
REQUIREMENTS FROM STATE
BOUNDARIES PARKS. GIVEN THE
DIVERSE WAY AND WHAT'S
DIFFERENT MEDIA REACHES ITS
BODY ANSWER THE QUESTION
WHETHER IT'S POSSIBLE OR
APPROPRIATE TO SUBJECT ALL
ADVERTISING MEDIA CHU IDENTICAL
REGULATION. IN CONCLUSION LIKE
SO MANY INDUSTRIES DURING THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMICS OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
HIT HARD AS ADVERTISERS HAVE
BUDGET. ASK FOR DISCOUNTS USING
THE SHELTER IN PLACE ORDER THE
JUSTIFICATION BUT YOUR
CONSUMERS ARE SEEING BILLBOARDS
OR CANCEL CONTRACT ALL
TOGETHER. CANNABIS IS A LEGAL
PRODUCT IN THE STATE AND MANY
OF OUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
PLACE ADS FOR LIFE AND-
CANNABIS COMPANIES. WE ARE WHAT
CHERNOBYL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MCH ANSWER ANY QUESTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. AT THE ON THE
PORTION TO WHICH YOU CAN
PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO MISTER MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. A PRESS ONE THEN
THE ROUTE THIS TIME. TO HAVE A
FEW LINES IN Q. ONE MOMENT. A
MOVE FIRST TO LINE WON ALL FOUR
ONE ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ACTUALLY THEN THAT ONE OF CARE
MEMBER I ACTUALLY ONE OF FOUR
COULD YOU START OVER. A YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOE CRUISE ON. BEHALF
OF DISPLAYS. GENERAL OUTDOOR
LAMAR ADVERTISING METAL STOCK.
AND BILL OUTDOOR ADVERTISING
WERE COALITION A FAMILY OWNED
AND OPERATED OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING COMPANY. WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
GOAL OF AB THIRTY THIRTY
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO OPPOSE THE BILL AT THIS TIME
AND WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
OURSELVESWITH COMMENTS MADE BY
T. S. AWAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. LINE ONE OH TWO ONE ZERO
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LEADING AS FAR SAUDI WITH THE
CULT BUT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
THESE PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG OPPOSITION SB.
THIRTY THREE THIRTY FOR THE
REASONS OUTLINED BY PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY FULLY URGE YOUR NOTE.
LINE ONE SIXTEEN ONE ONE SIX
WITH YOUR. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS MARK WITH DATA
BACK HERE I HAVE LOOKED CLEAR
CHANNEL OUTDOOR WE'D LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
ASSOCIATION AND- HOSTED. THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES
IN Q. AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BACK TO THE
CONVERSATION TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME WE BEGIN WITH. VICE CHAIR
BRO FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON. MR DONALD THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
MANY OF US IN THIS BODY BEEN
FIGHTING THE ILLEGAL GROW IN
THE LEGAL SALE OF MARIJUANA THE
LAWN FOR GIVING LAW ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS MORE- ABILITY TO GO AFTER
OTHER BAD ACTORS. I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU SIR ARE YOU TAKING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. I CAN'T
COMMIT TO ANY SPECIFIC
AMENDMENTS TODAY. I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION I THINK I DON'T WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITE PROBABLY GOT
OFF THE COURT BEFORE QUITE
FRANKLY- BUT THERE IS- THERE.
I'VE GONE THROUGH I'VE BEEN
I'VE MET WITH THE OPPOSITION MY
OFFICE MATE WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND I WILL COMMIT TODAY TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
GOING FORWARD BUT THERE ARE
SOME LEGITIMATE CONCERNS THAT
THE OPPOSITION AND BROUGHT UP.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THE PROBLEM IS
SOME OF THE MEMBERS THEY SHARED
WITH US ACTUALLY GOT OF THE
WHOLE INTENT OF THE BILL AND
ACTUALLY WORKS AGAINST THE
INTENT OF THE BILL. WORKING
TOGETHER AND I COMMIT TODAY
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER ON BY STATE MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON THANK
YOU MISTER JUDGES WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR JUST NOW
COMMITTING TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION CONTINUING FORWARD.
ESPECIALLY WITH THOSE THAT
DEALING WITH CHALLENGES IN
PRINT. AND BILLBOARD SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME IT'S
FIFTY NINE. SEVERAL DANTE WAS
TO CLOSE YES MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU- ALL JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE AND I REITERATE
THAT I DO WISH TO WORK- COMMIT
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER O'DONNELL I'D ALSO LIKE
TO STE OF ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
ALSO. INDICATE THAT WHEN YOU
AND I HAVE BEEN IN DISCUSSION
EARLY ON ABOUT THE INTENSE AND
SUPPORTING THE INTENT AND ALSO
ADDRESSING. THE ISSUES OUTLINED
BY OPPOSITION IN GOOD FAITH AND
CONSUME AFFORD I'LL BE VERY
MUCH LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU AND
ADDRESSING THOSE ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS. MOVING FORWARD SO
THIS DOESN'T JOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. IS THERE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. THIS
MOTION BY DOCTOR RAMBLER SECOND
BY MISTER GRAYSON TWENTY SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY IN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HI. LOW HI BRO. FOR OT VOTING
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI BLOOM CHEN.
CHEN NOT VOTING TO CUNNINGHAM
EGGMAN. FONG. FIND OUT VOTING
GIPSON. GLORIA GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN. WELL THE NOT VOTING
IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE MEDINA. MEDINA NOT VOTING
MULLIN. OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NOT
VOTING TING. THAT WAS ON CALL
THE BILL IS ON CALL WILL LEAVE
THE- WILL OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR ABOUT WHAT NOW THEN
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN. WHICH IS AB EIGHT
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE TODAY I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR CONTINUED WORK DURING
THIS UNIQUE LEGISLATIVE SESSION
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN DE LEóN
INTRODUCED AND PASSED EIGHTY
NINETY NINE A BILL WHICH ADDED
MATRICULA CONSULAR TO THE LIST
OF ACCEPTABLE ID'S FOR. HELLO
THIS. FUTURE LEGISLATION
CREATED THE CALIFORNIA PALM-
SECONDHAND DEALERS SYSTEM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAPS. THE
SYSTEM IS A SINGLE STATEWIDE
REPORTING SYSTEM OPERATED BY DO
GA. WHERE INFORMATION AND
TRANSACTIONS ARE RECORDED. IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS THERE ARE
INDICATIONS THAT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THE CAPS IS
REPORTING SYSTEM IS BEING
COMPROMISED FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT USE. MY PRETTY GOOD LUCK
ON SELECT AS A FORM OF
IDENTIFICATION. A SIGNIFICANT
PATTERN HAVE EMERGED WHERE BY A
CUSTOMER WHO USES THE MY
PARTICULAR COMES ALIVE. IN A
POND LOAN BECOMES  PERSON OF
INTEREST IN AT THE IMMIGRATION
AND NATURALIZATION SERVICES.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
CONTINUED EFFORT TO PROTECT OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WE CAN
ONLY- BUT THE CONCLUSION THAT
THIS INFORMATION IS BEING
RELEASED BY A SMALL GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH ACCESS TO
CAPS. THIS LET US BE CLEAR ON
THIS BILL THE PUMP. I WOULD
LOCALLY. AND READ AL OF THE
BECAUSE FROM. WE CURRENTLY DO
EVERY PART OF CURRENTLY TO THE
TWO CATS. HOWEVER IF A
MATRICULA CONSULAR WAS USED AS
ID PERSONAL INFORMATION WOULD
BE RETAINED LOCALLY FIVE NUMBER.
TO ACCESS THIS INFORMATION LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN SIMPLY REQUEST
BE OMITTED INFORMATION FROM THE
SPECIFIC BROKER THAT WAS
LOCALLY RETAIN. AB NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE IS A VERY MILD AND
SIMPLE STAFF IT WILL PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES FROM ENTITIES
THAT ARE NOT USING THE CAP
SYSTEM. AS INTENDED WITHOUT
PLACING UNDUE STRESS ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS.
HERE WITH ME TODAY SPEAKING I
HAVE MISTER BILL TO PLEASE THEM
WHO WILL SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FARMWORKERS THE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WELL MISTER TO PLACE YOU WILL
THAT ALLOW UP TO A TWO MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU COMING BACK TO
THE FLOOR. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
SURE GERMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
COME TALK ABOUT A VERY NEEDED
BILL. NEEDED VERY MUCH THERE'S
A AS IT GOES ON BECAUSE IT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
AND HER STAFF MAKING THIS
POSSIBLE. WHEN THE MATRICULA
CONSULAR CAME IN IN NINETEEN-
TWO THOUSAND I'M DATING MYSELF
THERE TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
THE SITUATION GOT VERY GOOD FOR
THE CAPS SYSTEM OVER THE O. J.
BECAUSE IT ENCOURAGE MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE TO COME WITH
LEGITIMATE IDENTIFICATION
RATHER THAN USING CIRCUITS
THINGS OF THAT NATURE. I JUST
WANT TO TELL YOU. IF THIS WERE
TO SEIZE HAPPENING. ABOUT THIS-
IT'S NOT WELL UNDERSTOOD AND I
KNOW THAT SOME OF THE FOLKS
THAT HAVE- OPPOSED TO. HAVE A-
ARTICULATED HOW THIS SITUATION
WILL GO. VERBALLY TO MEMBERS
OFFICES AND MEMBERS AND AS JUST
ISN'T JUST AIN'T THAT WAY IT'S
JUST NOT THAT WAY AT ALL I
WONDER EXPLAIN THAT ONE IN PALM
BROKER RECEIVES AN ITEM FROM
SOMEONE USING A MATRICULA
CONSULAR AS THEIR FOR A FORM OF
IDENTIFICATION WHICH IS THEIR
RIGHT. THEY TAKE THAT ITEM IN
THE REPORTS THAT WE GENERATE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE BOTH
PERSONAL INFORMATION AND
PROPERTY INFORMATION. AND THE
WHOLE BEING OF THE WHOLE WHOLE
EXISTENCE OF REPORTING IS FOR
PROPERTY- REPORTING AND IT'S
THE AUSPICES THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS. TO GET THESE
LOCAL MISSION. THIS BILL IS FOR
THE NEXT THE- THESE MISTER
DEPOSIT. ANYWAY TO GET THESE
REPORTS IN THE FIRST PLACE- AND
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE NOT
WARRANTLESS REPORTS IN THAT
CASE WARNER SIR WARRANTLESS
SEIZURE. THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER WHO'S LOOKING THROUGH A
PROPERTY REPORT AND HE SEES-
HERE'S A ROLEX WATCH THAT I
HAVE SINCE SOME CURIOSITY
ABOUT- BUT THERE'S NO PERSONAL
INFORMATION. BECAUSE WITH THE
MATRICULA CONSULAR- BOND
BROKERS WILL NOT HAVE TO BE
GIVING PERSONAL INFORMATION.
THE ONLY HAVE TO TRANSMIT THE
PROPERTY INFORMATION WHEN THEY
DO THAT THIS THE NAME OF THE
PAWNBROKER THE PHONE NUMBER THE
PAWNBROKER THE- EMAIL ADDRESS
THE PAWNBROKER WILL BE RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THEM ON THAT SCREEN IT
RUNS CONTINUOUSLY. IN FRONT OR
BEHIND THE SCREEN I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW THAT WORKS BUT- AND
THEY CAN SIMPLY CALL THEY CAN
TAXED THEY CAN EMAIL. TELL ME
SOMETHING- CALL ME OF-
IMMEDIATELY ABOUT THE REPORT
NUMBER NOW THAT EITHER THE- AND
THE PAWNBROKER HAS TO COMPLY
IMMEDIATELY. SO ALL THIS DOES
IS DELAY THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION TRANSMITTAL. BUT
ALL OF THE PROPERTY INFORMATION
IS THERE FROM THE VERY FIRST
REPORT. ANYWAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NUMBER NON TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. NAME AND AFFILIATION
ONLY IF YOU WISH TO DO SO. IF
YOU DO WISH TO DO SO IN A PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NO LINES
IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
NO SUBMITTED KEY WITNESSES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME BUT WOULD ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WISH TO. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THERE.
IS THE LEAST ONE LINE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WHAT ABOUT GO TO
LINE ONE TWO FOUR ONE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR KERRY MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
BORDERLINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. BEGIN
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
WHEN I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND-
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL- BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
KEEP INFORMATION LIKE MATRICULA
A CONFIDENTIAL. OTHERWISE WE
UNDERMINE ITS EXISTENCE SO I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT WILL BE A
VOTING I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND IS THIS
FOR MY OWN CLARIFICATION I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT- AS WAS
DESCRIBED BY THE WITNESS- THE
PROPERTY PART OF THE REPORT
STAYS THE SAME. THE ITEMS ARE
STILL REPORTED ONLY THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION IS LISTED
AS ON FILE FOR THE AGENCY TO
REQUEST IF THEY SO CHOOSE
ABSOLUTELY YES THIS DOESN'T-
HINDER THE ABILITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO READ THE
REQUESTED INFORMATION. IT'S
REALLY JUST KEEPING A COMPANY
THàNH IF THEY NEED THAT THEY
NEED TO THEY CAN CALL THE
PAWNBROKER WHICH IS WHAT THE
INFORMATION IS LISTED ON THE
CAP SYSTEM WE SIMPLY JUST CAN
GET THE INFORMATION AS- THEY
WOULD AND- THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. SEEING
NONE. FIFTY TO PLEASE THE
HOPEFULLY BE SEATS LOOKED JUST
AS COMFORTABLE AS THEY WERE
BACK WHEN YOU WERE SERVING IN
THIS INSTITUTION- THERE IS BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND ASSEMBLY
WOMAN REVIEW IF YOU WISH TO
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NOT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AS
I CAN'T COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE THE MOTION
IS PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HI LOW HI BRO. I ARAMBULA.
BLOOM GEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING EGGMAN EGGMAN I FONG.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA. WAY I
GRAYSON GRAYSON I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
MULLIN. OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
NOTING. IN QUEBEC THE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I. AS FOLLOWS THE BILL
ISN'T THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN THIS IS AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO I SOMEONE
AND- WOMEN RUBIO THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
FOR SOMETHING I. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. YES
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT- ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AN ACT RELATING
TO EFFORTS AS ENFORCEMENT OF MY
LIFE IS KIND OF HIS BUSINESSES.
AS YOU KNOW THE SENATE- THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEGAN
ISSUING LICENSES AT THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
FOR KIND OF ITS BUSINESSES TO
OPERATE IN THE STATE. I TO DATE
THIS BY SOME SUCCESS THE SINGLE
BIGGEST ISSUE WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LEGAL
KIND OF ITS MARKET. IS THAT WE
HAVE THE WRITING LEVEL ILLEGAL
MARKET- ACCORDING TO RECENT
REPORTS EAGLE FEATHERS IN
CALIFORNIA OUTNUMBERED LEGAL.
BUSINESSES NEARLY THREE TO ONE
THIS REPORT FOUND THAT WHILE
CALIFORNIA CANISTERS
COLLECTIVELY PRODUCE ABOUT NINE
MILLION POUNDS OF CAMPUS PER
YEAR. BUT THE MAN IN THE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET CAN ONLY
SUPPORT ONE POINT EIGHTY TWO
POINT TWO MILLION POUNDS PER
YEAR. THIS LEAVES ABOUT 80% OF
THE CROP EITHER TO BE DESTROYED
OR TO. MAKE ITS. WAY TO THE
ILLICIT MARKET. IF ARE PUT THE-
OF THE LEGAL CAN MARKET AROUND
EIGHT POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR ALL OF THIS
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IS BOTH
CONTACTED UNREGULATED. IN
ADDITION TO TWENTY IN TAX
REVENUES THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
REPRESENTS SERIOUS PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS TO OUR COMMUNITY. NEWS
ARTICLES FROM AROUND THE STATE
HAVE DOCUMENTED VIOLENCE AND
CRIME ON THE UP AT LEAST A
LICENSE DISPENSARIES. IN
ADDITION THE CANNABIS PRODUCTS
SOLD AT THESE LOCATIONS DOES
NOT MEET ESTABLISH QUALITY
STANDARDS AN INMATE. STATE
TESTING. AS WE CAN SEE HERE
TODAY COMBATING THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET IS A KEY POLICY GOAL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR. THIS
BILL WILL TARGET THE ILLICIT
MARKET BY CREATING CIVIL
PENALTIES FOR INDIVIDUALS FOUND
TO BE AIDING AND ABETTING THE
SALE OF A LICENSE CANDIDATES.
EXAMPLES OF AB AND ABETTING BE
AN ADVERTISER WHO NOT ONLY AND
INTENTIONALLY DIRECT BUSINESSES
TO ANALYZE THIS SHOP AS WELL AS
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE PAST YEARS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE COULD BE A
PROPERTY OWNER WHO KNOWINGLY
ACCEPT CASH TO EASE HIS OR HER
PROPERTY FOR ANY LEGAL SHOP TO
OPERATE. THE FACILITY. AT THE
LEGISLATURE WE CANNOT SAY THAT
WE ARE TAKING THE CANNABIS
BLACK MARKET SERIOUSLY. IF WE
ALLOW THE UNDERGROUND PROMOTION
ADVERTISEMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
PEOPLE BUSINESSES. TO EXIST
WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE. WE KNOW
THAT THESE ADVERTISEMENTS AND
PROPERTY OWNERS DRIVE BUSINESS
WITH EQUAL OPERATORS. AND WE
MUST FIND A WAY TO RESTRICT
THESE PRACTICE PRACTICES. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY AND I WILL NOW
TURN THE MIKE OVER TO OUR
SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS. TO OUR
OUR TODAY ARE THAT THE- BEHALF
OF A UFC W. AND- KING. WHO WILL
BE. ON BEHALF OF THE U. KIND OF
THIS. IS THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF. THE FOR THE TWO
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AS KEY WITNESSES YOU'LL
HAVE. NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
WE'LL BEGIN WITH MR TARIQ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
AFTERNOON. OTHER TO RECALL GAP
FOR UNITED PUT A COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WHAT YOU'RE STATES
COUNCIL. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE SKIN
YOUR STAFF OF COURSE FOR YOUR
TIRELESS WORK ON THIS BILL AND-
ONE POINT I WANTED TO I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR BECAUSE SHE'S
BEEN- SHE'S BEEN A STAUNCH.
ADVOCATE FOR TRYING TO. CUT
DOWN ON THE ILLICIT MARKET
PLACE WHICH IS EXTREMELY
DAMAGING AND DANGEROUS. TO THE
PUBLIC FOR THAT MATTER. UNITED
FRUIT COMMERCIAL WORKERS A BIT
AND- INVOLVED IN THE CANNABIS
LEGALIZATION OF PRO. FIGHTS
FIVE EIGHT TEN YEARS. IN OUR IN
OUR- GLOBAL INTERESTS HAS
ALWAYS BEEN TO RAISE THE
STANDARD OF LIVING TO CREATE.
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS WITH GOOD
WASTING GOOD BENEFITS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT OUR MEMBERSHIP.
THE FLEX THAT NOT ONLY IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ACROSS THE
BOARD AND GROCERY. STORES AND-
TALK THE FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN. OUR
NUMBER ONE ISSUE WHEN IT COMES
TO CANNABIS THIS YEAR AND OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS HAS
BEEN ENFORCEMENT- BECAUSE- AS
THE AUTHOR IS POINTED OUT IN
AND I'VE- EVEN TO SOMEONE IN.
THE MISSILE DONALD BILL FROM.
TO EIGHTY PER OF THE MARKET NOW.
IS THERE A HAS. BEEN LEGAL
OPERATORS WELL LICENSES. THE
AFFECT OF THAT IS MANY. HAVE
MANY APPLICABLE ONE- UNLICENSED
OPERATORS. DON'T GET TESTED SO
THE PRODUCT. THANKS FOR
DANGEROUS AND POTENTIALLY TOXIC
NUMBER TWO. I'M LICENSE
OPERATORS DON'T PAY TAXES THEY
DON'T PAY LIKE YOU TO PLEASE
AND MAY HAVE A SIGNIFICANT-
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE OVER
LICENSE OPERATOR AND THEY'VE
REALLY UNDERCUT THE GOOD
OPERATORS AND GONE GONE TO THE
PROCESS BEEN LICENSED PAY ALL
THE TAXES. WE JUST SO WE THINK
THAT THE SUPPORT BILL TO
CONTINUE TO CUT DOWN ON THE
ILLEGAL OPERATORS AND AGAIN WE
APPLY THE AUTHOR AND RESPECT
THE ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT HE WITNESSED NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS GERRY CARILLO
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED CAMAS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THIS BILL- THE SIZE OF
THE ILLICIT INDUSTRIES
ESTIMATED NINE BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR. FOR THE NEED FOR BETTER
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS IS REALLY
HERE TO COMBAT THE FIVE- OF
THIS- THIS INDUSTRY AFTER
THIRTY MONTHS OF LEGALIZATION
DELISTED INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO
GROW. WE'RE GONNA FOLLOW THE
PURPOSE AND INTENT TO. BEFORE
AS IT STATES THAT REDUCING THE
SIZE OF THE LISTED INDUSTRY IS
ONE OF ITS INTENTION. BELIEVE
NEED FOR BETTER ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS AND HERE BECAUSE POLICE
ACTION CONTINUED TO BE AT A
HIGH COST AND LOW PRIORITY
LOCALLY. AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUDGETS ARE BEING
CUT UNDER THE NEW BUDGETARY
CONSTRAINTS. THE PRIMARY THE
PRIORITY WILL CONTINUE TO BE
DIMINISHED AND LEAVING TOOL TO
COMBAT THE UNTESTED CONTACT
THAN ON REGULAR CAMPUS
INDUSTRY. AT THE MOMENT PLAY
COULD TIME ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
EIGHT TWENTY ONE TWO TO PUT
THEM PORTS TOLD FROM THE HAND
OF LOCAL. AND IT TOOK A TURN.
GIVING THEM THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT TO HOLD THE LEGAL
OPERATORS AND THE PEOPLE WHO
EIGHT IN THE BED THEIR ACTIVITY
ACCOUNTABLE- WE ALSO HAVE THE
SAME TOOLS AVAILABLE TO THE
CAMPUS REGULATORY AUTHORITY.
UNDER EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN- AND
FEEL THAT EMPOWERING LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT WITH THE SAME TOOL
SPREAD OUT. THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF ENFORCEMENT AND COMBATING BE
LEGAL INDUSTRY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW MR
MODERATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THE PRESS
ONE ANOTHER ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
WE DO HAVE A FEW IN CUBA ME
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. CAN WE
AUTO LINE ONE TWENTY LINE. THE
CAMERA THERE LINE ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY ONE TWENTY. YOU ARE
SIR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS
WERE MET IF YOU CARE MEMBERS
JUST BARBARA HARRIS ON BEHALF
OF A SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TWO EIGHT ONE TWO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS MARTIN
WITH OFTEN WHICH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. LINE ONE THIRTEEN
ONE ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
IN THE TANK AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE HAD A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED TO DESCEND
BUT HAVE BEEN IN COMMUNICATION
WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF. AND AS I
WILL BE MOVING OUR POSITION
FROM IN CONCEPT AT THE PORT
THANK YOU FOR AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLY WOMAN. NO
FURTHER LINE CAN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE
ONE SUBMITTED MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION FOR KEY WITNESS
TESTIMONY UP TO TWO MINUTES AND
WE HAVE MISTER MILLER. MISTER
CHAIRMAN NUMBER STORES MILLER
ON BEHALF OF WITH MAPS ONCE
AGAIN. I'M HAPPY TO NOTE THAT
MY TESTIMONY IS GONE FROM
OPPOSITION TO ONE OF
NEUTRALITY- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPERAS
RECOGNITION OF OUR EFFORTS TO
SCRUB OUR PLATFORM ON LICENSE
BUSINESSES I'M LIKE THAT OF
MANY OTHER PLATFORMS- WITH THE
RECENT CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH
STAFF IN THE OP THERE- WE ARE
MOVING OUR- DECISION FROM UP
CLOSE TO ONE OF NEUTRALITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR MIGHT THERE BE
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME NAME
AND AFFILIATION. THANK YOU YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THAN ZERO STATE
YOUR POSITION. DO YOU KNOW LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. SEE
NO QUESTIONS BECAUSE THERE IS A
MOTION ND A SECOND ASSEMBLY
WOMAN DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TENACITY
BY CONTINUING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE YEAR AFTER YEAR BUT
HOPEFULLY- WE WILL CONTINUE SEE
IT'S A SUCCESS MOVING FORWARD.
COMMITTEE SIX THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THE MOTIONS TO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS LOW HI LOW HI BRO.
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
GEN CHEN AYE CHIU. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN. FONG
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN WHEN I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE TING. WELL THAT'S
THE BILL ISN'T THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. MEMBERS
ROUTE WE'RE GOING TO PASS. A
KIMBERLY ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY
THREE. OF THE MEMBERS CURRENTLY
HELD UP IN A SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING RIGHT NOW SO AGAIN WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AND THEN
MOVING STRAIGHT INTO A FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE.
SHOULD THE AUTHORED BE
AVAILABLE TO PRESENT THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA. AGAIN
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
ONE AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A PLEASE
PRESENT TO YOUR TO THE
COMMITTEE- ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE FIFTY TWO BALLOTS ACT WHICH
WILL FOR THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
INCREASE ADOPTION OF RESCUE
ANIMALS AT PROTECT ANIMAL
WELFARE. BY PROHIBITING THE
RETAIL SALE OF DOGS CATS AND
RABBITS FROM PUPPY MILLS I
HEARD THE MOTION A SECOND I
APPRECIATE IT I DO HAVE SOME
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY SO I WILL
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF.
DIFFERENT WITNESSES AND TURN IT
BACK TO MISSION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A SIMILAR GLORIA WILL NOW
THEN MOVE ON TO KEEP WITNESSES.
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
FOR. KEY TESTIMONY- THEN BE A
HAVE TO SUBMIT IT. NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES PER MEMBER. WISHING
TO PROVIDE KEY TESTIMONY. AND
WILL BEGIN WITH- MISTER. BILL
CAN MEET WITH THE SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS BILL GAMBLING ON CHIEF OF
HUMANE LAW ENFORCEMENT OF THE
SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY I'LL
BE HAPPY ORGANIZATION I WANT
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS TODD GLORIA.
AND PATRICK O'DONNELL TO
JOINTLY ALTERING THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION. IN EARLY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE BEGAN WHAT
WAS TO BECOME ONE OF THE MOST
FRUSTRATING ENFORCEMENT
ENDEAVORS IN MY LONG LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAREER. AT THAT
TIME OF THE PROVISIONS OF AB
FORTY FIVE WANTED TO AFFECT
THEIR FOR PET STORES NOT COUNTY
SELLING PUPPIES THREE IN OUR
JURISDICTION. THE PROVISIONS IN
CURRENT LAW SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ENOUGH TO STOP THE PUPPY MILL
TO PET STORE PIPELINE HOWEVER
NONE OF THESE STORES EVER TOOK
US UP ON OUR OFFER WAS SYSTEM
WITH COMPLIANCE. AND NON
INQUIRED ABOUT WAYS TO SHOWCASE
OUR ADOPTABLE ANIMALS IN THEIR-
AS ALLOWED BY AB FORTY FIVE.
COMPLY WITH THE PROVISIONS
ANIMALS BECOME SHELTER ANIMAL
RESCUE GROUPS THE STORE OWNERS
THEMSELVES INCORPORATED FIVE OH
ONE C. REFUSE THE FINAL PUPPIES
THROUGH WORK BUT NEW FROM SUCH.
STATION SAME PURPOSE COMPLY
WITH AB FORTY FIVES REQUIREMENT
A COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT THE SO
CALLED RESCUE SIDE AGREEMENTS
WITH SHELTERING ENTITIES OUT OF
THE STATE AND EVEN OUT OF THE
COUNTRY. UNFORTUNATELY THE
LEUPOLD REPRESENT THEMSELVES AS
MADE FORCING THE LAWS INTENT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE NOT SINGLE
INSPECTION THE PAST YEAR AND A
HALF REVEALED THAT THE STORES
PULL THE ANIMALS FROM SHELTERS.
FOR LEGIIMATE RAP ORGANIZATION
WHICH WAS TEN FINDING THEM CART
LAW FURTHER THE CAR PENALTIES
ARE NOT ENOUGHTO DISSUADE
THESE BAD ACTORS THE FAIRLY
MINIMAL FEES ASSOCIATED WITH A
FRACTION OF CIVIL PENALTY FOR
THE FEW THINGS WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE SITE THAT. HAVE VERY
LITTLE IMPACT WHEN SELLING IS
FOR THREE TO FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS EACH I LIKE I. THE
MATTER IS BUSINESS. OUR TO IN
LIGHT OF PANDEMIC WHILE OUR
STAY WAS LOCKED DOWN EXECUTIVE
ORDER OF THE GUY. THE STORES
CAN. TO SHIP OF POP FROM A
STATE WHY UP TO TWO TIMES A
WEEK. AND WHILE PEP SUPPLIES
ARE. FROM DURING STAY AT HOME
ORDERS. WE WERE A FIVE FROM C.
PH THAT SALES OF POPPIES ARE
NOT ESSENTIAL. AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY TWO WILL PROVIDE
NECESSARY SAFEGUARDS TO CUT OFF
THIS DECEPTIVE. PUPPY MILL THE
PET STORE SUPPLY CHAIN IN AND
FRAUDULENT PUPPY LAUNDRY
PRACTICES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME ON BE OUT THE SCENE.
HUMANE SOCIETY WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR IDAHO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW MOVE ON TO THE
SECOND WITNESS HE WHEN THIS IN
TESTIMONY- AND THAT'S A MISS
SUSAN RIGS. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN LOWER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SUSAN READ
SEVENTEEN OR DIRECTOR OF STATE
LEGISLATION FOR THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY FOR THE PREVENTION OF
CRUELTY TO ANIMALS. I WOULD
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL REGARD
THEM AS THE- CURRENT LAW. THE
BROAD PURPOSE OF THE AMENDMENT
IS TO PUT AN END TO THE GROSS
ABUSES THE PET STORES HAVE
PERPETRATED IN ORDER TO SKIRT
THE INTENT OF THE LAW SET FORTH
BY A. B. AT FORTY FIVE PASSED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
STORE SAID KNOWINGLY ACTED IN
BAD FAITH TO PERPETRATE AN
ACTIVITY THAT YOU HAVE CLEARLY
INTENDED TO IN SEVERAL YEARS
AGO AS A RESULT OF CRUELTY
INHERENT AND PACTEL CONTINUE TO
THIS DAY. FROM THE VERY FIRST
DAY OF THE LOS IMPLEMENTATION
ON JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THERE ARE MYRIAD
REPORTS OF AN EIGHT WEEK OLD
COPIES BEING SOLD IN STORES
AROUND THE STATE FOR THREE TO
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. EIGHT OF
THE PUPPIES AND THE PRICE TAG
FOR THE TELL TALE SIGNS THAT
THESE ARE NOT LEGITIMATE
RESCUES BEING ADOPTED AS
REQUIRED UNDER. THE NEW LAW. IT
THE TO THE PROFIT MOTIVE
OUTWEIGH THE RISK OF. ENDED LAW
THE TO WORK. THE AS USUAL BUT
THE SO. THIS POP MILL AND-
THROUGH THE USE PROJECT NOT
NONPROFIT THAT WERE LAW.
ANIMALS FROM THE- TRACKING DOWN
A FORCING THE DIFFICULT. OF
THESE POPULAR. MIDDLE MAN COULD
TAKE YEARS AND RESOURCES AT OUR
LOCAL. ANIMAL CONTROL AGENCIES
SIMPLY DON'T HAVE. AT THE
RESULT IT QUICKLY BECAME CLEAR
THAT ELIMINATING CELLS FROM
RETAIL STOREFRONTS ALL TOGETHER
HAD TO BE A PRIMARY FOCUS OF
THE BILL. IN ORDER TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE. CONSTRUCTING THE BILL
HOWEVER WE NECESSARILY HAD TO
WALK A FINE LINE BETWEEN
REGULATING THE ACT. WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING HUNDRED THE GROUP
THAT BOTH THE FOR PROFIT. AND
NONPROFIT ROUND OPERATE
LEGITIMATELY TO BE HELD
THOUSANDS OF ANIMALS EVERY YEAR
FOR RETAIL SPACE. THIS AS A
RESULT WE NEED TO BE HEARD
REPUTABLE ORGANIZATIONS WORK
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY THE BAY
ON. AS PART OF OUR DUE
DILIGENCE A NUMBER OF OUR
COALITION REACHED OUT TO PET
STORES THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
WE'RE TOLD. THAT WERE BELIEVED
TO FACILITATE ADOPTION THROUGH
RETAIL SPACE AS- THE SURVEY
REVEALED THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PAT. ADOPTED FROM THE RE
LOCATIONS HAD ADOPTION. OF
THEIR DOLLARS. LOVE FOR WHAT
ARE LEFT IN THE TO ORGANISE. OR
TO THIS RULE INDICATED BELIEVE
THAT COMPLAIN. ABOUT HER DOLLAR
CAP WOULD NOT POSE ISSUE.%
STANDING COURSE THAT THE
CAPITAL. APPLY WHEN THEY
ADOPTING OUT OF REACH HEALTH
FRONTS. A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CAP THE DOT FROM. OKAY THE COMP
TO. GOAL BIRTHDATE MINIMIZED
THE PROF MOTIVE THOSE WHO WERE
TO ABUSE THE LAW. WELL ALLOWING
LEGITIMATE RESCUE. TO TRY. A
SECOND PROVIDES A CLEAR
INDICATION OF BY. FOR FOURTH.
AT PREVIOUSLY IT'S CLEAR THAT
STORM. ITS EXIT LAW. DOWN THE
PENALTIES WITH A A. B. FORTY
FIVE WERE NOT ENOUGH ABOUT YOUR
DETERRENT TO DISCOURAGE THEIR
BY LAWS. OF THE LAW ON. SUCH A
SECONDARY FOCUS MORE AMENDMENT
IS ENSURING THAT THE PENALTY
SUPPORT AND THIS BILL DO YOU
ACT AS IT AFFECTED. AFFECTED
DETERRENT TO FURTHER
SHENANIGANS. AND YOU THOUGHT
ARE BOTH WITHIN A MINUTE THE
BILL DOES CONTINUES TO BE A
FOCAL POINT OF OUR WORK TO
DEVELOP THE MOST EFFECTIVE
LEGISLATION POSSIBLE. IN
CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR GAP GRATITUDE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GLORIA AND O'DONNELL AS
WELL AS VIDEO HUMANE SOCIETY.
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL PIECE OF HUMANE
LEGISLATION AND WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. WILL BE TWENTY WANTED
TO KILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
TIME AND- ANY ADDITION MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CAN TO ADD. THEIR
SUPPORT AS WELL IN IF. ONLY YOU
WISH TO SO MISTER MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. WISHING TO
SPEAK INTO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO WE HAVE A FEELING Q.
ARE READY WE'LL START WITH LINE
THIRTY THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE THIRTY MAIN ST GET
SICK POSITION. NICHOLAS SOCKET
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION
IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN ONE THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S
JENNIFER FEARING EXPECTING THE
SUPPORT OF THE BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY SAN FRANCISCO
SPCA AND A COMPANION ANIMAL
PROTECTION SOCIETY THANK YOU.
LINE ONE EIGHTEEN ONE ONE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JUDY MAN CREW SO SOCIAL
COMPASSION AND LEGISLATION
ORIGINAL SPONSOR OF EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE AND WE WANT TO
THANK OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL AND GLORIA- WHILE AB
FOR YOU HI- WAS DOING ITS JOB
THERE WAS A FEW BAD ACTORS AND
IT'S ALL HELP THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHO- EASIER AND
FOR SAID HELLO THANK YOU FOR-
HAPPINESS STILL. TODAY THANK
YOU. ONE FOURTEEN ONE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHEN MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON
THE OTHER THE CALIFORNIA ON
WELFARE ASSOCIATION BECAUSE
THIS REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ANIMAL
SHELTER IN CONTROL AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TODAY AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER COREY FOR TAKING ON THE
STOCK. NINE NINETY ONE NINE ONE
YOUR LINE OF THE- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS BOB
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES ALSO IN SUPPORT AND WE
HAVE A CLOSE IN THE GREEN ROOM
ACACIA QUESTIONS. THANK. NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE ONE SUBMITTED FOR KEY
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION UP TO
TWO MINUTES AND WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE PET CAL
FOUNDATION PLEASE PLEASE
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBER
LOGIN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MARTY LORENZO AND I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF LEGAL AFFAIRS
OF PACO AND PRESENTING
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
TWO. WE SUPPORT THE OVERALL
INTENT OF THE BILL TO PREVENT
BAD ACTORS AND PET ADOPTION BUT
WE CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL AS
DRAFTED. A QUARTER TO TEN YEAR
AGO WERE FOUND IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE ECHO IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH A PACK OF FOUNDATION HAS
HELPED MORE THAN SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION ANIMALS. FINDER FOREVER
HOMES BY PARTNERING WITH
SHELTERS AND RESCUE
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. CALIFORNIA WE
ACCOMPLISH THAT BY HOSTING
ADOPTION EVENTS AT OUR STORES.
AND PROVIDING RETAIL SPACE TO
HOUSE AND SHOWCASE ADOPTABLE
ANIMAL. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PRIMARY PURPOSE OF THE BOOK OF
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO IT'S
INSURE THAT DOG CAPTION RABBIT.
BEING OFFERED IN CALIFORNIA PET
STORES COME FROM LEGITIMATE
REPUTABLE RESCUES AND SHELTERS.
AND WE SUPPORT THAT GOAL. WE DO
NOT WANT TO SEE ANYONE
PROFITING FROM DECEPTION OR
MISREPRESENTING AN ANIMAL. AS A
RESCUE AND DEPRIVING A TRULY
NEEDY ANIMAL OF A SHOT AT A
HAPPY LIFE. AGAIN WE SUPPORT
THE INTENT OF THE BILL. OR HOW
BILL ACCOMPLISHES THE CONTENT.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
PACO AND OTHERS PRESS SPECIALTY
STORES THAT CURRENTLY HOSTS
THOUSANDS OF ADOPTION EVENT
BROUGHT CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR.
BECAUSE THERE'S AN ASPECT OF
THIS BILL THAT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO PUT AN END TO
STORES BUT I CO PROVIDING SPACE
FOR IN STORE AND OPTIONS AND
HOSTING ADOPTION OF THAT. AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN SECTION FOR
THIS BILL HOLD AT STORES
CRIMINALLY LIABLE FOR ANY
ADOPTIONS FROM OR PROVISIONS OF
SPACE TO ANY ORGANIZATION THAT
DOES NOT MEET THE DEFINITION OF
QUOTE ANIMAL RESCUE GROUP END
QUOTE IN THE BILL. IF THE BILL
BECOMES LAW AS DRAFTED OUR
EXPOSURE TO CRIMINAL LIABILITY
FOR THE ACTIONS ARE MISSION OF
A THIRD PARTY ORGANIZATION
WOULD LEAVE US ON ABLE TO
CONTINUE HOSTING AND STORED
OPTIONS ADOPTION OF THAT OR
PROVIDING ADOPTION CENTERS AND
HABITAT. TO ALL OUR ANIMAL ARE
FULL PARTNERS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE-
OF THIS. IS TO PROHIBIT PET
STORES FROM SELLING DOGS CATS
RABBITS ALTOGETHER AND TO
FURTHER ENSURE THAT THEY DO NOT
PROVIDE SPACE FOR SPIRIT ANIMAL
RESCUE GROUPS TO MISLEAD.
PERSPECTIVE PET OWNERS. WE KNOW
THAT THE SPONSORS ARE EAGER TO
SEE MORE CALIFORNIA'S ADOPTER
IDEAL COMPANIONS FROM THE
NUMBERS LEGITIMATE SHELTERS AND
RESCUES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND AGAIN WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SHARE THIS VIEW AND OUR LONG
STANDING RECORD DEMONSTRATES
THAT. HOWEVER IT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO DISSIPATED
OPTIONS AT THIS BILL WERE
ENACTED AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED.
WE WORK WITH THOUSANDS OF
ANIMAL WELFARE ORGANIZATION
INCLUDING RESCUE ORGANIZATION.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY HOSTING
ADOPTION EVENTS AND PROVIDING
THE SPACE TO HOUSE AND DISPLAY
DOPPEL ANIMALS IN OUR STORES
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE MANY POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO HELP
ENSURE THAT ADOPTION. ARE
LEGITIMATE WE SIMPLY ARE NOT
ABLE TO CONFIRM AND CONTINUALLY
MONITOR THAT ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH WHOM WE PARTNER
ARE CONSISTENTLY IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE BILL. ADDITIONALLY OUR
ORGANIZATIONS DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MONITOR EVERY
ADOPTION CONTRACT FOR ANY PET
THAT IS ADOPTED. OR MAY HAVE
BEEN SHOWCASE FOR ADOPTION IN
OUR STORES TO DETERMINE THE
AMOUNT OF ADOPTION FEES CHARGED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
SUGGESTION OF WRONGDOING ON THE
PART. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
YOUR TIME IS LIMITED YOU WISH
TO FINALIZING CLOSE IN
CONCLUSION. CAN WE ALL SHARE
THE DIRE THE BILL'S SPONSORS
THAT AT SHELTERS AND RESCUE
THROW CALIFORNIA PLACE FOR
HOMES. WE JUST WANT TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS WITHOUT CRIMINAL
LIABILITY FOR PET STORES AND WE
THINK WE CAN WORK WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THE ILL TO MAKE
THE APPROPRIATE OPTIONS. AND
OPTIONS. THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU
DO FOR PATTERSON THE PATENT
PELTON KEEP PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW MR
OPERATOR. IT THERE ARE THERE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO. DO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I DO HAVE ONE
LINE IN Q. WILL GO TO LINE ONE
FOUR EIGHT ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE OF THE- GOOD AFTERNOON
KEREN MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WITH
THE DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE
HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIRS. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND AND WE- WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL TODAY THINK YOU. THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO
NINE THANK YOU MISTER TERRY MAY
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF THAT CONCLUDES PUBLIC
TESTIMONY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT THERE BE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
WILL REGAIN WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS I WAS
HAPPY TO SUPPORT OTHER
PREDECESSOR BILL BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM LONG BEACH
I THINK THIS IS- I WOULD EVEN
CALL IT A CLEAN UP I THINK IT
WILL CREATE THE PROPER
INCENTIVE STRUCTURE AND FORCED
MECHANISM TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE INTENT OF THAT ORIGINAL
BILLS IS HONORED- AND AT THAT
OUR FAMILY HAS A RESCUE CAT AND
A RESCUE DOG SO- IF MY KIDS ARE
WATCHING AT HOME WHICH IS
EXTREMELY UNLIKELY- I MENTIONED
OUR PETS ON THE FLOOR. THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA D. WHICH
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'D APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF BOTH THE SUPPORTERS
AND OPPONENTS LEGISLATION WANT
TO SHARE MY COLLEAGUES WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO TRYING TO FIND A
WAY. FOR ME VERY MINUTE THE
BILL TO REFLECT THEIR CONCERNS
WILL CONTINUE WORKING- BUT ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL WAS MY PARTNER WITH
THIS PARTICULAR DISTILLATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEES I'VE OF. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A SIMILAR GLORIA IT
AGAIN THE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE
TO SOME MILLION ON YOUR WORK.
IN ADDITION TO SOME AND
O'DONNELL. AS WELL- TO MEMBERS
WHO US BASICALLY HAD. AN
INTEREST KEEN INTEREST IN THIS
pCOLLABORATIVELY ON ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE. THIS DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
TWO THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI. LOW HI
BRO. I ARAMBULA. BLOOM BLOOM
AYE CHAN CHEN I TO. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN. FONG FONG
AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
LAURIE I GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. OBERNOLTE
TING. THE BILL HAS WELL THAT'S
THE BILL ISN'T THE BILL WITHOUT
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JUST AS A
REMINDER WE PROVIDED CREST
LUNCH FOR YOU AND THE LAUNCHER
EVERY AS YOU SEE FIT WE'LL NOW
MOVE BACK INTO FILE BECAUSE OUR
PRESENTER IN AUTHORS HERE THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
SUMMER BLOOM THIS DOES ENJOY IT
TO PASS RECOMMENDATION OF BOTH
SIDES THE OP. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE WAITING
FOR ME- GOOD MORNING YEAH I
GUESS IS GOOD AFTERNOON THAT-
I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
THANKING THE- COMMITTEE. IT'S
NOT. THIS BILL WILL BRING IT
THE- WORLD RENOWNED PHYSICIANS
WHO WILL BE ABLE TO TRAIN. NEW
CLASSES OF CALIFORNIA
PHYSICIANS OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT-
NOT ONLY TODAY IN THE CURRENT
CRISIS BUT GOING FORWARD. IN
ORDER TO LICENSE FOR AN
EDUCATED AND TRAINED PHYSICIANS
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS
UTILIZED. THE SPECIAL PERMIT
SECTION OF THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE. THROUGH THEIR
AFFILIATION AGREEMENT WITH THE
DAVID GEFFEN SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AT UCLA. THROUGH THE SAME UCLA
AFFILIATION AGREEMENT CEDAR
SINAI TRAINS MEDICAL STUDENTS
FROM UCLA AND FOR ALL THROUGH
UNIVERSITY. AND HAS
SUCCESSFULLY OBTAINED SPECIAL
LICENSES FOR BOTH FELLOWS AND
FACULTIES BUT HAVING TO GO
THROUGH UCLA TAKES TIME AND
THIS CAN BE UP TO EIGHT MONTHS.
THAT'S WHERE AB TWENTY TO
SEVENTY THREE COMES AT IT WOULD
ALLOW AN ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTERS SPECIFICALLY CEDAR
SINAI TO SUBMIT CANDIDATES FOR
SPECIAL FACULTY PERMITS
DIRECTLY WITH THE BOARD. AND
RECEIVE APPROVALS AND A
FRACTION OF THE TIME. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE TO KEY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT I DO NOT AFTER SHLOMO
MAD MAD MAD MAD AND HER OKAY.
GREAT AND UP TO TWO MINUTES OF
FOR EACH OF THE WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT- SO
LET'S BEGIN. WITH MISTER SCHECK.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON AFTER- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN LOW BY
CHAIRMAN BRO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
VACATION TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME
IS TARA OKAY AND I SERVE AS
VICE PRESIDENT OF HR AT CEDARS
SINAI. HERE SIGN I SPECIAL
LICENSING FUNCTION IS UNDER MY
ADMINISTRATION- THAT WE
CURRENTLY PROCESS ARE
SPECIALIZED CONCERNS THROUGH
OUR AFFILIATION AGREEMENT WITH
UCLA IN ORDER FOR A POSITION TO
QUALIFY FOR SPECIAL MIGHT SEND.
FINE A FACULTY MEMBER. MY FIRST
HOLD A CURE ACADEMIC
APPOINTMENT UCLA.
DISAPPOINTMENT IS IN ADDITION
TO OUR OWN HERE REVIEWED
ACADEMIC APPOINTMENT PROCESS AT
CEDARS SINAI. I THOUGHT THE
PROCESS FOR OBTAINING A UCLA
ACADEMIC APPOINTMENT TAKES
ANYWHERE BETWEEN THREE AND NINE
MONTHS CURRENTLY. ONCE THE
ACADEMIC APPOINTMENT HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY UCLA WERE THEN
ALLOWED TO SUBMIT THE SPECIAL
LICENSE DOCUMENTS TO UCLA
FORWARD YOU. ARE GENERALLY
UCLA'S REVIEW PRIOR TO
SUBMITTING TO THE MEDICAL BOARD
TAKES AN ADDITIONAL TWO TO
THREE MONTHS OF POTENTIALLY THE
ENTIRE PROCESS CURRENTLY COULD
TAKE UP TO TWELVE MONTHS. DID
BILL WOULD REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT TO PROCESS OUR
APPLICANTS THROUGH UCLA AND
ALLOW THESE OUTSTANDING
PRACTITIONERS TO SERVE THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA MORE
RAPIDLY IN APPROXIMATELY TWO TO
THREE MONTHS TIME. THIS BILL
DOES NOT IN ANY WAY CHANGE ANY
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS
ESTABLISH ANY NEW ENTITIES THAT
MUST BE REGULATED OR ALLOW AND
NINE LICENSE CALIFORNIA
PHYSICIAN TO PRACTICE OUTSIDE
OF THE CURRENT SPECIAL PERMITS
REQUIREMENTS. SHOULD THE BILL
PASSED. FIND IT WOULD CONTINUE
TO PUT FORTH THE SAME
EXCEPTIONAL QUALITY OF
APPLICANTS FOR THE DOES TODAY.
IN FACT THE- FINE I HAD NEVER
PUT FOR THE CANDIDATE WHO WAS
UNSUCCESSFUL IN OBTAINING A
SPECIALIZED SENT. TO ILLUSTRATE
CEDAR SINAI'S CURRENT POSITION
AND SPECIAL LICENSING PROCESS
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE TWENTY
ONE SIXTY EIGHT HOLDERS. TWO OF
WHOM HAVE THAT HELD THEIR
LICENSES FOR MORE THAN TEN
YEARS- WERE ALREADY RESPONSIBLE
FOR LIABILITY FOR ALL OF OUR
SPECIAL LICENSE HOLDERS THAT
INCLUDES MEDICAL MARK
MALPRACTICE AND GENERAL
LIABILITY COVERAGE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU WISH TO CONCLUDE YOUR
COMMENTS. YES PLEASE THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD ALLOW CEDAR
SINAI AND A FEW OTHER PROMINENT
INSTITUTION TO RICK'S RECRUIT
OUTSTANDING AND QUALIFIED SIGN
TEST- FROM OTHER COUNTRIES TO
BRING THEIR EXPERTISE. AND
ENHANCE OUR TEACHING CLINICAL
RESEARCH MISSION WHICH HAVE A
DIRECT POSITIVE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S THAT IT'S DONE.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A YES VOTE
ON AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND FOR THE FINAL WITNESS
INTO. PROVIDING TESTIMONY OF
FOR THE DOCTOR REPRESENTING
COMES A SENIOR AT. CEDARS SINAI
WOULD YOU KINDLY KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS. TO TWO MINUTES PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT CHAIRMAN LOW VICE CHAIRMAN
BROUGH AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. IT'S REALLY A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY I'M
DOCTOR MAIL MAN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
ACADEMIC AFFAIRS AND DEAN. THE
MEDICAL FACULTY AND PROFESSOR
OF MEDICINE AT CEDARS SINAI. WE
ARE NOT FOR PROFIT HEALTH
SYSTEM AND I'M PROUD TO LEAD
OUR RESEARCH AND EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. WE RECRUIT NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED FACULTY LEADERSHIP.
WE STAB EACH NEW EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS WE MAINTAIN THE
HIGHEST ACADEMIC STANDARDS. ON
BEHALF AND SEE THE FUN I WE'RE
SPONSORING AB TWO TWO SEVEN
THREE. OF NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED TO RECRUIT THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST. MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IN THE WORLD.
TRYING TO DAY AND SOME POSITION
AND MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS FOR
CALIFORNIA. CURRENT LAW. ONLY
ALLOWS APPROVED MEDICAL SCHOOL
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE SECTION
TWO ONE SIX EIGHT. THIS LIMITS
THE FLEXIBILITY OF INDEPENDENT
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS LIKE
pFRIEND POLITICALLY WITHOUT
THINKING SUPPORT OF A MEDICAL
SCHOOL. DURING THOUGHT FOR THE
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER TO
ENGAGE IN THE MEDICAL SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR PROPERTIES WHICH
DELAYED THE ABILITY POSITION TO
BECOME AN ACTOR THE NATION
TREATING PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE BILL MAKERS
WILL CHANGE THAT TO A LOT THE
THOUGHT MIGHT BE THE APPLICANT
UNDER THE SPECIAL USE PERMIT
LANGUAGE UNDER CURRENT GOAL.
FEEDER FINE I'M NOT GO THROUGH
UCLA TO COMPLETE THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND OBTAIN
THE PROPER PERMITS. VERY
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL WILL NOT
CHANGE IN LIFE. FIND IT COULD
NOT ESTABLISH ANY NEW ENTITY.
THAT MUST BE RIGHT. LOADED THE
ALLOW AND NON LIFE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE TO PRESS OUT.
THE CARD SPECIAL AND THE GROUP.
INDEPENDENT ACADEMIC MEDICAL
THINGS IN THE USA ARE AMONG THE
MOST HIGHLY REGARDED HOSPITAL
FOR CLINICAL CARE TEACHING AND
RESEARCH ON OCCASION THE- GROUP
BY RECRUIT THE. TRULY A- FOR
THE- WHO HAVE BEEN IN OTHER.
BUT MAY HOSPITAL OF THE FEEDER
THOUGHT MIGHT THANK YOU WAS
TAKEN AS- HE WAS TAKEN YOUR OF
DOCTOR. THANK YOU THROUGH OUR-
RAY THE FELLOWSHIP OF THE RING.
PROGRAM THE THOUGHT I TRY MUCH
FIVE JUNE POSITION. TOGETHER
WITH THREE. OF THOSE THE P.
LOOK. AND LEAD NATIONALLY BUT
THE BILL CLINICAL AND RESEARCH
PROGRAMS IN THIS LEGISLATION.
WOULD ALLOW US TO BE IF YOU ARE
THE PROMINENT IMPLICATIONS TO
RECRUIT. BUT IMPORTANT MEMORY
POSITIONS AND PROVISIONAL
SCIENTISTS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES. WHO BRING SPECIAL X.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MULTIPLE ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'VE CONCLUDED PAST
YOUR TWO MINUTES. THAT'D BEEN
ALLOTTED MR OPERATOR OTHER ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. NAY
MANIPULATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. HE CORPORATE AS SUPPORT MY
PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL WILL
GO TO THE LINE OF ONE FIFTY
FIVE ONE FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE HELLO ONE FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH BY THE
BILL I'D LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT-
THANK YOU YOU MAKE YOU MAKE YOU
UP AGAIN AT THAT TIME. WE HAVE
AN ANOTHER PARTICIPANT IN Q.
ONE MOMENT. AND ONE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE FIVE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER MY NAME
IS SERRA HOPEFUL ON BEHALF OF
THE UC OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND FOR THE WORK OF THE
STAFF- AND FEATURED ON THE
BILL. IF YOU THINK THAT IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND CONFIDENCE EASILY
APPRECIATE THEIR TIME WORKING
OUT OUR TECHNICAL CONCERNS. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO DELIVERING
ARE DELIVERING OUR LETTER IN.
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO KEY
WITNESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED. WITH SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION FOR THAT TWO MINUTES
ALLOTMENT BUT ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. IF SO
IMPRESSED ONE THAN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. NO LINES IN
Q. COULD CONTINUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW BACK TO THE
CONVERSATION TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
KATE THE SCENE- ADICIONAL
QUESTIONS A COMMA CIRCULAR
MEMBERS THAT. I HAVE EVER BLOOM
JEWISH TO CLOSE YEAH I HAVE A
SHORT FIVE MINUTE STATEMENT.
STRUCTURE I'LL TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOSING ARGUMENTS ACTUALLY
AFTER I'VE A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND ALSO THIRTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CONTINUED
ADVOCATES I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
BEEN A CHAMPION. IN THIS AREA I
WITH A NUMBER OF THE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY THREE
EMOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI LOW HI
BRO. BRO I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I
BLOOM. BLOOM I TEN CAN I TO.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
FONG. FONG I GIPSON. GLORIA
GRAYSON RECENT AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. MCCARTY
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
LEVEL OF ITS THE BILL ISN'T.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. THE COLLEAGUES WILL GO
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THREE THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AGAIN
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE.
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- TODAY I'M PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY THREE. THE BILL ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND SAFETY
AND HEALTH CARE. THE BILL
INSURERS BUSINESS PRACTICES BY
MAJOR PHARMACY PHARMACIES ARE
IN LINE WITH THE CORRECT
PRACTICE THE PHARMACY AND
MEDICINE. CURRENTLY PHARMACIES
USE AUTOMATIC SYSTEMS THAT WILL
CONTACT THE DOCTOR THROUGH A
FAX TO REQUEST A REFILL FOR
PRESCRIPTION. FOR EXAMPLE THE
DOCTOR PRESCRIBES A THIRTY DAY
SUPPLY OF MEDICATION WITH THE
WITH THREE REFILLS. OTHER THIRD
REFILL WITH THE PATIENT'S
PERMISSION THE PHARMACY WILL
CONTACT THE DOCTOR TO RENEW THE
PRESCRIPTION. THIS IS HELPFUL
FOR PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS TO TAKE DAILY
MEDICATIONS BY REDUCE ANY LAG
TIME BETWEEN REFILLS. HOWEVER
SOME STORES ARE TAKEN THIS
PROCESS A STEP TOO FAR I
REQUEST THE REFILLS BEYOND WHAT
WAS ORIGINALLY CHRIS
PRESCRIBED. AND MORE THAN THE
PATIENT SHOULD HAVE. SOMETIMES
THIS IS A REQUEST ON BEHALF OF
A PATIENT BUT AS GROWN INTO A
BUSINESS PRACTICE TO RETAIN
CUSTOMERS AT THE RISK. OF
PATIENT SAFETY. THE PRACTICE
ALSO INCLUDES BOMBARDING
DOCTORS OFFICES WITH FAXES
UNTIL THEY RESPOND. FAR BEYOND
WHAT WAS PREVIOUSLY DONE
OVERWHELMING THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE AND STAFF. OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WAS OVERTAXED
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. THE
COMBINATION OF CHANGE REFILL
REQUEST WITH THE BOMBARDMENT OF
REQUEST CAN EASILY LEAD TO
MISTAKES WHEN APPROVING THE
DISPENSING MEDICATIONS TO
PATIENTS. WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN
EXAMPLES OF THESE MISTAKES. BUT
THESE ARE MORE THAN MISTAKES
THE RESULT. THEY ARE RESULT OF
DECISIONS BY THESE COMPANIES TO
PURSUE MORE AGGRESSIVE BUSINESS
PRACTICES. A NEW YORK TIMES
ARTICLE IN JANUARY DOCUMENTED
EXAMPLES OF ONE CHAIN DRUGSTORE
ROUTINELY REQUESTING AND
DISPENSING THREE MONTH SUPPLY
OF PSYCHIATRIC DRUGS DESPITE
DOCTOR'S URGING THEM NOT TO. IT
ALSO SHOWED DOCTORS OFFICES
BEING OVERWHELMED WITH THE
REQUEST THAT ORIGINATED WITH
THE PHARMACY AND NOT THE
PATIENT. SO THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT IS IMPACTING PERCOLATING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. I'VE ALSO
HEARD FROM DOCTORS IN MY
DISTRICT WHO HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR FIX TO THIS
ISSUE FOR A LONG TIME. AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE WOULD
RESTORE BALANCE BY PROHIBITING
A PHARMACY FROM AUTOMATICALLY
REQUESTED A REFILL. FOR PATIENT
UNLESS THEY HAVE PERMISSION
FROM THE PATIENT. OR THE DOCTOR.
THIS WILL LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
REFILLS REQUESTED AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE PHARMACY
WITHOUT PATIENT FOR DOCTOR
INPUT. IT ALSO PROHIBITS THEM
FROM REQUESTED REFILLS BEYOND
WHAT THE DOCTOR ORIGINALLY
PRESCRIBED. SO THEY CAN%
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE THE
REQUESTED REFILLS ON BEHALF OF
PATIENTS AS THEY SHOULD. BUT
THE NUMBER OF REFILLS THE
PATIENT RECEIVES SHOULD NOT BE
RECOMMENDED BY PHARMACY. DO I
BELIEVE THE NEED IS URGENT I
RECOGNIZE IT IS NECESSARY. A TO
ALLOW THE SYSTEM TO ADOPT
OUTSIDE THE CURRENT CRISIS.
THAT IS WHY I AGREE TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND HIS
COMMITTEE FOR COLLABORATING
WITH THOSE AND TRY TO FIND A
WAY TO ADDRESS THE TIMING ISSUE.
TODAY I HAVE DOCTORS WALK FOR.
OUR SHE AND EVA PRONE TO
TESTIFY ABOUT THIS PRACTICE AND
HOW IT'S AFFECTED THEIR WORK
AND THEIR PATIENTS. AND
RESPECTFUL AFTER I'VE- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A SUMMER HOLDEN
AND IT'S JUST AS A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION TO- TO REFER TO
REAFFIRM FOR COMMITTEE THE
CONVERSATION WITH PERSPECTIVE
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION IS
SOMETHING THAT I YOU ARE
ACKNOWLEDGING AND WOULD LIKE
TO. MOVE FORWARD AND IMPLEMENT
SHOULD THIS WE'VE COMMITTEE AS
WELL THAT'S CORRECT. IN FULL
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCHTHEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO- MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WE MOVE ON TO KEY
WITNESS TESTIMONY. UP TO TWO
MINUTES OF FOR KEY WITNESS
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. HI
AND MY NAME IS EVA PAN AND I AM
A BOARD CERTIFIED INTERNAL
MEDICINE PHYSICIAN AND PRIVATE
PRACTICE. I WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINETY THREE. THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THE AUTOMATIC RESULT THIS
DOWN DEFEAT THE ORIGINAL INTENT
OF SUCH A SYSTEM. THE PURPOSE
OF THE AUTOMATIC REFILL SYSTEM
WITH THE STREAMLINED THE
MEDICATION REFILL PROCESS. AND
ABOUT MEDICATION AND HERE I
THINK CRIME DISEASE MANAGEMENT.
INSTEAD PHYSICIANS HAVE BECOME
OVER BURDENED WITH AN ORDER AND
NUMBER REFILL REQUEST COMING BY
FACT ANY PRESCRIBED. WHEN THE
AUTOMATED SYSTEM. IN MY
EXPERIENCE THIS IS A CONSISTENT
PRACTICE OF THE SYSTEM TO
REQUEST AN APPROPRIATE WE FELT
THAT. BECAUSE THE DANGER TO
PATIENT. WEEK I WOULD RECONCILE
YOU MIGHT BE MEDIC. DURING A
TELL THAT THAT. OUT SHE WAS
RECEIVING AUTOMATIC REFILL THE
OLD BLOOD PRESSURE MEDICATION
THAT WAS PRESCRIBED ON JULY OF
LAST YEAR I ANY CHANGES
MEDICATION DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR THE SYSTEM PULLED UP HER
OLD MEDICATION WITH THE
REMAINING RESULT. IN GAVE IT TO
HER IN THE MARCH UNBEKNOWNST TO
ME THE PATIENT HERSELF AND EVEN
THE PHARMACIST. THE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES OF OPTIMAL BLOOD
PRESSURE CONTROL OR STROKE AND
HEART ATTACK. THE SITUATION IS
FURTHER EXACERBATED BY THE CODE
PANDEMIC IN WHICH IS THE
TELEMEDICINE THAT THAT WERE
MARCHING LIMITED DUE TO LACK OF
PP. MICHAEL PROVIDERS ARE
SPENDING A DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT TIMES DURING THE
LEGITIMACY OF THESE ARE CLASS.
WHICH CREATES A TREMENDOUS AN
UNNECESSARY BURDEN ON OUR
PRACTICAL. INCOME WITH INTERNET
ONLY FURTHER STRESSES THE
IMPORTANCE OF PATIENT SAFETY
AND THE NEED TO LEVY A POSITION
FATIGUE. COURAGE FOR THE SHOW
WORKFORCE RETENTION AND
ECONOMICALLY TRYING TIME. I
COULD NOT IT'S AUTOMATIC REFILL
PRACTICE IS BEING DRIVEN BY
ECONOMIC INSTEAD OF THE
PHARMACIES AND NOT YOUR BY WHAT
IS BEST FOR THE PATIENT.
ULTIMATELY THE RESULT IN
PATIENT INJURY POSITION FATIGUE
AND HIGHER HEALTHCARE COSTS.
THE RESULT YOU REQUIRE CONTENT
AND KNOWLEDGE OF THE
PRACTITIONER OF THESE ACTIONS
FALL UNDER THE BURDEN OF THE
PRACTICE WITH. MEDICINE WE
DON'T TWENTY NINE THREE WILL
HELP AND- THAT THE RELATIONS
BETWEEN DOT PATIENT ARE. MAY
BALLOT WALAU FOR CONVENIENCE
AND IF YOU'RE COMMUTING MEDICAL.
THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE NEXT WITNESS TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN LOW MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND MISTER
HOLMAN HOLDEN THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THE I'M A
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER IN
PASADENA CALIFORNIA THE
AUTOMATED- AND I'M DOCTOR ALL
RUSH AT THE AUTOMATED REFILL
OUR SYSTEM HAS CAUSE AN UNSAFE
PROCESS AND REFILLING
MEDICATION. OUT FOR OUR
PATIENTS I HAVE EXAMPLES OF
INAPPROPRIATE AUTO REFILL
REQUESTS FROM PHARMACIES ASKING
FOR FIFTEEN REFILL OF NINETY
DAY SUPPLIES ASKING FOR WATER
RESULT ON DECEASED PATIENTS AND
SEVERAL OTHER EXAMPLES. THE
TASK OF INTERCEPTING THESE
REQUESTS ARE BOTH TEDIOUS FOR
PHYSICIANS AND HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND ALSO DANGEROUS.
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE
WE'LL KEEP OUR PATIENTS SAFER
AND PROTECT THEM FROM
MEDICATION ERRORS AND ALSO
ALLOWS THEIR PHYSICIAN TO GUIDE
THEIR MEDICAL CARE IN A
PRACTICAL AND SAFE MANNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT CONCLUDES KEY
WITNESS TESTIMONY ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAME AND AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO MISTER
MODERATOR OTHER ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BILLS MY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WILL
MOVE THE LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT A LINE OF THE- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIR NUMBER.
CONNIE DELGADO. PEOPLE DON'T
GOT ON THE OF THE CAL BE ABLE
DIRECT WITH THE- AND. YOU HAVE
ANOTHER LINE BE JUST A MOMENT.
WE. LINE ONE SIXTY ONE ONE SIX
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS MEGAN ALL RIGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IS GOING TO
THINK BOTHER FOR ALL OF HIS
WORK ON THAT IMPORTANT ABOUT.
YOUR NO FURTHER LINE THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW OPEN UP TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
ONE INDIVIDUAL LISTED UP TO TWO
MINUTES OF. KEY WITNESS
TESTIMONY PLEASE FEEL FREE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHERRY
NUMBER MY NAME IS WHEN THE GOAL
HORN AND I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATIONAND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN DRUG
STORES. WE ARE AND FORTUNATELY
IT COULD BE TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
THREE. WHILE WE APPRECIATE
MATTER GOLDEN CAN'T BEAT THE
AND MITIGATE WORK WORK WORK THE
PRESCRIBER. WE DO NOT HOLD A
BETWEEN EIGHTY. LISTEN THIS
DOUBLE PHARMACY LOOK I. RE AND-
DRAMATIC WRITTEN AFTER THE FROM
THE MARKET GRABER. BURNABY WHAT
TO THINK THAT WRITTEN ON. FOR
EVERY PEOPLE ARE. WHICH IS
CUMBERSOME AND THINKING. THAT
MEANS WOULD BE SO IN FACT NOW
DURING THE CURRENT AND THEN. IT
ALSO AGREED IF YOU CAN THE
QUESTION. I'M OF PEOPLE.
SCRIPTED IT IS ALSO IN FACT. IN
ADDITION TO THE PENCIL HARMFUL
BUT- ACTUALLY THE A CHRONIC.
FOR MANAGING MEDIC. ITEM I
NEEDED RIVER THE LOCKER OF THE-
KING THEY KERN AND FOR THE NEXT.
BUT COULD RESULT. IN HEALTH.
THE REQUESTED BUT RESULT ONE
THAT APPLICATION MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO READILY AFRICA.
PRACTICES ALWAYS BENEFITS EVEN
MORE SO NOW. WE UNDERSTAND
EVERYTHING YOU AUTUMN GO
CLASSES AND- BUT THE PRESCRIBER
SO MAKING. IN THE NIGHT
REQUEST. THE PHARMACY IN LEAVE
THE WITH WITHOUT RUBBER THE
PREQUEL CURRENTLY THE PROCESS.
THE REPUBLICAN APARTMENT IT IS
NOT ONLY TO THE QUICKLY FOR THE
PATIENT BUT RESPECT WAITING
IDENTICAL. NUMBER BONTA
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. WITH
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
THOSE LINES MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. Q. INTERNAL
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANYQUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME WE'LL BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- JUST FOR SOME
CLARIFICATION. OF THE BILL.
COVER A SECTION OF
PRESCRIPTIONS LIKE THOSE
CERTAIN DRUGS FOR OUR OLD
PRESCRIPTIONS ALL DRUGS COVERED
UNDER THIS BILL. THE WAY THAT
THE BILL IS STRUCTURED RIGHT
NOW IT WOULD COVER ALL
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. ABOVE WE
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE PATIENT- NOT
NECESSARILY CALL THE POSITION
IN ORDER TO PLACE THE REFILL
BUT TO GO DIRECTLY TO THE
PHARMACIST TO DO SO THAT.
RECOGNIZE AND WE ARE CERTAINLY
CONTINUING TO THINK ABOUT. IS
THERE A WAY TO SORT OF SHAPE
THIS A LITTLE BIT MORE NARROWLY
BUT AT THIS POINT WE ARE LOOK
AT ALL MEDICATIONS. IN IF I
UNDERSTAND ACROSS CAN THE
IMPETUS OF THE BILL WOULD THAT
THE DOCTORS WERE BEING WITH
RICK FROM FAR. YES NOT A THAT
IS THAT BECAUSE THE MAY HAVE
BEEN BUT REQUEST AND THEREFORE
THE PHARMACY WAS FOR THAT RICK
FOR. IS IT IS THERE DATA IS
THAT. AFTER EVERY SINGLE
REQUEST THERE'S NOT REPETITION.
IN REQUEST THAT ARE IN WITH THE
DA NOT RESPONDING QUICK ABOUT
RIGHT MIGHT. THE TWO THAT WAS
THE BY PRIMARY WE OR SUGGEST
THAT THEY ARE JUST BEING OVER.
I WOULD. OBVIOUSLY NOT AS OF SO
MINE. WOULD BE TELEMARKETERS.
MICROPHONE RING ALL THE TIME
AND- USUALLY IT'S WITH A CALL I.
PROBABLY DON'T NEED TO TAKE I
THAT HAVING MORE PURSE OF TO
THE FOR THE PACE THE PHYSICIAN.
AND THE PHARMACIST TO BE A TO
INTERACT IN A MORE PRO WAY TO
ALLOW FOR. THE HEALTH NEEDS. TO
BE ADDRESSED IN A MORE WAY OF
THINKING WHAT THIS IS DESIGNED
TO DO I BE ABLE TO. A ONE OF
WORK MY WAY TO BE ABLE TO RE
MORE LIVELY HOW IT AFFECTS
THEIR. LAST MONTH. BUT IF THIS
BILL TO MOVE FOR OUT OF
COMMITTEE TO YOU'RE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH MEAN SOME OF
THE ON IN OR OR BLOOD PRESSURE
THEY'VE BEEN ON IT FOR WHILE IT
JUST SEEMS UNLESS TO FORCE A
MAP GO BACK IN AND GET A
WRITTEN UNLESS WRITTEN MEAN
SICKENING BE. OUR ON ON YOU
KNOW. RIGHT ON THE INTERNET
WELL IF PROGRAM RIGHT NOW THE.
THE THAT THE PATIENT SIGN UP
WITH THE PHARMACY AND ONCE THEY
AGREE TO THESE AUTUMN REFILL
THE ON THE PHARMACY THAT IS
MAKING. AGGRESSIVE PLANS OFTEN
OVER A RICH THIS IS. AND
NOTICED THAT WAS. WAS BASICALLY
SAYING LOOK ARE MY PATIENT
HERE'S THE YEARS THEIR PRO THAT
WE THINK IS A PRO AND THE TEN.
AND I COME FROM THE POSITION.
TO THE FIRST THE PHARMACIST
THAT HERE'S THE NUMBER OF RE OF
I'D LIKE TO AND PLAY FOR PERIOD
OF. THAT MAKES SENSE AND I
THINK THAT AND AGAIN I WOULD
PROBABLY LOOK TO. A ONE OF MY
WITH. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY QUESTION OR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. CASEY YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
THIS TIME ASSEMBLY WILL HOLD
AND YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
TERM HIGH YOU KNOW LET ME TO
SAY THE WE THINK THIS AN
IMPORTANT BILL. ARE WE READ.
THE THERE IS SOME COM. THAT WE
ARE PREPARED TO HAVE ALL WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. DURING THE
TIME OF THIS. OF IS A DRIVER
CONCERN AND THAT'S WHY WE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT WHICH WE DID
WE TO THE FOR THE- BEFORE WE-
EVEN DECIDED TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE THE BILL. AND ASK IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK NEED
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE IN A SET OF
BOOKS. THEY'RE THE ONES ON THE
FRONT LINE. THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT ARE DEALING WITH THE
PROCESSING OF THESE
PRESCRIPTIONS AND SO WE
RECOGNIZE THE SET SEVENTY AND-
TODAY. IN THIS. CORPORATION WE
MADE IT IS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE COMMERCE GOING FOR. BUT
AWAY AFTER I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS HOLDING THIS ENJOY
THE PASSWORD IS THERE MOTION IN
A SECOND. CAME MOVING MEDINA BY
DOCTOR. MISS SIXTY PLEASE CALL
THE- AB TWENTY NINE THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATE
LOW I. LOW HI BRO. BRUNO
ARAMBULA. RANDALL I BLOOM BLOOM
I. TO CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN. I
CANNOT VOTING FONG. FONG NOW
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON GRAYSON NOT VOTING
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
NOTING. THE BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT BILL
IS ON CALL. AND I WILL PASS
OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR AS NOW
BE PRESENTING A NUMBER OF BILLS.
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX A. B. NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT BY THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES- THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL. NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT EXCUSE ME- AS YOU MAY
RECALL OF SORT OF OUR CHEAP
PURPOSE AND FOCUS HAS BEEN WITH
RESPECT TO CONSUMER PROTECTION
THAT IS THAT OF THE AREA OF
EXPERTISE IN THIS ARENA AND
PART OF THE NOTION WAS SUCH
THAT WE LOOKED AT. THE SUNSET
EXTENSIONS DURING A NUMBER OF
ENTITIES INCLUDING THAT OF THE
DENTAL BOARD AND PART OF THAT
DISCOVERIES TO LOOK INTO
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
ASSOCIATED ISSUES OF FROM THAT
IT BECAME VERY APPARENT THAT
THERE WERE UNSCRUPULOUS
PRACTICES GOING ON WITH
PREDATORY PRACTICES
SPECIFICALLY. IN HURTING
CONSUMERS SIMILARLY WE'VE
MENTIONED THEN AND PASSING
LEGISLATION THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE THE ISSUES
ON CONSUMER PROTECTION AB PLACE
WHAT IT IS SO SUCH THAT THERE
IS THIS NOTION OF THIS TELL IT
TO STREET AND THESE PRODUCTS
WHICH FRANKLY IS. TELE CRAP
SALUTE OR TO SEE WHAT EXACT
OCCURRING WHAT I MEAN BY THIS
YOU MIGHT THINK WELL WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM OPPOSITION THAT
THIS PER DOMINANTLY HURTS.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WELL IT'S
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE FACTS THE
FACTS OP SPECIFICALLY THAT ARE
VERY OWN ATTORNEY GENERAL
OBVIOUS HERE AS A DISCIPLINARY
ACTION AGAINST COMPANY WITH
THIS SEC. AN AIR FRANCE IN.
FRAUD GROW SICK WE GROSS
NEGLIGENT TREE. AIDING ABETTING
A- DENTISTRY ADVERTISE TO
MISLEAD OUR OWN ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS THIS PLAN ACTIONS
AGAINST COMPANIES IN THIS
INDUSTRY. BUT IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE THAT MAYBE HAVE A THAT
CLOSE TO TWO THOUSAND
COMPLAINTS FROM THE BETTER
BUSINESS BUREAU OR THE
PRACTICES TO WHICH WE SEE THESE
COMPANIES SUING THE DENTAL
BOARDS IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA
OR ALABAMA. OR THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH LET'S SAY LESTER HOLT OF
NIGHTLY NEWS DOES A CONSUMER
REPORTS. PIECE THAT
DEMONSTRATES THE- SCRUPULOUS
PREDATORY ACTIONS. WHAT IS THE
COMPANY DO. THIS CURRENTLY OF
LAWSUIT TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR LAWSUIT. FROM THESE
COMPANIES AGAINST NBC. WHAT IS
A NEW YORK TIMES ARTICLE SAY
THIS COMPANY SAYS IT WILL FIX
YOUR SMILE. BUT IT ALSO MAY
SHUT YOU. IF IT DOESN'T. WAS
THE LA TIMES SAY BRACE YOURSELF
FOR THE REST. WHAT DOES FOX
NEWS SAY. COSTING CONSUMERS
MORE WHAT IS REUTERS SAY TALK
ABOUT THE CRACKDOWN FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. MEMBERS THIS
IS SPECIFICALLY THAT OF OUR
CONSUMER PROTECTION IN PLACE
NOW YOU'LL HEAR FROM ADVOCATES
THAT. THIS IS ANTI INNOVATION
THAT WE SHOULD SUPPORT TELE
DENTISTRY. BUT THIS IS SUB PAR.
CONSUMER ADVOCACY THIS IS
HURTING COMMUNITIES. AND THAT
IS WHY IT IS IN OUR BEST
INTEREST TO PROTECT CONSUMERS.
IT BRINGS ME NO DELIGHT AS THE
MEMBER FROM SILICON VALLEY TO
TAKE ON. AN INDUSTRY THAT LIKES
TO PROMOTE ITSELF AS THE
INNOVATION ECONOMY. BUT FRANKLY
WE ALSO NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROTECTIONS ARE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT PEOPLE AND WE SHOULD
NOT TO LOOK AT JUST SHAREHOLDER
PROFIT AT THE EXPENSE OF
EVERYDAY PEOPLE. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS FUNCTION
FUNDAMENTALLY IS ABOUT THIS
BILL BEFORE US REQUIRES THEN
THAT YOU HAVE IN IN PERSON
pAND PROFESSIONS. WE OVERSEE A
LOT OF THE LICENSE CATEGORIES.
AS AN EXAMPLE MY FATHER'S AN
ATOMIC TRISTEN I DOCTOR. AND
SIMILARLY HE WOULD LIKE ME TO
PURCHASE THESE GLASSES AT HIS
OFFICE. BUT HE DOESN'T KNOW SO
HAVE A GOOD SELECTION HIS STYLE
IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. SO
WHAT I DO. I ASKED HIM FOR THE
PRESCRIPTION. HE LEGALLY
OBLIGATED TO GIVE ME MY
PRESCRIPTION SO- I DO I GO TO
THE MALL I'M READY TO WATCH A
MOVIE THE LINES LONG AT THE
RESTAURANT SO I GO TO THE MALL
I SEE ALL THESE FRAMES. WELL I
HAVE A PRESCRIPTION I GO AND
PURCHASE. THE FRIENDS MYSELF.
IT'S THAT CHOICE. BUT I MUST DO
SO IN AN INFORMED FASHION. AND
WE CANNOT BYPASS THE
CONSULTATION OF A DOCTOR TO BE
ABLE TO. UTILIZED PRODUCTS THAT
COULD CAUSE SIGNIFICANT HARM.
SIMILARLY IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WHY IS IMPORTED GET AN X. RAY
IN PERSON FOR A VISIT WITH YOUR
DENTIST AS WELL PERHAPS YOU
MIGHT HAVE THE K. CAVITIES
SHORTEN ROUTES OR GUM DISEASE.
THE PRODUCT MIGHT NOT BE
SUITABLE FOR YOU IN THAT CASE.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE. THAT'S WHY THIS
IS A SIMPLE PROTECTIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE-
COORDINATION WITH YOUR DOCTOR.
ENSURING THAT THIS IS AN
ELIGIBLE PRODUCTS AND YOU CAN
UTILIZED SAFELY. EVER THAT'S
WHAT THIS CONVERSATION IS ABOUT
AND WITH INTELLIGENCE OF A VICE
CHAIR ALSO HAVE A FEW BOARDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE
CHAIR THESE ARE SPECIFICALLY
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
TYPE OF RISKS I THIS IS A POST
ON SOCIAL MEDIA EVERY TIME I
PUT. THEM IN. STARTS BLEEDING
HERE IT IS. EVEN DIRECTLY FROM
ONE OF THE COMPANIES AS A
RESPONSE FROM THE COMPANY'S
PUBLIC LISTING HERE SMILE
DIRECT CLUB BASE THEY REPLIED
TO CONSUMER SAYING ALL MEMBERS
ARE REQUIRED TO VISIT A DENTIST.
SIR SAYING YOU REQUIRE THEM TO
VISIT THE DENTIST ANYWAY BUT
HERE'S THE REALITY. NO ONE
READS THE CONSENT FORMS AND
JUST CLICK YOU JUST CLICK AWAY.
BUT THEY SAY SO THEMSELVES
YOU'RE REQUIRED TO VISIT THE
DENTIST. OTHER PEOPLE SAY I
COULDN'T STOP TALKING IT WAS
VERY PAINFUL. AND THEN HERE'S
WHAT THEY SAY IN THE FINE PRINT
ALL OF THESE COMPANIES. THAT IS
THE ONLY ADDRESS THE ALIGNMENT
OF MY TEETH- NOT CORRECT MY
EXISTING BITE CONDITION. MY
TEETH WILL BE STRAIGHTER THAN
THEY CURRENTLY ARE BUT WILL
STILL BE COMPROMISED. ALTHOUGH
MY TEETH WILL BE STRAIGHTER ANY
PRE EXISTING BY CONDITIONAL
REMAIN COMPROMISED. SO AGAIN
WE'RE LOOKING AT PRACTICES IT
IS THAT AREA OF JURISDICTION
FOR OUR COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT
CONSUMER PROTECTION. AGAINST
THESE TECH ROAST ARE LOOKING TO
JUST MAKE A QUICK DOLLAR ASKING
FOR FORGIVENESS THAN FOR
PERMISSION AND IT IS INCUMBENT
UPON US IN A DUE DILIGENCE A
PUBLIC PROTECTION IN THIS
COMMITTEE OF BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS. TO GO AFTER IT AND
AGAIN LET'S LOOK AT THE FACTS.
AND THAT'S WHY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS A DISCIPLINARY ACTION. ALL
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM ON A WIDE
VARIETY OF PRACTICES. SO AGAIN
THIS BILL IS SENSIBLE AND
ENSURING THAT YOU HAVE. THAT X.
RATE FROM THAT VISIT IN PERSON
VISIT. VERY REASONABLE. WHILE
ALSO SUPPORTING THE DIVISION
THAT STILL EXISTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR THE
MAIN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO RIGHT. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MERRY IN WITH HELP
DONALD. HERE TODAY WITH THE
SUPPORT AMENDED ON EIGHTEEN
NINETY EIGHT AT THE APRIL BUT
MY LOWER FOCUS ON THE ISSUE AND
SIMILARLY TO THE CHAIR BELIEVE
THERE ARE TWO PUT. NEEDED FOR
PATIENTS WITH THE POWER DID ON
A CARE EVEN THE PASSAGE OF LAST
YEAR AB SO NINE. ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO PATIENT
ACCOUNT THAT MANY OF DIRECT
CONSUMER PORTAL COMING HAVE YET
TO COME WITH THE NEW PAY ABOUT
REQUIREMENTS THAT WENT INTO AT
THE OF THIS YEAR AN ADDITIONAL
PAGE ARE BEGIN TO SEE THE TERM
OF DIRECTED. OR BUSINESS MODEL
ONE OF THE MAJOR ARE LOT EATING
AND ABC NINETEEN DESPITE
RECEIVING FEDERAL PROTECT LEARN
HAS CURRENT THERE ANY TO FISCAL
PRE ORDERED ONLINE WILL PROCESS
FUN BUT YET AT THE TIME THERE'S
A NEW ORDERS FOR IMPRESSION HIT
THIS IS GOING PATIENT ON THE.
PRIMARY EXAMPLE IS A VIRTUAL
BATTLE HOME WERE SPECIALLY
TRAINED DENTAL STAFF PROVIDE
CARE AND A REMOTE SUPERVISION
OF A DENNIS AND BECAUSE OF THIS
WE PLAN TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR
TO DEVELOP AMENDMENT THAT
ENSURE HOW ORTHODONTIC
BUSINESSES HAVE THE SAME LEVEL
OF PATIENTS SB AS IN PERSON
DENTAL CARE BOB DOLE PRESERVING
THE PROGRESS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS PREVIOUSLY MADE ON
TELEVISION. THREE POLICY. BRING
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE'S NOT. TO
CLOSE STATUTES RECALLED BY
SEVERAL SHE MAKES. PATIENT TO
REQUEST AN RECORD AND SIGNED
CONTRACT BUT THEIR PROVIDER AND
EXPANDING THE PROHIBITION FOR
ANY PERSON INCLUDING EMPLOYEE
ACTUALLY. TO ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT THAT LIMIT THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY THE MAIN
COMPLAINT A REGULATOR AND OF
THE REASON. CDA RESPECTFULLY
URGES THE COMMITTEE TOOK I ON
THE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU SHOW WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT MODERATOR. YES
COOPER REPRESENTING CALENDARS
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ORAL AND MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS
WALL CALENDAR DOES SUPPORT
CALIDAD A THREE IN SOME
INSTANCES CERTAIN STANDARDS OF
CARE NEED TO BE CLEARLY
CODIFIED IT IS OUR POSITION
THAT YOUR REVERSIBLE TREATMENTS
SUCH AS ORTHODONTICS REQUIRED
DATA GATHERING AND TREATMENT
PLANNING OFTENTIMES THERE ARE
CERTAIN NUANCES TO THE
EXAMINATION THEREFORE WE
BELIEVE THE DENTIST NEEDS TO
SEE AND TREAT THE PATIENT IN
PERSON AND THEREFORE WE SUPPORT
AB NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AS
INTRODUCED WITHOUT A MAN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. LIKE TO
SHARE YOUR POSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. A LINE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES OF THE MAIN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS COURTNEY
JENSEN WHAT TACK MATT IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT AT THE BILL-
INCLUDE RESTRICTIONS THAT RUN
CONTRARY TO PROGRESS THAT AN
ANIMATED HEALTH CARE PUBLIC
POLICY NOTABLY AT A TIME WHEN
PUBLIC HEALTH IS BEING
EXPLORED. AND EXPANDED TO KEEP
PATIENTS SAFE FROM VIRAL
EXPOSURE THIS LEGISLATION
JEOPARDIZES THE SUCCESSES
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION HAS
HAD HEALTHCARE SUCH AS REDUCE
COSTS AND INCREASE ACT ACCESS
DAMMERS. THESE BENEFITS ARE
PARTICULARLY EVIDENT IN THE
TELE DENTISTRY FACE WHERE
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
DENTAL ASSOCIATION HELP PAUL
AND HERE THIS CALL ACCESS TO A
DENNIS ACOSTA HERE ARE THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES FOR
CONSUMERS AND CALIFORNIA.
BALLOT INDUSTRY OFFERS A
SOLUTION BUT NIGHT AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT WITH STRICT THAT
pADDED. CALIFORNIA AT EVERY
STATE IN THE NATION AS SPEAKING
TO ENCOURAGE TELEHEALTH THIS
MOVE CALIFORNIA BACKWARDS
CREATING MORE BARRIERS TO
DENTAL CARE ACCESS. IN FACT
DOCTOR MARK ACKERMAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE AT THE BEACH AND A
CALIFORNIA LICENSE DENNIS. WHO
IS ON THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY LINE
IN A RESOURCE FOR CLINICAL
QUESTION I STATED THAT THE
WHOLE GOAL CAL HEALTH IS TO BE
ABLE TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
QUALITY AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE.
WE HAVE YET TO SEE ANY CLINICAL
EVIDENCE THAT REQUIRING MORE IN
PERSON VISIT BENEFITS
CALIFORNIANS REQUIRING AN IN
PERSON VISIT TO A DENNIS BEFORE
TELE DENTISTRY IS NOT ONLY
CONTRARY TO THE STANDARD OF
CARE. BUT WILL SHOT OUT
CALIFORNIANS AND GETTING THE
CARE THEY WANT NEED AND
DESERVE. FURTHER NOTE STATE AND
ANY BRAND TELEMATICS AND HAVE
AN IN PERSON REQUIREMENT AND
LAW OR REGULATION. THIS IS
CORRECT THAT BENEFIT
CALIFORNIANS. DENNIS PRACTICING
USING ABOUT COLLAGEN. ARE LIGHT
CALIFORNIA DOWN AT OUR- GAME
THEATER. THE ANY TREAT. I AND
AT THAT. AIM OLD COURSE AND AT.
ORDERED UNDER THE- AND GOVERNOR
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL. FINALLY
THIS PUT THAT RAY AT LEAST FIVE
JOBS AN APP SALARY OF APPROX
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THE ANY. EVIDENCE TO PROVE
THIS BILL NECESSARY SAID NOW IS
THE TIME TO SHUT ANDERSON IN
CAL AND JOBS WE ARE YOUR NOSE
ON EIGHTY NINE NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL WHAT ROB.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SELENA
FIRE AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE BLACK SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ESPN
OPPOSES AB NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT BECAUSE THE PATH IT WOULD
CREATE AN ACCESS ISSUE TO ORAL
HEALTH CARE FOR MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES AND IN MANY AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY. UNDER SERVED BY
THE DENTAL INDUSTRY FOR
GENERATIONS I HAVE A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE ON HOW CRITICAL
TELOGEN IS STREET HE
STRAIGHTENED SERVICES ARE AS I
DECIDED IN MY THIRTY TO GET MY
FEET STRAIGHT AND I WAS IN AND
THERE'S A LINE CUSTOMER AND
AFTER I RECEIVED MY EYELINER
MIGHT GET THIS ONE OUT OF IT.
AND DIDN'T COULDN'T HELP ME I
WAS STUCK AND I COULDN'T AFFORD
TO RESTART WITH ANOTHER DENTAL
HAD I BEEN USING TELE DENTISTRY
SERVICE THAT DID NOT REQUIRE IN
PERSON VISITS I WOULD NOT HAVE
HAD THE TROUBLE BACK AT BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY BECAUSE THIS
IS A LIFETIME BENEFITS I WAS
UNABLE TO COMPLETE TREATMENT
AND THE STATE LOCKED OUT ON ITS
INVESTMENT. IF EIGHT NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT PRACTICE WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT CONSUMERS WILL
BE STRIPPED OF THIS OPTION FOR
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
OPTION TO STRAIGHTEN ARCHY DOES
MORE LAYOFFS AND JOB WILL JUST
TAKE PLACE TO THE PUBLIC
NINETEEN WE WILL NOT HAVE WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD IN
PERSON VISIT AND FOR THOSE WHO
ARE LUCKY TO FIND EMPLOYMENT WE
WILL HAVE. TO TAKE OFF FOR WORK
FOR THESE REASONS BAFTA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THANK YO THANK
YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
KILL ANY OTHER MEMBERS. OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION. THE PRESS
ONE THEN THE AT THIS TIME. YOU
HAVE A FEW LINES IN Q. ME JUST
A MOMENT.
FIRST LINE WILL GO TO
A LINE ONE SIX FIVE ONE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY
NAME IS DOCTOR JEFFREY SO LET'S
SIR I AM A CALIFORNIA LICENSE
DENTISTS AND HAVE BEEN LICENSED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS I AM IN
OPPOSITION AND OPPOSED TO
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. THANK
YOU I'M ALSO I'M ALSO
AFFILIATED WITH SMILE DIRECTLY.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIX NINE
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS DOCTOR MARK
ACKERMAN I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE
TRANSPORTATION THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE CENTER AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
AND ONE SIX FOUR ONE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
THE ONE LOMBARD I'M THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIX SIX ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ALBERTO TO
RECALL THE APPLE BUY TO LET YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE.
OF RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION.
THANK. ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR ONE
SEVENTY FOUR AIRLINERS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BECAUSE
SANDRA JENNINGS PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
URBAN LEAGUE AND WE OPPOSE AB
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OUR LAST LINE
IN QUEUES ONE SEVEN ZERO ONE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
YES MY NAME IS TO REACH DURING
MY LOW WEAVER PRESIDENT AND CEO
NOT FEDERAL EXPRESS THEIR
CRUSADE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
A. B. NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CAN YOU
MAY CONTINUE NO OTHER LINES AND
KILL THANK YOU KNOW A MODERATOR
NO OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
WISHING TO REGISTER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THAT'S CORRECT
THANK YOU. I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY%
MEMBERS WISHING TO COMMENT OR
QUESTION MR GRAYSON. THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR I DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS AND ONE OF
THEM. IS IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT- SMILED DIRECTS PRODUCT
TARGETS THE- TOP AND BOTTOM
SIXTEENTH ON THE FRONT ON THE
FRONT. IS THERE- IS THERE A WAY
THAT THEY GUARANTEE THAT IT
DOESN'T MOVE OR IMPACT THE
OTHER TEETH. THAT ARE IN THE
MOUTH I KNOW THAT'S A REAL
TECHNICAL QUESTION. BUT DO THEY
HAVE A GUARANTEE AND THERE'S A
REASON WHY I ASK THAT. MY
APOLOGIES I'M NOT THAT FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT THE PRIVATE SECTOR-
IT BUSINESS. IS ADVERTISING BUT
I CAN SAY- THAT SPECIFICALLY-
WITH RESPECT TO CARE. THEY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS DOES NOT
FIX A BITE. WHEN FACT IS JUST
COSMETIC SO THERE COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT ASSOCIATE HARM-
SURROUNDING THIS BUT THEY AGAIN
VERY MUCH INDICATE YOU HEARD
FROM TESTIMONY THAT THIS IS.
DENTAL CARE WHEN IN FACT ON THE
DISCLOSURES SPECIFICALLY AT
THAT LIGHT THAT PREVIOUSLY
SHOWED YOU. THIS IS NOT A
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THAT OF
DENTAL CARE THEY JUST TALKED
ABOUT THAT OF NOT FIXING THE
BITE AND THE KNOWLEDGE THAT. SO
I HEARD IT SAID- THAT THE
COMPLAINS THAT THAT YOU
MENTIONED TO BETTER BUSINESS
BUREAU AND THINGS LIKE THAT. I
HEARD IS SAID THAT THOSE
COMPLAINTS WERE NOT NECESSARILY
ABOUT. THE PRODUCT AS MUCH AS
IT WAS ABOUT THE SERVICE THAT
WAS BEING PROVIDED SO THERE'S
KIND OF A- DISTANT GENUINE-
CLAIMED THAT- THE PRODUCT IS
DOING HARM. IT WAS JUST A
MATTER OF MAYBE SOME BAD
SERVICE THAT THE CUSTOMER GOT.
A HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
DELINEATE BETWEEN WHAT WAS A
PRODUCT ISSUE VERSES. A SERVICE
ISSUE SURE THE AND THE EVIDENCE
IT IS SUGGESTED IN IS VERY VERY
CLEAR YES THERE'S A WIDE
VARIETY OF COMPLAINTS FROM THE
BETTER BUSINESS BUREAU. BUT
WHEN YOU COMPOUND THAT. IN
ADDITION TO THAT OF THE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION
SPECIFICALLY FOR FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ARE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND ALL THE ARTICLES
AND FRANKLY. AS YOU WELL KNOW
THE WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE IN
LOOKING AT THE DETAILS COMING
FROM THE SUNSET EXTENSION OF
THE TEN SUPPORT. AND THAT
ADVANCING AND CONTINUE THAT
WHICH IS TO SAY THAT THE MORE
WE DUG INTO THIS ISSUE. THE
MORE THAT WE FOUND AND OF
COURSE IT'S EASY POLITICS
BEATING FOR ME JUST TO TURN A
BLIND GUY. AGAINST MY TECH
FRIENDS BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE AND SAID THIS
IS WRONG AT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ADDRESS. LAST NAME. THE HAVE
YOU. GIVEN OPPOSITION THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME TO THE
TABLE- COMPANIES WHO WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THIS. AND TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH HOW THIS
BILL WOULD DEVELOP AND MOVE
FORWARD. YES ABSOLUTELY HAVE
BEEN AND CONTINUE CONVERSATION.
WITH THEM AND ACTUALLY HAVE AS
PUBLIC RECORD THAT OF OUR
PROACTIVE. REACHING OUT TO
ELICIT ANY CONVERSATION. TO
LOOK AT AN IMMENSE IN TRYING TO
WORK FORCE OUGHT MARK FORD ON
ON THESE ISSUES SO ABSOLUTELY
AND AN ABUNDANCE OF RECOGNITION
OF TRYING TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION. HAVE EXHAUSTED THAT
OUT WITH NO RESULTS AND- AND
AGAIN NO THAT FROM THIS
COMMITTEE THE IMPETUS FROM THIS
WAS WHAT WE DISCOVERED. THIS IS
NOT JUST OF THAT I JUST WOKE UP
SOME DAY AND SAID I'M GOING TO.
RUN FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND GO
AFTER THIS BUT IT WAS A
SIGNIFICANT DISCOVERY FROM THE
FACT OF THAT WE DID IT THE
DILIGENCE OF A SUNSET PAPER.
THANK YOU. MR HOLDEN YES I'D
I'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO CLOSE MY
QUESTION TO THE OPPOSITION'S
MAIN WITNESS OF PARKER.
MODERATOR COULD YOU OPEN THE
LINE OF THE MAIN OPPOSITION
WITNESS PLEASE. PILOT OPEN FOR
THE QUESTION IS THAT WE
UNDERSTAND UNDER. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SITUATION THEY
WERE DEALING WITH WITH CO IN
NINETEEN. THAT A LOT OF THESE
TELE DENTISTRY. ARE WOULD LIKE
TO OPERATE ON A PLATFORM. THEY
GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONVENIENT FOR THEIR FOR THEIR
CLIENTS- CAN YOU TELL US SO
WHAT I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND IS
WHAT IS. THE RELATIONSHIP. WITH
THESE COMPANIES WITH BRICK AND
MORTAR- DENTAL PRACTITIONERS.
THANK YOU I HAVE MISTER RIGHT
HERE AND MEMBERS AND ALL THAT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION AS
A CORE IN JACKSON I PACKED THAT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THAT ANSWER A
QUESTION BUT YOU SO TELL IT IN
THE CODE NINETEEN TIME OUR
COMPANIES HAVE DEFINITELY BEEN-
WORKING THE WAY IT BRICK AND
MORTAR DENNIS- YOU OFFER. HELLO
HELLO AND CAL DENTISTRY
PLATFORM TO ENSURE THAT THEIR-
YOU KNOW CUSTOMERS AND THEIR
THEIR PATIENTS CAN CONTINUE TO
GET SERVED AT THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE STREET THOSE BEACH AND
HAS WORKEDWITH MANY DEBT-
JANET DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC TO GET THEM UP AND
RUNNING TO PROVIDE THE PUBLIC
WITH TELE DENTISTRY SERVICES-
AND ONE OF OUR MEMBER COMPANIES
WAS ALL ALSO THE FIRST OPERATE
DIGITAL TELL AT DENTISTRY
PLATFORM TO DENNIS. AND EIGHTY
BE A AFTER BROADCASTING THAT
AVAILABILITY OF THAT POPCORN
HAS RECEIVED A REPORT THAT THE
DENNIS WITH. BRICK AND MORTAR
PRACTICE WERE ABLE TO. ASIAN
DURING THE TRIAL TIME WHERE THE
TELE STRIPPED AND JUST AS AN
FROM ARM COME. NINETEENTH FIRST
OF AT THEIR- DOWN AT ALSO OFFER
TRADITIONAL BRICK AND MORTAR.
THE MAN DENNIS WHO IT OF THAT-
ARE OPERATING BY HELLO
DENTISTRY POPCORN BAD WELL AS
AND IN BRICK AND MORTAR
LOCATION. THANK YOU ARE JUST A
QUESTION OR COMMENT ACTUALLY TO
THE TO THE AUTHOR. OF I THINK
THAT. YOU HAVE OF CERTAINLY
DONE A LOT OF REVIEW AND HAVE.
UNCOVERED SOME ISSUES HERE THAT
I THINK ARE IMPORTANT TO NOT
LOSE SIGHT OF AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY- BUT
I'M HOPING THAT. AS A
CONVERSATIONS CAN STILL HAPPEN-
GOING FORWARD. IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE COULD BE CERTAIN ELEMENTS
OF HOW WE MOVE FORWARD THAT
COULD JUST ESSENTIALLY WIPED
THIS. PART OF THE SEGMENT OF
THE BUSINESS MARKET AL. AND SO
I I'D LIKE TO. KNOW THAT
THERE'S AT LEAST SOME OPENNESS
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO NEW
ON CERTAIN- CONCERNS AND TRY TO
FIND WAYS AYE AND LET ME JUST
SAY THAT I CAN SPEAK FOR MYSELF
THAT YOU HAVE- BEEN. ARE VERY
FORTHRIGHT AND SITTING ON A
TRYING TO WORK THINGS OUT SO I
DO APPRECIATE THAT I THINK
THAT'S WHAT YOU BRING TO THE
CONVERSATION SO I'M ASKING A
QUESTION ABOUT WE ALREADY KNOW
THE ANSWER TO BUT- I JUST
THOUGHT I'D TO. SEE IF YOU'RE
OPEN TO THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ABSOLUTELY A SUMMER
HOLDEN- IT IS. THE DEEP
COMMITMENT OF MYSELF. AND OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO BE AS
TRANSPARENT. OPENED PROACTIVE.
IN ENSURING THAT WE HAVE.
ENGAGE WITH ALL INTERESTS
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION ALIKE-
AND SIMILARLY I WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO WE HAVE DONE SO IN
WRITING- AND THAT IS A DEEP
COMMITMENT THAT I SHARE AND
CONTINUOUSLY BUT BEFORE. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TO SPEAK.
SEEING NONE MISTER JERRY MY
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CAN BE MEMBERS AGAIN
I APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE
AND THINKING ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
ISSUE AT HAND- BUT AGAIN WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE COMPANY AND
THIS GROWING. INDUSTRY TO WHICH
THEY SIDE STEP THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK OF BASIC CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT'S WRONG. AND
WE MISSED CALL IT OUT AS WE SEE
IT AND SPECIFICALLY THESE ARE
SOME OF THE TECH COMPANIES THAT
RECEIVED VENTURE CAPITAL FOR
THE REGION THAT HAIL FROM SO
GIVE ME NO DELIGHT. TO GO AFTER.
THE TECH INDUSTRY BUT IT IS OUR
OBLIGATION WITH RESPECT TO
PUBLIC INTEREST AND AGAIN. THE
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS FROM
ATTORNEY GENERAL SPEAK FOR
ITSELF. AND IT WAS VERY MUCH A
QUESTION TO WHICH WE EXPLORE
THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR WTH
RESPECT TO X. RAYS AND AGAIN
THE CLARIFICATION NOW THIS YEAR
IS THE IN PERSON EXAMS. I WOULD
HAVE BEEN POTENTIALLY
POLITICALLY SPEAKING JUST TO
STOP THERE AND SAID OKAY ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH. BUT THAT'S WHY YOU
SEE SIGNIFICANT ACTION GOING ON
THAT'S WHY. WE'RE TAKING THIS
ACTION MOVING THIS ISSUE FOR.
AND TRYING TO ACCOMMODATE A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. A SIMILAR
YOU HEARD SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS
ABOUT DIRECTLY MARKETING TO
CONSUMERS. HOW ABOUT THAT
NOTION OF THAT MALARIA DRUG
HYDROXY CLARK WHEN WOULD YOU
WANNA AMOUNT OF MEDICALLY JUST
TAKE THAT WITHOUT CONSULTATION
FROM A DOCTOR. THERE
SIGNIFICANT HARM BUT WE ARE THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE AND THEY'RE OF
JURISDICTION OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
AND THAT IS THE VANTAGE POINT
TO WHICH WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
SO WITH RESPECT I ASKED FOR A
VOTE. COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. LOW AYE BRO
DOWNLOAD BURNOUT VOTING
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I AM BLOOM.
BLOOM I TEN. TO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
FONG FIND AT LEARNING GET OUT
THANK FONG AYE GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE GLORIA. GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN WHEN I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA I AM MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO TING.
THE BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES THE
PLACENTA. THE BILLS OUT CONTROL
UP IN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL
NOW MOVE ON THE FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN THE CHAIR SECOND
BILL AB TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS ROGER
AND COLLEAGUES THIS SIMPLY
ALIGNS WITH THAT OF THE-
EXPLORATION OF PROCESSING FOR
LICENSING FOR REFUGEES AND
ASYLUM SEEKERS SO MUCH THAT OF
WHAT WE DO FOR VETERANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND THEN
LOW AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DONNA
GIVEN I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE INTERNATIONAL
RESCUE COMMITTEE AND SAN DIEGO.
THE IRISH SEA AS A REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT AGENCY WITH TWENTY
FIVE OFFICES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. INCLUDING SEVEN RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE PROVIDE
A RANGE OF SERVICES AND SUPPORT
TO NEWLY ARRIVED REFUGEES AND
THE BROADER IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
IN OUR STATE. I URGE YOU TO
DATE HIS SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN REFUGEES IF I LEAVE
AND IMMIGRANTS PROFESSIONAL I
THINK LIKE THANK. AT THE I RC
WE WORK WITH REFUGEES
AGGRESSIVE THEY REBUILD THEIR
LIVES IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WORK TOWARDS SELF SUFFICIENCY
AND INTEGRATION. FOR MANY
NEWCOMERS THAT MEANS THE FIRING
TO RELY FOOD PROGRAM WE
CREDENTIALS IN THE US. TO
CONTINUE TO IN THEIR TRAINED
AND CHOSEN FIELD. HOWEVER THESE
END OF FAITH AND THEN BARRIERS
BUT IT TO READ AND OR WE
LICENSE IN THE YEAR. AS THEY
WORK TO REBUILD LIVES AND A NEW
COUNTRY. SOME OF THE BARRIERS
ARE INSURMOUNTABLE. THAT IS WHY
WE ARE SO PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL WHICH ADDRESSES ONE
FETCH BARRIER TO ENTRY. AND
THAT IS TIMING. REFUGEES HAVE
NINETY DAYS TO ACHIEVE SELF
SUFFICIENCY WHEN THEY FIRST
ARRIVE IN YOU ASKED FOR THE
OPTION TO WAIT IT OUT. WEATHER
APPLICATION IS REVIEWED AND
CONSIDERED IS JUST NOT AN
OPTION. MAY LET'S BEGIN WERE
IT'S GONNA POSSIBLE UP AND-
ACCEPTING THE FOR MAN WAGE JOB
SAYS OFFERED. FOR CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A HUGE LASSEN THAT THIS
AND MANY OTHER BARRIERS PREVENT
OUR STATE FROM TAPPING INTO THE
VAST AND DIVERSE SKILLS OF OUR
NEWEST AMERICAN LABOR. TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE THE CURRENT HEALTHCARE
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNDER UTILIZED
IMMIGRANT HEALTHCARE WORKERS
WHO RECEIVE THEIR MEDICAL
EDUCATION OUTSIDE OF THE U. S.
THAT MEANS THOUSAND OF
INDIVIDUAL WITH VITAL
EXPERIENCE. WHO COULD BE
SUPPORTING OUR STATE RESPONSE
THE CODE NINETEEN AND FILLING
SHORTAGE OF BUYING EXPERIENCE
BY THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY.
MANY SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA
RECIPIENTS TO WORK FOR OR
ALONGSIDE THE U. S. MISSION IN
IRAQ OR AFGHANISTAN ARE ALSO
HIGHLY SKILLED PROFESSIONALS.
THAT IS ENGINEERED MECHANICS
AND ELECTRICIANS AND FIND
THEMSELVES UNDER EMPLOYED AND
WORKING IN JOBS THAT DO NOT
LEVERAGE THEIR PROFESSIONAL
TRAINING AND SKILLS. FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS RETURNING TO
BECAUSE CAREER. WHAT MADE ME
OPPORTUNITY TO MORE RAPIDLY
PURCHASE A HOME SAVE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN'S FUTURE AND TRULY
CREATE A HOME AND A NEW
COMMUNITY. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN AND ALLOW THESE
TALENTED INDIVIDUALS TO UTILIZE
THEIR SKILLS AND GIVE BACK TO
THE COMMUNITY THAT WELCOME
THEM. CHAIRMAN LOW AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL NOT A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS TALKED
FELT THING THAT I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN SO I GOT
THE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES THAT
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES BASED
IN OBTAINING PROFESSIONAL
LICENSES. IMMIGRANT REGARDLESS
OF BATTERED CONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANTLY TO CALIFORNIA'S
THROWBACK THING GROWING ECONOMY
IMMIGRANT COMPRISED OVER ONE
THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS WORK FOR
THE STATE IS ALSO BENEFITED
FROM AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP FROM
200-072-2000 ELEVEN IN THE YEAR
FOLLOWING THE GREAT RECESSION.
IMMIGRANTS IN THE STATE SENATE
APPROXIMATELY 45% OF ALL NEW
BUSINESSES ALL THIRTY SIX POINT
6% OF THE STATE BUSINESS OWNERS
WILL TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN ARE
IMMIGRANTS. AS WE START TO
THINK ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIA ARE
FROM THE ECONOMIC CRISES THE
CURRENT WILL FACE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND GREATER
ACCESS TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES CONTINUE
TO BE NECESSARY TO HELP FOR OUR
ECONOMY WHAT WHERE. DESPITE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS OF
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IS MISSING
OUT BY NOT FULLY ACKNOWLEDGING
VALUING AND INVESTING IN ALL OF
OUR IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. IMMIGRANT
WORKERS ARE ON AVERAGE 20% LESS
THAN US ONE WORKERS WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT MANY PEOPLE WHO
COME TO THE US ARE WORKING BUT
ARE WORKING IN LOW WAGE JOBS
WITH THEIR SUBJECT TO
APPLICATION AND ABUSED WITHOUT
A PATH FORWARD. BUT ABOUT
PEOPLE LIKE CALIFORNIANS WERE
NOT IN MOST DON'T BUT LOW PAID
JOBS AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE LIKE ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE NOT SKILLED. RATHER
HIGHLY SKILLED WITH A RANGE OF
EXPERIENCES THAT ARE SIMPLY NOT
ALWAYS VALUED ARE ABLE TO BE
TRANSLATED. INTO HIGHER PAID
JOBS. IN THE I PP REPORT MAKING
RIGHT AND THAT. ENSURING MARK
ORKED ABOUT MEANT PROBE WORK
FOR CALIFORNIANS. WE THE NEED
CHALLENGES THAT AND REFUGEE
WORK FACING. BASED ON CON. WITH
OVER CAN BASED. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE FOUND THAT A COMMON
CHALLENGE FOR AND REFUGEES ACT
TO PROVIDE. LIKE THIS OCCUR TO.
ECONOMIC GETTING UP OF LIFE
WRECK. THE HIGH AND BUYING
INVESTMENT AND WHEN PEOPLE NEED
JOBS IMMEDIATELY BACK
INVESTMENT. NOT ALWAYS. AB
TWENTY THIRTEEN WOULD PROVIDE
EQUITABLE ACCESS OPTIONAL. FOR
BY. ASYLUM AND AGAIN BE DOUBLE.
ACTED I A LICENSING UP WITH ON
SHE THAT THE- WHO ARE FACE
TRAUMA. AND I CARDS. ARE ABLE
TO BUY BY NOW MORE QUICK AND A
STRONG. FOOTING AND I HOME AND
IT WILL HELP WITH THAT THE
IMPACT HIGHER WAGE. WHICH WILL
TRAIN INTO TO REVENUE I CANNOT
GROWTH AND FOR THAT WE URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU THOUGHT. THANK.
ADDITIONALLY THIS IS A SPORT
NAME AFFILIATE. IF YOU LIKE TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CHEN
MEMBERS BENJAMIN TREND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NECKLINE ONE EIGHT TO ONE
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AB
OUT WITH A FEW CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU. WE WERE LINE ONE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE EIGHTY THREE ALONE IT'LL
YES THANK YOU CALLING FOR AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. THAT'S
THE NEXT BILL SIR. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN A BOND WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND LASTLY- LINE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SCHERING GOAL FOR BEING OF
HEALTH SCIENCES COLLEGE OF
BILLION IN FULL SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MUCH THANK YOU LIST TO
WALMART ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT. NOT AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU LET'S- LET'S GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
WANT A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
THANK YOU BRING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANYBODY
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THE SIDE.
SEEING NONE. MISTER RESPECT AS
RIPE. THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY
MISTER MEDINA SECOND BY MISTER
ARAMBULA COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWO
ONE ONE THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW. LOW
AYE BRO BROWN NOW ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CHAN. TO CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE EGGMAN. FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON. GLORIA GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN
WHEN I MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN MULLIN
AYE OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NOTING.
ELEVEN VEGETABLE ISN'T. THAT
GIPSON AYE AYE TWELVE BUCKS BUT
LISTEN THE BILL IS OUT AS WE
MOVE TO OUR FINAL ITEM I'D LIKE
TO MAKE A CALL FOR ANY BE IN
PEAK COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
RETURN TO THE CHAMBER FOR FINAL
VOTING- OUR FINAL ITEM TODAY IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE BY THE
CHAIR. AB TWO TWO EIGHT EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES IS SIMPLY
TO HELP CLARIFY SOME OF THE
NURSING STUDENTS. THEY GET HELP
GOT HELD UP IN SOME OF THE
PLACEMENTS NOT GETTING THEIR
CLINICAL HOURS SO WE WANT TO
HELP ENSURE THAT WE CAN GET.
OUR FIRST LINE RESPONDERS AN
APPROPRIATE FASHION- I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
REPRESENTED FROM VENTURE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AT. A SCHOOL
OF NURSING AS WELL AS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE KINDLY ASK THOSE TWO.
NUMBERS TO SPEAK TO A LIMITED
TO THIRTY SECONDS IF YOU MIGHT
BE SUCCINCT. YOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECT VAST PRIVATE. MODERATOR
IF YOU'D OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE GO AHEAD HERE
LINES ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DOCTOR SANDRA MELTON
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL
OF NURSING AND ALLIED HEALTH
CENTER COLLEGE ANDPRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATION
ASSOCIATE DEGREE NURSING THE
ADSL I HAVE FORTY FOUR YEARS OF
EXPERIENCEIN NURSING EDUCATION
AND I'M THRILLED TO TESTIFY
TODAY- ON BEHALF OF THE- AB AND
WE SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENT AB.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT MORE
CODIFIED IN STATUTE GOVERNOR
NUISANCE EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
THIRTY NINE TWENTY THAT
PROVIDED FLEXIBILITY IN
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS DURING
THE GOVERNOR DECLARED DISASTER
THIS FLEXIBILITY IN
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS
SUPPORT THE NURSING WORKFORCE.
BY ENSURING THAT REGISTERED
NURSING STUDENTS AND PRE
LICENSURE ARE IN ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS CAN USE SCIENTIFICALLY
SOUND TEACHING AND LEARNING
METHODS TO HELP OUR IN STUDENTS
TO PROGRESS TOWARD GRADUATION
AND ENTER THE WORKFORCE AND
PROVIDE ACCESS TO CARE THAT
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLE TO OBTAIN
EVEN PRIOR TO THE COLD AT NIGHT.
WITH THIS SELECT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NURSING. WILL STRUGGLE
TO PROGRESS AND GRADUATE
NURSING STUDENTS FOR EXAMPLE
RIGHT NOW ONLY 74% OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADM PROGRAMS IN THE SOUTH CAN
COMPLETE THEIR LAST SEMESTER
STUDENTS WITH ANY CERTAINTY. IN
ADDITION 60% OF SCHOOLS HAVE
ONE SEMESTER FOR MORE OF
pTO PROGRESS TO THE NEXT
SEMESTER THIS IS THE RESULT OF
pLONGER ALLOW NURSING STUDENTS
IN THE FACILITIES FOR CLINICAL
EXPERIENCES. MY COLLEAGUES AND
I ARE WORKING TO FIND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS IN THIS CHALLENGING
CLIMB THAT BUT WITHOUT AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT WE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO GRADUATE AND
AFTER SEEING STUDENTS TO
MAINTAIN THE NURSING WORKFORCE
HI WANTING. TO AVOID A SHORTAGE
OF NURSES IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
FUTURE PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
NEXT PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY MAKE SURE YOU
CAN HEAR ME WE CAN. OKAY THANK
YOU ARE ON A ROLL RIGHT HERE IN
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS A PART OF
THEM AND I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT NURSING AND CLINICAL
SERVICES. AT THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND ARE AND TO
WORK IN OUR QUEUE CARE
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS.
NURSES ARE THE GLUE THAT HOLDS
OUR HOSPITAL TOGETHER AND
PROVIDE PATIENTS THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OPTIMAL
HEALTH HEALING AND RECOVERY.
MAINTAINING A STRONG ARE AND
WORKFORCE IS VITAL TO DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS AND NEEDING ANY.
OUR CRIED FOR ANY AND ALL
CRISES AND WILL BE CRUCIAL AS
WE RESUME DEFERRED CARE DURING
THE CARPET BANKING PANDEMIC
MERRY OUT OF REASON TO THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
COPING NINETEEN DISASTER
HOSPITALS AND ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONALIZED. ARE UNABLE
TO FULFIL AREN'T STUDENT
CLINICAL ROTATIONS AND HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES. TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND ARE IN STUDENTS ARE
NOW TO STAND STILL AND WE ARE
IN THE WORKFORCE HI POINT
STARTING OUR STATE RIGHT AREN'T
SUPPLY CHAIN. AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT SIX TO ADDRESS
HOCKEY BUT ON CLINICAL SETTING
NEEDS FLEXIBLE SOLUTIONS TO
RESPOND TO THE CODE NINETEEN
THIS AFTER. AND RESURGENT THOSE
OR ANY OTHER GOVERNMENT
DECLARED DISASTER THIS BILL
PROVIDES THAT SOLUTION AND WE'D
LIKE TO SUGGEST SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS AGREED UPON BY OUR
HELP WORK OUR STATE HEALTH
WORK. FOR WORK OR CENTER HEALTH
IMPACT AND MULTIPLE NURSING
PROFESSIONAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ONCE YOUR
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS THAT HERE THE
STANDARD AND TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION ALL THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC. IF YOUR THINK
CHRISTINE. HER WE PROPOSE THAT
THE LAND TO KEEP OUT INTO THE
OF TWENTY ONE AT. YEAR SECOND
THE DEATH. OF CONCURRENT THEORY
NEEDS TO BE PROUD WHICH TO
INCLUDE CRIER Q. AND CONCURRENT
WITH CLINICAL EDUCATION. THIRD
GENERATION EXPERIENCES AND
PROGRAM SHOULD ADHERE TO
NATIONAL STANDARDS. YEAH FOR
OUR AND PROGRAM DIRECTORS OF
ACADEMIC IN SHUSHAN ACCREDITED
BY A REGIONAL ACCREDITING
COMMISSION SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
DECREASE THEIR CLINICAL HOURS
TO TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. AND
THEN FINALLY THE BILL NEEDS TO
NARROW THE DEFINITION OF ALL
ALTERNATE CAN FACILITY TO
INCLUDE ACCEPT A CALL FACILITY
YOU'RE CREEPIN METATRADER
BURDEN ON ACADEMIC INSTITUTION.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT IS
ESSENTIAL TO PREVENT
INTERRUPTION IN THE ARE AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE HI FINE
THEY COULD PROPEL US INTO A
STATEWIDE NURSING SHORTAGE.
THAT'S WHEN I TURN HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. NURSING STUDENT
CONGRESSIONAL CRITICAL TO
MAINTAINING A VITAL WELL
PREPARED MARK NURSING WORKFORCE
FOR THESE REASONS HA AND IT'S
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH OF THE
MEMBERS THE PORT EIGHTY TWO TWO
EIGHT EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS AND
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MODERATOR LET'S- ASK IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IF THERE ARE ANY ME PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
WELL FIRST THE LINE OF ONE
EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
ON THE INTERESTS OF THE SAME
WITH LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA I
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT MAKING
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT ONE
EXPRESS OUR- GRATITUDE AND
SUPPORT FOR. YOU HELPING- GAIN
MORE NURSES INTO THAT SYSTEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OR GOING
OUT TO LINE ONE EIGHT ZERO ONE
EIGHTY YEAR LINES OPEN. A GOOD
AFTERNOON AIR POCKET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM PROUD TO BE AN SUPPORT
AND APPRECIATE- THIS A MOMENT
WAS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE EIGHT
THREE ONE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
VERY CLEAN IT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS
AT FRESNO STATE. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT I WANT TO THANK YOU OFFER
CORRECT LEADERSHIP AND FOR THE
SUPPORT BAR FUTURE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
NINE ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE FORTY NINE.
GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
ONE. ONE EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS DOCTOR DANIEL
MAN ON THE CARE THAT SACRAMENTO
STATE SCHOOL OF NURSING AND I'M
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN ONE EIGHT SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SHERRY
GOLDFARB TEAM OF HEALTH
SCIENCES COLLEGE OF MARIN AND
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATION OF ASSOCIATE
DEGREE NURSING PROGRAMS NORTH I
AM IN STRONG AND FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE ONE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON ERIC
RECKLESS WITH THE UNION- YOU
KNOW WE'RE IN SUPPORT AND
CAUGHT. UP THE CONCEPT- WE
STILL HAVE SOME. DISCUSSIONS
WILL BE HAVING WITH. STAFF AND
THE AUTHOR OF THAT WE
APPRECIATE BREAKING THIS
IMPORTANT. ISSUE OUR BECAUSE
THERE IS A NEED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE EIGHTY TWO ONE EIGHT
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHO MATT
WAS A FROM CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THE SPELL WITH ONE OF THE
GOVERNMENT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
IT STOPPED HER THINKING A LEAD
ON THIS ISSUE AND- CONTINUE TO
LOOK FOR THE CAN. PRODUCTIVE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR
ONE EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS RYAN ACCORDING TO THE
COMMUNITY LIKE A CALIFORNIA-
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
LINES IN SUPPORT IN PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ALL. AND THERE ARE
NO FURTHER LINES IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU MODERATE IF
YOU'D MOVE TO- ANYBODY WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. YES
MISTER CHAIR BY CHAIR MEMBERS
CURSE FLANK THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ARE PROFICIENT. WE'RE
NOT OPPOSED OR SUPPORTING A. B.
PORT EIGHTY EIGHT. BUT THE
MINUTE THE LETTER CONCERN AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
START AND FROM THERE WE ALSO
FREE SHE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS AS WELL YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO REACH OUT TO US.
FOR CALM AND BE BACK WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES THE LEGISLATURE
IS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO THIS
NURSING STUDENTS IN ADDRESSING
THE HOSPITAL CREATE CRISIS. WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
NECESSARY NARROW AND TIME LIMIT
BUT STOP OPTIMAL ALTERNATIVE TO
DIRECT PATIENT CARE WHICH IS
RATIONAL. UNDER SPICES
CONDITIONS IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF NURSING STUDENTS
WHO BUT FOR THE ACTIONS OF
HOSPITALS. WITH A GRADUATE OUR
PROGRESS IN THEIR PROGRAM. CNA
NURSES ARE SUPERVISED THE
PROVISION OF CARE BY STUDENTS
DURING THE CLINICAL ROTATION WE
BELIEVE TO THE NURSES AREN'T
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF PATIENT
CARE. SERVICES AND IT IS
IMPORTANT NOT TO UNDERVALUE THE
CONTRIBUTION VESTED IN CAN MAY
TO PACE CARE YOU HAVE SOME
SPACE THIS PENSION. STREET
HISTORIC OPPOSE REPLACING
DIRECT PATIENT CARE CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE WITH BILLS
LABORATORY LEARNING THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED MACHEN CANNOT
READ REPLICATE THAT YOU
RESPONSE TO NURSING CARE. OR
INDICATE THE SUBTLE CHANGES
THAT OCCUR THAT CAN OCCUR
DURING THE COURSE OF AN
ILLNESS. STOP THE PATIENT MADE
AND KNOWLEDGE ACQUIRED DURING
CLINICAL TRAINING OR THE
BEGINNING OF A BATHROOM ON THE
BEACH. THE LEARNING THERE'S
GOING TO BE NEEDED TO PROVIDE
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE DIRECT CARE
DIRECT CARE ISN'T IN HOSPITALS
CLINICS AND COMMUNITY SETTING.
SEE NAY BELIEVES PART
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC RECORD
DIRECT PATIENT CARE EXPERIENCE
WE WORRY ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
FOR REDUCE CLINICAL COMPETENCY.
ALSO IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF STATE
BOARDS OF NURSING STIMULATION
STUDY THAT IS OFTEN CITED BY
PROPONENT OF INCREASE. SIMILAR
XIN HAD BEEN STRUCK OUT OF THE
STUDY. AND THOSE STUDENTS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY STUDENTS
FROM MINORITY GROUPS AND
RETURNING VETERANS. YEAH HAVE
HAD CONCERNS YOU THE EXPERT
GROWTH OF PRIVATE NURSING FOR.
AND IN THE PAST SOME PRIVATE.
TO THE PROPONENT OF APRS
DECREASED THE DIRECT PATIENT.
CLINICAL HOURS AND INCREASED IN
RELATION. IN A CONCERNED
PRIVATE NURSE PRO. WILL BE TO
PICK UP. INCREASINGLY MORE SO
IN A PUBLIC NURSING PROGRAM
COUNTERPOINT. WE HAVE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS THAT IN SHORT THE
BILL CLINTON'S ARE CARRIED OUT.
HI LINK TO BE ABLE. IF
INCREDIBLE OFFER AND THAT ARE
MOST RAP REFLECT OF THE DC
WAIVERS MOMENTO TO SPECIFIC
SECTIONS OF TITLE SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS TODAY. THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PLANNED WITNESSES STRUCTURE.
SCUTTLED RATHER. OR SHOULD WE
OPEN IT TO THE PUBLIC LET'S
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC. THANK YOU
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. UGH I
GUESS- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD THIS HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE IN MYDISTRICT AS YOU
HEARD FROM THE FIRST SPEAKER-
SOME VERY DISTRAUGHT NURSING
STUDENTS SO- I WOULD LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR BECAUSE
THIS IS GOING TO SOLVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS. THANK YOU INITIAL
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK.
SEEING NONE. MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU LIKE CLOTHES THERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE IT'S BEEN A MOTION AND
SECOND COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWO TWO EIGHT
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS FOR
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI. LOW HI
BRO HI. I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHAN. CHAN I
TO. TWO I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FONG. FUN
I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA
LAURIE I GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN WHEN I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
EIGHTEEN VOTES THE BILL ISN'T
PAID THE BILL IS OUT ON LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL NOW GO THROUGH
AND FALL ORDER. AGAIN AS A
POINT OF REFERENCE THERE ARE
TWO BILLS ON CALL THAT IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B. THIRTY
TO THIRTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU. AS WELL AS ANOTHER
BILL ON CALL FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE A. B. THIRTY THREE
THIRTY. SO AGAIN WILL BEGIN AND
FOLLOW ORDER. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. BRO BRO I
ARAMBULA RANDALL I BLOOM BLOOM
AYE CHIU CHIU AYE FONG. FUN I
GLORIA. LARA AYE MULLIN. MULLIN
AYE TING. THE ROSARIO. THE BILL
IS OUT. NEXT AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTIONS TO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS BRO I
BLOOM. WE MIGHT. TO CHIU AYE
FONG. FUN NOT VOTING GLORIA.
GLORIA I AM MULLIN. HIS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KOREA. MULLIN I OBTAIN.
THE BILL IS OUT. APOLOGIZE
HOSTED OF ALSO WANT TO MENTION
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE IS
ALSO ON CALL HOLDEN. I NEXT
ENEMIES AB THIRTY TO THIRTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. BRO
BROWN NOW BLOOM. BLOOM I TO AYE
FONG. FONG NO GLORIA. NUMBER IN
A BURNING WHEN WE'RE NOT VOTING
MULLIN. ONE NINE TING. A TING
IS HI. FROM. ABOLISHED ON CALL
CAPABILITY THE BILL IS STILL ON
CALL AND THEN MOVING ON TO
FODDER FOR. NEXT BILL IS AB
THREE ZERO ONE SIX I SOME
MEMBER DOLLY. MOTIONS TO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS BLOOM. BLOOM I TO.
CHIU AYE GLORIA LARA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TEAM. IT CONVERTS
THE BILL ISN'T. AND THEN
BECAUSE WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
ANNOUNCE THE FINAL VOTE ANSWER
GO THROUGH ALL THESE AS WELL.
AT THE END. NEXT ITEM IS AB TWO
FOUR SIX ZERO BY SOME A MEMBER
DALY EMOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM. BLOOM I
TO. TWO I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I. EGGMAN. GLORIA GLORIA I'M
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE TING.
SEVENTEEN VEGETABLES ON. NEXT
ITEM IS AB TWO FIVE NINE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA THE
MOTIONS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I TO
TWO I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING. SIXTEEN VOTES
THAT BILL IS OUT. NEXT BILL IS
AB THREE ZERO FOUR FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I AM BLOOM.
BLOOM I TO YOU AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I GLORIA GLORIA I AM
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE TING.
EIGHTEEN BUT SETTLES OUT. NEXT
BILL IS AB TWO ONE NINE NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS AREA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ARAMBULA HI
BLOOM. BLOOM I TO. TO DO NOT
VOTING CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
AYE EGGMAN US EXCUSE ME GLORIA.
I THANK YOU MULLIN. MON I TING
TING HI. EIGHTEEN VOTES LEVEL
IS OUT. NEXT BILL IS AB THREE
THREE THREE ZERO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM. BLOOM I
TO. TWO I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE EGGMAN. GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GLORIA GLORIA I'M MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING. TING I. TWELVE
VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT. NEXT
BILL IS A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
MOTIONS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM. BLOOM I
TO. CHIU AYE FONG. FONG NOT
VOTING MULLIN. MULLIN I TING
CAN I. SIXTEEN VEGETABLE IS OUT.
NEXT BILL IS AB TWO ONE TWO TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRO. ROBAINA
BLOOM. BLOOM I TO. CHIU AYE
EGGMAN. FONG. FINE I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING TING I.
EIGHTEEN VOTES THE BILL ISN'T.
NEXT IS AB TWO TWO SEVEN THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO. CHIU AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE TING.
NINETEEN VEGETABLES OUT. NEXT
IS AB TWO ONE FIVE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I TO CHIU AYE EGGMAN.
IRWIN WHEN I MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE. TING. SEVENTEEN
VOTES THE BILL IS OUT. NEXT IS
ASSEMBLY BELT TO NINETY EIGHT
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAN. CHEN NOT
VOTING TO NOT VOTING CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO GLORIA. GLORIA I
IRWIN. THIS IS AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY THREE BY SOMEONE NUMBER
HOLDEN WHEN NOT VOTING MULLIN.
MULLIN I TING. TING I. THE
BILLS ON CALL THE OF A AT NINE
VOTES WILL KEEP IT ON CALL.
NEXT BILL IS AB NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS CHAN. CHEN NOT
VOTING TO. CHIU AYE EGGMAN.
GLORIA. GLORIA I. TING TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FOURTEEN VOTES
THAT BILL IS OUT. NEXT BILL IS
AB TWO ONE ONE THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW THE MOTION
IS TO PASS YOUR PREPARATIONS
CHEN. GEN UPLOADING TO AYE
EGGMAN. GLORIA GLORIA I
EIGHTEEN TEN I. FIFTEEN VOTES
THAT BILL IS OUT. FINAL BILL IS
AB TWO TWO EIGHT EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
TING. TING HI THE BILL HAS
NINETEEN BOOKS THAT BILL IS. SO.
COLLEAGUES WERE JUST GOING TO
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES TO
ALLOW FOR ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. YEAH.
CONTENT FILE TING I. AB TWO
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT TEN I. AB
THREE ZERO ONE SIX. DALY AS OUR
TING. TING I. AB TWO FOUR SIX
ZERO DALY TING I. AB TWO FIVE
NINE TWO GARCIA TING TING AYE.
AB THREE ZERO FOUR FIVE GRAY
TING TING AYE.
CONFIRMING AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE-
HOLDEN MCCARTY HI YEAH. THEY
DID ALL THE OTHER. AB TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY THREE HOLDEN. THAT
HAS TEN VOTES THE BILL IS OUT.
A VOTE CHANGE A. B. THIRTY TO
THIRTY FIVE. GIPSON I TO NOT
VOTING.
ERNEST SECTOR I THINK
WE JUST HAVE A ONE ADDITIONAL
BILL ON CALL THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB EIGHT THIRTY TO
THIRTY FIVE. AB THIRTY TO
THIRTY FIVE OF A CHANGE COR.
HAVE TO SPEAK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND IS COMMITTED TO AMEND HIS
BILL TO ADDRESS THE
RETROACTIVITY OF THIS PROVISION
OF A LOT. FOREVER CHANGE NOT
VOTING TO I. THE SECTOR. THE
TOTAL. THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES
THAT MEASURE FAILS. OKAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BEEN RETURNED.